.
%%%JENSTART.
THIS IS A TEST.  RISCHI
MONTHLY
ACTIVE USER:  ACTIVE USER.
USER.
TECH
MAKERS.
TOR NORBYE.
Tor Norbye:
ESPECIALLY
ESPECIALLY.
Ellie Powers:   ELLIE.  ELLIE
POWERS.
PSSST!
[ MUSIC ]
[ CHEERS AND APPLAUSE ]
Jason Titus:  HI, EVERYONE.
I'M
JASON, AND I RUN OUR DEVELOPER
PRODUCT GROUP HERE AT GOOGLE.
AND IT IS SO GREAT TO BE BACK
AT
SHORELINE AGAIN THIS YEAR.  AND
FOR THOSE OF YOU JOINING OUR
VIA
400 I/O EXTENDED SESSIONS
ACROSS
85 COUNTRIES AS WELL AS YOU
JOINING OVER THE LIVESTREAM,
THANK YOU AND
WELCOME.
EARLIER SUNDAR TALKED ABOUT OUR
VARIOUS BILLION-USER PLATFORMS.
AND WHETHER IT'S ANDROID OR THE
WEB THROUGH CHROME, OUR SUCCESS
HERE WOULD NOT BE POSSIBLE
WITHOUT YOU.  SO WE'RE GOING TO
SPEND THE NEXT HALF AN HOUR
DIVING DEEP INTO OUR EXACTLY
WHAT WE'RE DOING FOR ALL OF
YOU,
THE DEVELOPERS WHO BUILD ON OUR
PLATFORMS EVERY DAY.
[ CHEERS AND APPLAUSE ]
AND NO MATTER WHAT PLATFORM
YOU'RE BUILDING ON, OUR GOAL IS
TO MAKE YOUR JOB EASIER AND
ALLOW YOU TO FOCUS ON THE
PROBLEM YOU'RE TRYING TO SOLVE
BY MINIMIZING THE PAIN POINTS
OF
BUILDING A PRODUCT.
WE WANT TO SIMPLIFY REPETITIVE
TASKS, WHETHER THAT MEANS
DEALING WITH USER LOGIN OR
INSTRUMENTING ANALYTICS OR INC.
SYNCHRONIZING REALTIME DATA, WE
WANT TO GIVE YOU THE TOOLS TO
MAKE IT EASY FOR YOU TO SOLVE
EVERYDAY PROBLEMS IN SIMPLE AND
POWERFUL WAYS, AS WELL AS
CREATE
ENTIRELY NEW PRODUCTS USING
TECHNOLOGIES LIKE MACHINE
LEARNING AND VR AND
VOICE-ENABLED INTERACTIONS.
IT IS IMPORTANT TO US THAT YOU
ARE SUCCESSFUL.  SO IN ADDITION
TO BEING -- BUILDING PRODUCTS
THAT HELP YOU BUILD YOUR APPS,
WE ARE ALSO ON THE GROUND IN
OVER 130 COUNTRIES WITH
PROGRAMS
LIKE WOMEN TECH MAKERS AND THE
GOOGLE DEVELOPER GROUPS.
[ CHEERS AND APPLAUSE
]
MANY OF WHOM ARE HERE TODAY.
(CHANTING).
SO I BELIEVE WE HAVE GDDs FROM
79 COUNTRIES HERE TODAY.  SO
THAT'S PRETTY EXCITING.
[ CHEERS AND APPLAUSE ]
SO WE'RE ALSO INVESTING IN
TRAINING PROGRAMS, LIKE GOOGLE
DEVELOPER CERTIFICATIONS AND
COURSES THROUGH UDACITY AND
OTHER PARTNERS TO HELP YOU
DEEPEN YOUR TECHNOLOGICAL
CAPABILITIES.
AND FROM THIS WORK AROUND THE
WORLD, WE'RE SEEING FIRSTHAND
THAT DEVELOPERS ARE AT THE
FOREFRONT OF TECHNOLOGICAL AND
CHANGE INNOVATION.
WE SEE YOU SOLVING CHALLENGING
PROBLEMS IN WAYS THAT COULD NOT
BE DONE BEFORE.  FOR EXAMPLE,
LAST YEAR ON A TRIP TO
INDONESIA, I MET GIBRAN
HUZAIFAH
HUZAIFAH.  HAVING WATCHED
AQUACULTURE BECOME AN
INCREASINGLY IMPORTANT PART OF
HIS COUNTRY'S ECONOMY, HE LEFT
A
CAREER IN BIOLOGY TO BECOME ONE
OF THE NATION'S 3.5 BILLION
FISH
FARMERS.  WHAT HE FOUND WAS A
400-YEAR-OLD TRADE THAT WAS
MIRED IN INEFFICIENCY WHERE
FARMERS WERE FREQUENTLY OVER OR
UNDERFEEDING THEIR FISH.  WITH
HIS CO-FOUNDER MUHAMMAD, THEY
DECIDED THEY COULD HELP AND
THEY
STARTED eFISHRY WHICH PROVIDES
A SMART AUTOMATED FISH FEEDER
WHICH CAN SENSE WHEN FISH ARE
HUNGRY AND FEED THEM.  AS A
RESULT THEY CAN SAVE THE
FARMERS
UP TO 20% OF THEIR ANNUAL COST
AS WELL AS REDUCING HARMFUL
ENVIRONMENTAL RUN-OFF.  AND
THIS
IS JUST ONE OF MANY STORIES OF
HOW OUR GLOBAL DEVELOPER
COMMUNITY IS MAKING AN IMPACT
IN
UNEXPECTED
WAYS.
NOW, I WOULD LIKE TO BRING UP
SOME COLLEAGUES TO GIVE UPDATES
ACROSS OUR DEVELOPER PLATFORMS.
WE'RE
DOING TO MAKE ANDROID
DEVELOPMENT EASIER.  PLEASE
WELCOME STEPH.
[ CHEERS AND APPLAUSE ]
Stephanie Saad Cuthbertson:
AS
SUNDAR AND DAVE SAID, WITH
2 BILLION ACTIVE DEVICES ON
ANDROID AND 82 BILLION APPS
INSTALLED FROM PLAY, ANDROID'S
MOMENTUM IS AMAZING.  WHAT I
LIKE EVEN MORE IS HOW ANDROID'S
MOMENTUM IS MAKING SO MANY
DEVELOPERS SUCCESSFUL.  THE
NUMBER OF DEVELOPERS WITH OVER
A
MILLION INSTALLS GREW 35% JUST
IN THE PAST YEAR.  AND WE'RE
MAKING IT EASIER TO GROW
REVENUE, TOO.  IN ADDITION TO
CREDIT CARDS, GIFT CARDS,
EVERYTHING ELSE, WE'VE EXPANDED
DIRECT CARRIER BILLING TO REACH
900 MILLION DEVICES WITH 140
OPERATORS.  ALTOGETHER, THE
NUMBER OF PEOPLE BUYING ON PLAY
GREW BY ALMOST 30% IN THE PAST
YEAR.
NOW, TO SUPPORT THIS VAST
ECOSYSTEM, WE'RE WORKING HARD
TO
HELP DEVELOPERS BUILD GREAT
APPS
AT EVERY STAGE, WRITING YOUR
APP, TUNING, AND GROWING YOUR
BUSINESS.  TODAY, WE'LL WALK
THROUGH FOUR BIG THEMES.  THE
FIRST IS LANGUAGES.
[ CHEERS AND APPLAUSE ]
NEXT IS MAKING ANDROID
DEVELOPMENT FASTER AND EASIER
WITH THE IDE AND LIBRARIES.
THIRD, WE'LL SHOW YOU EVEN MORE
TOOLS TO BUILDING HIGH-QUALITY
EXPERIENCES.  FINALLY, WE WANT
TO HELP YOU GROW AND REACH NEW
USERS, LEVERAGING ANDROID
INSTANT APPS.  SO LET'S GO
STRAIGHT IN.
WE HAVE BEEN SO EXCITED TO
ANNOUNCE FIRST-CLASS SUPPORT
FOR
KOTLIN.
[ CHEERS AND APPLAUSE ]
THIS STARTS NOW.  IN ANDROID
STUDIO, KOTLIN SUPPORT IS NOW
BUILT IN.  WE'LL SUPPORT
BUILDING APPS WITH AS MUCH
KOTLIN AS YOU WANT, FROM ZERO
TO
100%.  NOW, ALL OF YOU OF WHO
AN
SITTEN CODE IN KOTLIN KNOW WHY
WE DID THIS ALREADY.  BUT FOR
EVERYONE, WE DID IT BECAUSE
KOTLIN IS A BEAUTIFUL
PROGRAMMING LANGUAGE.  WE ASKED
ONE GOOGLER HOW HE FELT AFTER
WRITING KOTLIN FOR A COUPLE OF
WEEKS.  "WELL, I WOULD NEVER
EMBARRASSED ADAM POWELL BY
USING
HIS NAME ON STAGE, HE SAID, I
THINK I AM IN LOVE."
[ LAUGHTER ]
SO MANY OF YOU TOLD ME KOTLIN
MAKES PROGRAMMING FUN AGAIN,
WITH SO MANY WONDERFUL FEATURES
LIKE YOU'RE GOING TO SEE HERE
AND TOR WILL SHOW YOU MORE IN
JUST A MOMENT.  AS DEVELOPERS,
LANGUAGES ARE THE TOOLS WE USE
TO EXPRESS OUR THOUGHTS.  WITH
KOTLIN, THERE'S JUST SO MUCH
LESS SYNTACTIC NOISE THAT
STANDS
BETWEEN WHAT I WANT TO SAY AND
HOW I SAY IT.
NOW, FOR THOSE OF YOU WHO ARE
WONDERING WHAT THIS MAY MEAN
FOR
THE JAVA PROGRAMMING LANGUAGE
AND CPU
C+PLUS, WE ARENESS ENHANCING
OUR EXISTING LANGUAGES.  FOR
INSTANCE, IN ANDROID STUDIO,
JAVA 8 FEATURES ARE NOW
DIRECTLY
SUPPORTED WITH THE JAVAC
COMPILER.  AND WE HAVE ADDED
MORE JAVA 8 LANGUAGE APIs IN
O.  SO IF YOU WISH, YOU CAN
IGNORE KOTLIN COMPLETELY AND
YOUR EXISTING LANGUAGE SUPPORT
WILL KEEP GETTING BETTER.
BUT...
[ APPLAUSE ]
IF YOU CAN'T WAIT TO GET
STARTED
WITH KOTLIN, IT IS INCREDIBLY
EASY.  KOTLIN WORKS 100% WITH
THE JAVA PROGRAMMING LANGUAGE,
WHICH MEANS IT IS COMPLETELY
INTEROPERABLE.  THAT MEANS YOU
CAN KEEP EVERY LINE OF CODE IN
YOUR EXISTING PROJECT.  YOU CAN
SEAMLESSLY CALL FROM KOTLIN
INTO
THE JAVA PROGRAMMING LANGUAGE
AND BACK WHICH MEANS IT IS VERY
EASY TO GET STARTED.  YOU CAN
ADD AS LITTLE AS A SINGLE
KOTLIN
CLASS.
ANOTHER REASON WHY KOTLIN IS
SUCH AN AMAZING FIT FOR ANDROID
IS IT'S MATURE AND
PRODUCT-READY.  KOTLIN HAS BEEN
AROUND FOR FIVE YEARS, AND
MAJOR
APPS LIKE FLIPBOARD, PINTEREST,
SQUARE CASH, EXPEDIA, AND MORE
ARE ALL USING KOTLIN IN
PRODUCTION.  NOW, KOTLIN'S NOT
JUST A GREAT LANGUAGE.  IT HAS
OUTSTANDING IDE SUPPORT.  THE
TEAM THAT BROUGHT YOU KOTLIN IS
THE SAME TEAM BEHIND INTELLIJ
WHICH AS YOU KNOW IS WHAT
POWERS
ANDROID STUDIO, OUR IDE.
FINALLY, ANDROID HAS COMMITTED
TO KOTLIN AS A FIRST-CLASS
LANGUAGE AND AS YOU HEARD,
WE'RE
ANNOUNCING OUR PLANS TO PARTNER
WITH JETBRAINS TO MOVE CLOTH
INTO A NON-PROFIT FOUNDATION --
KOTLIN INTO A NON-PROFIT
FOUNDATION.  KOTLIN IS OPEN
SOURCED UNDER
APACHE 2.  WE LOVE
HOW IT FITS.AROUND OUR
COMMUNITY.  NOW TOR WOULD LOVE
TO SHOW YOU KOTLIN IN ACTION.
SO, TOR.
[ CHEERS AND APPLAUSE ]
Tor Norbye:  THANKS, STEPH.
SO HERE'S A PRETTY TYPICAL DATA
CLASS WITH THREE PROPERTIES
IMPLEMENTED IN JAVA.  AS YOU
CAN
SEE, THERE'S A LOT OF
BOILERPLATE CODE HERE WITH
FIELDS, GETTERS, SET
QUESTIONERS, HASH CODES,
ET CETERA.  LET'S LOOK AT HOW
WE
WOULD IMPLEMENT THIS IN KOTLIN.
AND NOW I'M GOING TO WRITE THE
EQUIVALENT KOTLIN CODE.  HERE'S
THE FIRST LINE.
AND THAT IS ALSO THE LAST LINE.
THIS CODE --
[ CHEERS AND APPLAUSE ]
THIS CODE IS COMPLETELY
EQUIVALENT TO THE 87 LINES I
JUST DELETED.  THE COMPILER
DOES
ALL THE WORK.  IT GENERATES THE
SAME CODE AS BEFORE PLUS SOME
EXTRA GOODIES.  SO FROM JAVA, I
CAN CALL INTO MY NEW KOTLIN
CLASS AND ACCESS THE SAME
GETTERS AS BEFORE.  BUT LOOK
WHAT HAPPENS IN KOTLIN.  HERE
WE
HAVE A REALLY NICE PROPERTY
SYNTAX, SO I CAN, FOR EXAMPLE,
USE ASSIGNMENT TO ASSIGN TO
THIS
PROPERTY INSTEAD OF CALLING A
SETTER.
NOW, AS YOU ARE STARTING OUT
WITH KOTLIN, YOU MIGHT FIND
YOURSELF STUCK REALIZING YOU
DON'T KNOW HOW TO DO SOMETHING.
IMAGE PROCESSING AND I REALIZE
THAT I DON'T KNOW HOW TO
DECLARE
TWO-DIMENSIONAL ARRAY.  WELL,
WHAT I CAN DO IS OPEN UP A JAVA
FILE, WRITE THE CODE IN JAVA,
WHICH I KNOW HOW TO DO, GO BACK
TO KOTLIN, AND LOOK WHAT
HAPPENS
WHEN I PASTE.  THAT'S RIGHT,
THE
IDE CONVERTS IT FOR ME.
[ CHEERS AND APPLAUSE ]
IT'S A HUGE HELP WHEN YOU'RE
STARTING OUT.  SO AS STEPH CAN
ATTEST, I CAN LITERALLY SET FOR
THREE HOURS AND TELL YOU ALL
THE
THINGS I LOVE ABOUT KOTLIN.  WE
DON'T HAVE TIME FOR THEM.
INSTEAD I WOULD ENCOURAGE THEM
ALL TO COME TO OUR EXCELLENT
TALKS ON FRIDAY WHERE YOU LEARN
EVERYTHING YOU NEED TO KNOW TO
GET STARTED WITH KOTLIN.  I
HOPE
YOU WILL LOVE CODING IN KOTLIN
AS MUCH AS I DO.
Stephanie Saad Cuthbertson:
THANKS, TOR.
[ CHEERS AND APPLAUSE ]
FOR US ON ANDROID, ADDING
KOTLIN
FEELS LIKE A MOMENT IN  HISTORY.
WE'RE EXCITED TODAY.  IT'S  JUST
THE BEGINNING, THOUGH.   WE'RE
EVEN MORE EXCITED ABOUT  THE
POSSIBILITIES THAT KOTLIN
CREATES FOR THE FUTURE.
BUT THERE'S MORE.
OUR SECOND THEME IS MAKING
DEVELOPMENT FASTER AND EASIER
WITH OUR TOOLS AND LIBRARIES.
ANDROID STUDIO'S OUR OFFICIAL
IDE.  IT IS PURPOSE-BUILT FOR
ANDROID.  AND WE KEEP
INCREASING
INVESTMENT.
TODAY, WE'RE RELEASING  ANDROID
STUDIO 3.0'S FIRST  CANARY,
FOCUSING ON SPEED AND  SMARTS
AND
ANDROID PLATFORM  SUPPORT, PLUS
NEW LIBRARIES  FOR APP
ARCHITECTURE.
SO LET'S GO STRAIGHT TO A  DEMO.
THIS IS MORE FUN.
ALL RIGHT.  SO HERE I HAVE
ANDROID STUDIO 3.0.  AND I'VE
JUST BUILT AND DEPLOYED MY  APP.
PROFILERS, CPU,  MEMORY, AND
NETWORK.
SO I'M JUST GOING TO OPEN THE
APP.
AND LET ME DO A LITTLE BIT OF
NETWORK HERE SO YOU CAN SEE  IT
ON THE GRAPH.
WHAT YOU CAN SEE IS THE  NETWORK
PROFILER.  AND IT'S  REALLY COOL
THAT YOU CAN SEE  ALL OF THE
REQUESTS.  BUT  PARTICULARLY
COOL
WOULD BE IF  YOU COULD CLICK AND
SEE THE  ACTUAL PAYLOAD OF THE
REQUEST.
EVEN BETTER THAN THAT WOULD  BE
IF YOU COULD LOOK AND SEE  THE
HEADERS.  BUT I ACTUALLY  THINK
IT WOULD BE VERY COOL  IF YOU
COULD CLICK ON THE  CALL STACK
AND SELECT AND GO  TO THE LINE
OF
CODE.
[ CHEERS AND APPLAUSE ]
SO THOSE ARE THE THREE NEW
PROFILERS.  3.0 ALSO INCLUDES  A
PREVIEW FEATURE FOR  DEBUGGING
ANY APK, SO YOU CAN  BUILD IN
ANY
IDE AND DEBUG IN  ANDROID
STUDIO,
INCLUDING  USING THESE PROFILERS
FOR  JAVA CODE.
SO TO SAY MORE ON SPEED AND
SMARTS, YOUR FEEDBACK HAS  MADE
DRIVING DOWN SYNC AND  BUILD
TIME
OUR NUMBER-ONE  PRIORITY.
BENCHMARKING WITH  A REAL-LIFE,
100-MODULE  PROJECT SINCE 2.2,
THE BUILD  CONFIG TIME HAS
DROPPED FROM  THREE MINUTES DOWN
TO TWO  SECONDS, AND WE WILL
KEEP
WORKING ON BUILD SPEED.
ON THE EMULATORS, WE'VE ADDED
PLAY STORE FOR END-TO-END
TESTING.  AND THERE'S SO MUCH
MORE HERE.
THE NEXT THING I WANT TO TALK
ABOUT IS ANDROID PLATFORM
SUPPORT.
YOU WILL FIND AWESOME  FEATURES
FOR ANDROID AND O,  LIKE
END-TO-END INSTANT APPS
SUPPORT,
O SYSTEM IMAGES, AND  TONS OF
HELPER TOOLS.
FOR INSTANCE, DAVE TALKED  ABOUT
ADAPTIVE ICONS, WHICH  WE ALL
NEED TO BUILD NOW.  SO  OUR TEAM
HAS BUILT TOOLS THAT  MAKE THAT
EASY.
AND ONE OF MY PERSONAL  FAVORITE
FEATURES IS TO  DOWNLOAD ANDROID
DEPENDENCIES  FOR BUILD, YOU
DON'T HAVE TO  GO THROUGH THE
ANDROID SDK  MANAGER ANYMORE.
WE'RE NOW  DISTRIBUTING THROUGH
OUR OWN  MAVEN REPOSITORY.
[ CHEERS AND APPLAUSE ]
FINALLY, YOU HAVE ASKED US TO
MAKE ANDROID FRAMEWORKS  EASIER,
LIKE PROVIDING AN  OPINIONATED
GUIDE TO BEST  PRACTICES OR A
BETTER WAY OF  DEALING WITH LIFE
CYCLES.
WE'RE LAUNCHING A PREVIEW OF
NEW
ARCHITECTURE COMPONENTS,
LIBRARIES FOR COMMON TASKS.
THIS STARTS WITH LIBRARIES  FOR
THE VIEW MODEL PATTERN,  DATA
STORAGE, AND MANAGING  ACTIVITY
AND FRAGMENT LIFE  CYCLES.
WE WOULD LOVE IF YOU WOULD
DOWNLOAD AND TRY ALL OF THIS
TODAY.
NOW, AS WE MOVE FROM CODING
OVER
INTO HOW TO TUNE YOUR  QUALITY
AND GROW, I'D LIKE  YOU TO HEAR
FROM ELLIE  POWERS.
PLEASE WELCOME ELLIE.
THANK YOU.
[ APPLAUSE ]
Ellie Powers:  THANK YOU,
STEFTDZ.
AS ALL OF YOU KNOW, BUILDING  A
SUCCESSFUL BUSINESS ON PLAY
STARTS WITH A HIGH-QUALITY  APP.
AND YOU'VE TOLD US THAT
SOMETIMES YOU NEED TO TARGET
THE
RIGHT DEVICES IN ORDER TO
ENSURE
THE BEST USER  EXPERIENCE.
SO WE'RE MAKING IT EASIER TO
UNDERSTAND ANDROID'S DEVICES
AND
TARGET THEM IN THE PLAY
CONSOLE.
NOW YOU CAN BROWSE A DETAILED
DEVICE CATALOGUE, NO MORE
SEARCHING FOR SPECS ONE  DEVICE
AT A TIME.
IF YOU NEED A CERTAIN AMOUNT  OF
RAM OR YOU HAVE A PROBLEM  WITH
A
SPECIFIC SYSTEM ON A  CHIP, YOU
CAN NOW SET  TARGETING RULES TO
ADDRESS  THAT.
BEFORE EXCLUDING DEVICES, YOU
CAN EVEN SEE YOUR INSTALLS,
RATING, AND REVENUE PER  DEVICE.
NOW, ENSURING QUALITY
EXPERIENCES REALLY MATTERS.
THE
PLAY TEAM TOOK A SAMPLE  OF APPS
AND ANALYZED THE  CORRELATION
BETWEEN APP  QUALITY AND
BUSINESS
SUCCESS.
WHEN APPS MOVE FROM AVERAGE  TO
GOOD QUALITY, WE SAW AN  AMAZING
SIXFOLD INCREASE IN  SPEND, AND
A
SEVEN HELPFOLD  INCREASE IN
RETENTION.  THAT  IS PHENOMENAL.
WE ARE ALWAYS LOOKING FOR NEW
WAYS TO BRING USERS TO YOUR
APPS, AND INSTANT APPS IS OUR
BIG BET IN THIS AREA.
LAST YEAR, WE PROVED ANDROID
INSTANT APPS.  INSTANT APPS
ALLOWS YOU TO EXPERIENCE
EVERYTHING YOU LOVE ABOUT  APPS,
BUT WITHOUT THE HURDLE  OF
INSTALLATION.
SINCE THEN, WE'VE BEEN  WORKING
WITH PARTNERS TO  REFINE THE
PRODUCT.  THEY  HAVE LAUCHED 50
INSTANT APPS,  FROM IMMERSIVE
VIDEO WITH  VIMEO TO MOBILE
COMMERCE WITH  JET, TO
APARTMENT-HUNTING  WITH HOTPADS.
AND WHILE IT'S STILL EARLY
DAYS,
DEVELOPERS ARE  REPORTING
POSITIVE RESULTS.   FOR EXAMPLE,
JET, HOTPADS,  AND VIMEO ARE
SEEING  DOUBLE-DIGIT INCREASES
IN
PURCHASES, LEADS GENERATED,  AND
VIDEOS WATCHED.
SO TODAY, WE ARE OPENING UP
ANDROID INSTANT APPS TO ALL
ANDROID DEVELOPERS.  THIS  MEANS
ANYONE --
[ APPLAUSE ]
THANK YOU.
THIS MEANS ANYONE CAN NOW  BUILD
AND PUBLISH AN INSTANT  APP.
FEEDBACK FROM OUR PARTNERS  HAS
SHAPED THE DEVELOPMENT  TOOLS
THAT WE'RE MAKING  AVAILABLE TO
ALL ANDROID  DEVELOPERS TODAY.
LET'S TAKE A LOOK.
YOU BUILD INSTANT APPS IN
ANDROID STUDIO 3.0.  MANY OF
YOU
WONDERED IF BUILDING AN  INSTANT
APP MEANS MAINTAINING  TWO FORKS
OF YOUR CODE;  RIGHT?
THE ANSWER IS NO.
YOU CAN USE EXACTLY THE SAME
CODE FOR YOUR INSTANT APP AND
YOUR INSTALLABLE APP.
YOUR INSTANT APP IS  DOWNLOADED
AS NEEDED, FEATURE  BY FEATURE.
SO YOU'LL  ORGANIZE YOUR PROJECT
INTO  FEATURE MODULES AND THEN
USE  THAT CODE IN BOTH YOUR
INSTANT APP AND YOUR
INSTALLABLE
APP.
NOW, WE KNOW REFACTORING YOUR
APP INTO FEATURES CAN  SOMETIMES
BE A BIT OF A PAIN,  SO WE'RE
PROVIDING TOOLS TO  EASE THE
PROCESS.
FOR EXAMPLE, THE NEW  MODULIZED
REFACTORING ACTION  HELPS YOU
MOVE CODE AND  RESOURCES BETWEEN
MODULES.
EVERY APP IS DIFFERENT, BUT
WE'VE SEEN WITH OUR EARLY
PARTNERS THAT INSTANT APP
DEVELOPMENT TYPICALLY TAKES
ABOUT FOUR TO SIX WEEKS WITH
THE
LATEST TOOLS.
AS YOU ALL KNOW, THE FASTER
YOUR
PRODUCT IS, THE MORE  USAGE
YOU'LL GET.  SO YOU'LL  WANT
EACH
MODULE TO LOAD AS  QUICKLY AS
POSSIBLE.  WE'RE  PROVIDING
OPTIMIZATION TOOLS,  FROM
SPACE-SAVING SHARED  LIBRARIES,
TO MORE EFFICIENT  ASSET
DELIVERY, TO  ON-THE-WIRE
COMPRESSION.
AND WHEN YOU'RE READY, YOU'LL
JUST UPLOAD YOUR INSTANT APP
APKs TOGETHER WITH YOUR
INSTALLABLE APK IN THE PLAY
CONSOLE.
IF YOU'RE GETTING READY TO
BUILD
FOR ANDROID O, WE'RE
INTRODUCING
NEW APIs AND  BEHAVIORS FOR
INSTANT APPS.
THERE'S A NEW, MORE EFFICIENT
RUNTIME SANDBOX, AND USERS  WILL
BE ABLE TO FIND INSTANT  APPS
DIRECTLY IN THE LAUNCHER  AND
THEN ADD THEM TO THEIR  HOME
SCREENS.
LET'S LOOK AT AN EXAMPLE.
I HEARD ABOUT THE NEW YORK
TIMES
CROSSWORD APP RECENTLY,  AND I
CAN SEARCH FOR IT IN  THE
LAUNCHER AND THEN OPEN IT  WITH
A
SINGLE TAP.  I CAN  EVEN DRAG IT
TO THE HOME  SCREEN, SO IT'S
EASY
TO COME  BACK LATER.
BY THE WAY, IN EARLY TESTING,
THE TIMES IS SEEING
SIGNIFICANTLY MORE ENGAGEMENT
FROM PEOPLE PLAYING AND
COMPLETING PUZZLES.
TO GET STARTED BUILDING AN
INSTANT APP TODAY, GO TO
G.CO/INSTANTAPPS, AND COME
VISIT
US AT OUR I/O SESSIONS  OR AT
THE
ANDROID SANDBOX.
WITH ANDROID IN SO MANY  PLACES,
TYPES OF  EXPERIENCES, LIKE THE
GOOGLE  ASSISTANT, BRINGING
GOOGLE'S  INTELLIGENCE TO
BILLIONS OF  PEOPLE.  IT'S BEEN
REALLY  COOL TO SEE THE
ASSISTANT
REALLY COMING TO LIFE AND
ROLLING OUT ON SO MANY  DEVICES
THIS YEAR.
NEXT UP, WE'LL LEARN WHAT THE
GOOGLE ASSISTANT MEANS TO YOU
AS
A DEVELOPER FROM BRAD  ABRAMS.
THANK YOU.
Brad Abrams:
THANKS, ELLIE.
IN DECEMBER LAST YEAR WE
LAUNCHED AN EARLY VERSION OF
THE ACTION ON GOOGLE
DEVELOPER PLATFORM.  THIS
VERSION LETS YOU BUILD APPS
FOR GOOGLE HOME, BUT SINCE
THEN, WE'VE BEEN FOCUSED ON
GROWING YOUR AUDIENCE,
EXPANDING THE PLATFORM
FEATURE SET, AND IMPROVING
THE DEVELOPER EXPERIENCE.
AS YOU HEARD IN THE KEYNOTE
THIS MORNING, YOUR APPS ARE
NOW AVAILABLE TO GOOGLE
ASSISTANT USERS ACROSS
ANDROID AND THE iPHONE.
AND AS WE CONTINUE TO EXPAND
THE ASSISTANT'S REACH TO MORE
SURFACES, THE DEVELOPER
PLATFORM WILL FOLLOW.
WITH APPS FOR THE ASSISTANT
NOW AVAILABLE ON THE PHONE,
YOU'LL HAVE THE OPPORTUNITY
TO GROW YOUR USER BASE, BUT
MORE IMPORTANTLY, YOU'LL BE
ABLE TO BUILD APPS FOR
ENTIRELY NEW ASSISTIVE USE
CASES, THINGS THAT PREVIOUSLY
WEREN'T WELL SUITED TO A
VOICE-ONLY INTERFACE, SUCH AS
SHOPPING FOR CLOTHES OR
ORDERING FOOD FROM A LENGTHY
MENU.
IN ADDITION, WITH OUR NEW UI
ELEMENTS SUCH AS IMAGE
CAROUSELS, LISTS, AND
SUGGESTION CHIPS, USERS CAN
EASILY GET THINGS DONE WITH
YOUR APP.  THEY CAN
SEAMLESSLY TRANSITION BETWEEN
VOICE, TYPING, AND TAPS, ALL
IN THE SAME CONVERSATION.
YOU CAN BUILD AND DEPLOY APPS
FOR THE ASSISTANT ON THE
PHONE STARTING TODAY.
[ CHEERING ]
THANK YOU.
WE ALSO WANT TO MAKE IT EASY
TO COMPLETE PURCHASES THROUGH
THE ASSISTANT TO HELP YOU
GROW YOUR BUSINESS.  WE
DESIGNED THE TRANSACTION
EXPERIENCE ON THE ASSISTANT
TO BE EASY AND LIGHTWEIGHT
FOR USERS AND DEVELOPERS
ALIKE.
YOU HEARD ABOUT TRANSACTIONS
THIS MORNING FROM VALERIE,
BUT LET ME EXPAND A LITTLE
BIT FROM A DEVELOPER POINT OF
VIEW.
FOR PAYMENTS, YOU CAN CHOOSE
TO USE GOOGLE-FACILITATED
PAYMENTS WHICH ARE EASY TO
INTEGRATE, ALLOW YOU TO
LEVERAGE HUNDREDS OF MILLIONS
OF CARDS THAT USERS HAVE
ALREADY STORED WITH GOOGLE,
AND ARE AVAILABLE TO
DEVELOPERS FOR FREE.
OR YOU CAN CHOOSE TO USE A
PAYMENT METHOD THAT USERS
HAVE ALREADY PROVIDED YOU.
TO DO SO, WE RECOMMEND USING
OUR NEW SEAMLESS ACCOUNT
LINKING SUPPORT.  THAT ALLOWS
USERS TO SIGN IN TO AN
EXISTING ACCOUNT OR EVEN
CREATE A NEW ACCOUNT IN JUST
TWO
TAPS.
HOWEVER, THE TRANSACTION
ISN'T OVER WHEN THE USER
PAYS.  USERS MAY WANT TO
CHECK ON THE STATUS OF AN
ORDER, MODIFY AN ORDER, OR
EVEN RE-ORDER AN ITEM.
THAT'S WHY THE ASSISTANT NOW
ALLOWS USERS TO SEE ALL THEIR
TRANSACTIONS IN A SINGLE
HISTORY VIEW.
FINALLY, WE BUILT A NEW
ORDERS-UPDATE FEATURE TO
ALLOW USERS TO MAKE IT EASIER
TO ENGAGE WITH YOUR APP.  YOU
ARE NOW ABLE TO SEND STATUS
UPDATES ASYNCHRONOUSLY FOR
EXAMPLE WHEN THEIR CAR
ARRIVES OR A PRESCRIPTION IS
READY.   YOU CAN BUILD AND
TEST TRANSACTIONAL APPS TODAY
AND THEY'LL BE AVAILABLE TO
GOOGLE ASSISTANT USERS ON THE
PHONE SOON.
BUT WHAT GOOD ARE THESE
TRANSACTIONAL FEATURES IF
USERS CAN'T DISCOVER YOUR
APP?
TODAY WE'RE ROLLING OUT A NEW
APP DIRECTORY.  USERS CAN
ACCESS IT WITH A SINGLE TAP
FROM THE GOOGLE ASSISTANT.
IT NOT ONLY HAS CATEGORIES
AND USER RATINGS, IT ALSO
ALLOWS USERS TO TRY YOUR APP
RIGHT FROM THE DIRECTORY
PAGE.
USERS CAN ALSO CREATE A
SHORTCUT TO YOUR APP FOR AN
EASY WAY TO INVOKE IT.  FOR
EXAMPLE, INSTEAD OF SAYING,
SAYING,
"OKAY, GOOGLE, ASK FORE
CASTER JOE WHAT ELSE THE SURF
REPORT FOR THE OUTER BANKS,"
YOU CAN JUST SAY YOUR
SHORTCUT, "OKAY, GOOGLE, IS
THE SURF UP?"
EACH APP'S DIRECTORY PAGE IS
ALSO SHAREABLE ON THE WEB SO
THAT YOU CAN PROMOTE YOUR APP
TO NEW USERS AND YOUR
EXISTING USERS CAN SHARE IT
WITH THEIR FRIENDS.
AND TO MAKE FINDING YOUR APP
EASIER, THE ASSISTANT IS ALSO
LEARNING FROM THE DIRECTORY
AND OTHER INFORMATION
PROVIDED BY THE DEVELOPER.
THANKS TO THESE ADDITIONAL
SIGNALS, THE ASSISTANT CAN
OFTEN PRESENT USERS WITH A
FEW DIFFERENT OPTIONS FOR
GENERAL REQUESTS LIKE, "PLAY
A GAME."
WHILE WE'RE CONFIDENT THESE
FEATURES WILL HELP IMPROVE
DISCOVERABILITY OF YOUR APPS,
OUR WORK IS NOT DONE.
IMPROVING DISCOVERABILITY IS
IMPORTANT TO ALL OF US, AND
YOU CAN EXPECT ONGOING
INVESTMENTS AND IMPROVEMENTS
IN THIS AREA.
WE'RE EQUALLY INVESTED IN
PROVIDING A GREAT DEVELOPER
EXPERIENCE.  TODAY, WE'RE
LAUNCHING A NEW DEVELOPER
CONSOLE, THE ACTIONS CONSOLE
HELPS YOU WORK BETTER AS A
TEAM, COLLECT DATA ABOUT YOUR
APP'S USAGE, PERFORMANCE AND
DISCOVERY PATTERNS.  THIS NEW
CONSOLE IS WELL INTEGRATED
WITH FIREBASE AND THE GOOGLE
CLOUD CONSOLE SO YOU CAN
EASILY SHARE DATA WITH YOUR
APPS.
IN ADDITION TO THE BRAND-NEW
CONSOLE, WE'RE ALSO PROVIDING
YOU ACCESS TO DEVELOPER TOOLS
THAT LET YOU QUICKLY AND
EASILY BUILD APPS FOR THE
ASSISTANT.
SINCE LAUNCHING OUR PLATFORM,
WE'VE WORKED WITH AN
EXPANDING NUMBER OF DEVELOPER
TOOLS COMPANIES TO MAKE THEIR
SOLUTIONS COMPATIBLE WITH
ACTIONS ON GOOGLE.  WE'RE
ALSO EXPANDING THE
CAPABILITIES OF API.AI, OUR
OWN CONVERSATION BUILDING
TOOL, LAUNCHING NEW FEATURES
SUCH AS FOLLOW-UP INTENTS,
PREBUILT AGENTS, AND
IN-DIALOGUE ANALYTICS.
WHILE WE'RE STILL AT THE
EARLY DAYS OF THE ACTIONS ON
GOOGLE PLATFORM, WE'RE
FOCUSED ON MAKING IT ROBUST
AND EXPANDING ITS REACH AND
CAPABILITIES.  WE'RE SOON
LAUNCHING THE PLATFORM IN
U.K. ENGLISH WITH FRENCH AND
FOLLOWING LATER THIS YEAR.
WE ALSO INTEND TO BRING THE
PLATFORM TO MANY NEW DEVICES,
INCLUDING ALL THOSE POWERED
BY THE GOOGLE ASSISTANT SDK.
WE'RE EXCITED ABOUT THE ROAD
AHEAD, AND WE WANT MORE OF
YOU TO JOIN US BY DEVELOPING
FOR THE PLATFORM.  WITH AN
ADDRESSABLE AUDIENCE OF 100
MILLION DEVICES, NEW
CAPABILITIES LIKE
TRANSACTIONS AND IMPROVED
DEVELOPER EXPERIENCE, WE
THINK THIS IS AN INCREDIBLE
OPPORTUNITY FOR ALL OF US.
YOU KNOW, THE MAGIC OF THE
ASSISTANT IS ENABLED BY
GOOGLE'S DEEP INVESTMENTS IN
AI AND THE CLOUD.  AND TO
TELL YOU MORE ABOUT HOW YOU
CAN USE THAT DIRECTLY, PLEASE
WELCOME FEI-FEI.
THANK YOU.
[ APPLAUSE
]
Fei-Fei Lee:  HI.  I'M
FEI-FEI LEE.  I'M CHIEF
SCIENTIST OF AI AND MACHINE
LEARNING AT GOOGLE CLOUD.
WHAT AN EXCITING DAY.
I'VE BEEN DOING AI RESEARCH
FOR ALMOST TWO DECADES, AND I
CAN HONESTLY SAY THESE LAST
FEW YEARS HAVE BEEN THE MOST
EXCITING OF MY ENTIRE CAREER.
AI IS TRANSFORMING EVERYTHING
GOOGLE DOES.  AND AS WE
SPEAK, INDUSTRIES FROM
FINANCE TO HEALTHCARE ARE
AUGMENTING HUMAN CAPABILITIES
WITH MACHINE INSIGHTS.
BUT BUILDING AI EXPERTISE IS
A SIGNIFICANT INVESTMENT, AND
WE KNOW THAT MANY OF YOU
SIMPLY HAVEN'T HAD THE
OPPORTUNITY.
I JOINED GOOGLE PRECISELY FOR
THIS REASON, TO ENSURE THAT
EVERYONE CAN LEVERAGE AI TO
STAY COMPETITIVE AND SOLVE
THE PROBLEMS THAT MATTER MOST
TO THEM.
IN OTHER WORDS, WE'RE MEETING
YOU WHERE YOU ARE.  WE CALL
THIS DEMOCRATIZING AI.  AND
I'D LIKE TO SHARE A FEW
EXAMPLES IN ACTION.
FIRST, WE'RE DEVELOP- --
DEMOCRATIZING THE ALGORITHMS
THAT MAKE AI SO POWERFUL,
WITH A COLLECTION OF
HIGH-LEVEL MACHINE LEARNING
APIs THAT CAN HELP YOUR
APPLICATIONS UNDERSTAND THE
CONTENT OF IMAGES, VIDEOS,
AUDIOS, AND NATURAL LANGUAGE
WITH MINIMAL EFFORTS.
WHATEVER YOUR LEVEL OF
EXPERTISE, THESE ARE TOOLS
YOU CAN PUT TO USE
IMMEDIATELY AND SEE RESULTS.
AT THE SAME TIME, WE'RE
EQUALLY FOCUSED ON DEVELOPERS
READY TO BUILD THEIR OWN
MODELS.
IN NOVEMBER 2015, GOOGLE OPEN
SOURCED TENSORFLOW, A
SOFTWARE FRAMEWORK FOR
MACHINE LEARNING THAT IS USED
EXTENSIVELY THROUGHOUT
GOOGLE.  TODAY, WE'RE
CONTINUING THE EVOLUTION BY
BRINGING NEW HIGH-LEVEL
APIs IN TENSORFLOW 1.2 THAT
MAKES IT EASIER FOR YOU TO
START TRAINING MACHINE
LEARNING MODELS ON YOUR DATA
RIGHT AWAY USING THE BEST
HARDWARE YOU HAVE AVAILABLE.
I ENCOURAGE YOU TO CHECK OUT
OUR TENSORFLOW SESSIONS TO
LEARN MORE.
ADDITIONALLY, WE ALSO
LAUNCHED THE CLOUD MACHINE
LEARNING ENGINE TO HELP YOU
MANAGE LARGE-SCALE TENSORFLOW
TRAINING AND PREDICTION JOBS
IN THE
CLOUD.
OF COURSE  OF THERE'S NO
GETTING
AROUND THE FACT THAT AI
REQUIRES ENORMOUS
COMPUTATIONAL RESOURCES, AND
THIS REPRESENTS ONE OF THE
STEEPEST BARRIERS TO ENTRY
FOR DEVELOPERS.  TO ADDRESS
THIS, SUNDAR ANNOUNCED THIS
MORNING THAT GOOGLE HAS
DEVELOPED A SECOND-GENERATION
TPU, OR TENSOR PROCESSING
UNIT, THAT CAN TRAIN MACHINE
LEARNING MODELS AS WELL AS
RUN THEM.
OUR TPUs DELIVER A
STAGGERING 180 TERAFLOPS AND
ARE BUILT FOR JUST THE KIND
OF NUMBER-CRUNCHING THAT
DRIVES MACHINE LEARNING
TO PUT THIS IN PERSPECTIVE OUR
NEW LARGE-SCALE TRANSLATION
MODEL TAKES A FULL DAY TO TRAIN
TODAY.ON 32 OF THE WORLD'S BEST
COMMERCIALLY
AVAILABLE GPUs
WHILE ONLY 1/8 OF A TPU POD CAN
DO THIS JUST IN AN AFTERNOON.
BUT TPU SPECS ARE ONLY PART OF
THE STORY.  THE REAL
BREAKTHROUGH LIE IN HOW WE'RE
WORKING TO DEMOCRATIZE
COMPUTATION AS A WHOLE.  GOOGLE
CLOUD PLATFORM ALLOWS US TO
MAKE
THIS INCREDIBLE NEW HARDWARE
AVAILABLE TO EVERYONE.
YOU'LL SOON BE ABLE TO RENT
CLOUD TPUs WITHOUT ANY UP
FRONT CAPITAL EXPENSES, THE
SAME
WAY YOU CAN RENT OTHER
INFRASTRUCTURES ON GOOGLE
COMPUTE ENGINE, PAYING ONLY FOR
WHAT YOU NEED.
WE STRIVE TO ENSURE CONSISTENT
EXPERIENCES AND PAINLESS
INTEROPERABILITY, WHETHER
YOU'RE
RUNNING YOUR CODE ON CPUs,
GPUs, TPUs, OR WHATEVER
COMES NEXT.
IF YOU'RE INTERESTED IN BEING
ONE OF THE FIRST DEVELOPERS TO
TRAIN MACHINE LEARNING MODELS
ON
CLOUD TPUs, PLEASE SIGN UP AT
THIS LINK TO LEARN MORE ABOUT
OUR CLOUD TPU ALPHA PROGRAMS.
I
SEE ALL THE CELL PHONES.
[ LAUGHTER ]
AS AN AI RESEARCHER MYSELF, I
CAN TELL YOU THAT THE RESEARCH
IMPLICATIONS OF TPUs ARE
SIGNIFICANT AS WELL, WHICH IS
WHY I'M SO EXCITED ALSO ABOUT
THE TENSORFLOW RESEARCH CLOUD,
A
CLUSTER
OF 1,000 CLOUD TPUs
THAT WE'RE MAKING AVAILABLE TO
TOP MACHINE LEARNING
RESEARCHERS
FOR FREE!
AS AN EXAMPLE, WE SHARE THE
NEWS
ABOUT OUR CLOUD TPUs WITH
HARVARD MEDICAL SCHOOL, AND
THEY'RE EAGER TO USE OUR
TENSORFLOW RESEARCH CLOUD TO DO
RESEARCH AT A NATIONAL SCALE
THAT JUST HASN'T BEEN POSSIBLE
TILL NOW.
WE'RE SETTING UP A PROGRAM TO
ACCEPT APPLICATIONS FOR ACCESS
TO THE TENSORFLOW RESEARCH
CLOUD.  AND YOU CAN SIGN UP TO
LEARN MORE ABOUT THIS.
I ESPECIALLY ENCOURAGE STUDENTS
AND KAGGLE USERS TO APPLY.
THESE ARE EXCITING TIMES.
GOOGLE HAS SPENT YEARS
DEVELOPING SOME OF THE MOST
ADVANCED AI IN THE WORLD.  AND
THE EMERGENCE OF THE CLOUD
MEANS
YOU CAN SHARE IT WITH EVERYONE,
FROM STARTUPS TO ENTERPRISES,
FROM HEALTHCARE TO RETAIL, AND
EVERYTHING IN BETWEEN.
WE CREATED THE CLOUD AI TEAM TO
MAKE AI DEMOCRATIC, TO MEET YOU
WHERE YOU ARE WITH GOOGLE'S
MOST
POWERFUL AI TOOLS AND TO SHARE
THE JOURNEY AS YOU PUT THEM TO
USE.
WHETHER YOU'RE BUILDING
STATE-OF-THE-ART MACHINE
LEARNING MODELS FROM SCRATCH OR
JUST WANT TURN-KEY SOLUTIONS
FOR
IMMEDIATE RESULTS, WE'RE HERE
TO
SUPPORT YOU AT EVERY STEP OF
THE
WAY.
NOW, TO TELL YOU MORE ABOUT HOW
GOOGLE IS IMPROVING DEVELOPMENT
FOR THE WEB, PLEASE WELCOME
TAL.
THANK YOU.
[ CHEERS AND APPLAUSE ]
Tal Oppenheimer:  THANKS,
FEI-FEI.  I'M A TAL FROM THE
CHROME TEAM AND I'M EXCITED TO
TELL YOU ABOUT SOME OF THE
GREAT
IMPROVEMENTS WE'VE MADE ON THE
WEB OVER THE LAST YEAR.  THE
WEB
IS BIG.  WITH OVER 2 BILLION
INSTANCES OF CHROME, WE KNOW
THAT THE WEB HAS TREMENDOUS
REACH.  BUT ONE OF THE REAL
STRENGTHS OF THE WEB IS THAT
IT'S BIGGER THAN A SINGLE
BROWSERS.
BROWSER.  VARIOUS ESTIMATES
SHOW
THAT THERE ARE WELL OVER
5 BILLION ACTIVELY USED
DEVICES,
AND REGARDLESS OF WHETHER THAT
DEVICE IS A SMARTPHONE OR A
LAPTOP OR A DESKTOP OR A
TABLET,
THEY ALL HAVE A BROWSER.  AND
THAT MEANS THAT ANY WEB APP IS
AVAILABLE ON THESE BILLIONS OF
DEVICES TODAY.  AND WE'VE SEEN
THIS HAVE A REAL IMPACT ON HOW
MANY USERS WEB APPS ARE
REACHING.
WEAVES ALL SEEN HOW QUICKLY
MOBILE HAS BEEN GROWING.  AND
NATIVE APPS HAVE BEEN GROWING
AT
A TREMENDOUS PACE WITH IT.  BUT
WHAT'S REALLY REMARKABLE IS
THAT
EVEN WITH THE WEB'S LARGE
INITIAL REACH, WE'VE SEEN THE
AVERAGE MONTHLY WEB AUDIENCE
GROWING EVEN FASTER.  AND
BECAUSE OF THIS GROWTH, WE'RE
SEEING THE WEB EXPAND INTO NEW
AREAS WITH EXPERIENCES LIKE
WEBVR BEING BUILT ON THE WEB
PLATFORM.  AND THE WEB
CONTINUES
TO POP UP IN MORE AND MORE
PLACES.  EVEN SOME WE DIDN'T
REALLY EXPECT.
A COUPLE OF WEEKS AGO McDONALD
McDONALD'S ANNOUNCED THAT THEY
USED THE WEB AND POLYMER TO
BUILD THEIR NEW MENU BOARDS.
NOW WHEN YOU ARE LOOKING AT THE
MENU AT McDONALD'S, THAT'S
BUILT ON THE WEB AS WELL.  SO
WITH THE WEB PRETTY MUCH
EVERYWHERE, WE ARE CONSTANTLY
TRYING TO PUSH THE BOUNDARIES
OF
WHAT IT CAN DO.
IF YOU LOOK AT ALL OF OUR
LAUNCHES SINCE LAST YEAR'S I/O,
WE'VE SHIPPED 215 ADDITIONAL
APIs THAT COVER A RANGE OF
CAPABILITIES, FROM MAKING IT
EASIER TO INTEGRATE PAYMENTS
INTO YOUR EXPERIENCE, TO MAKING
IT POSSIBLE TO BUILD FULLY
CAPABLE OFFLINE MEDIA
EXPERIENCES DIRECTLY ON THE
WEB.
AND WITH ALL OF THESE NEW
CAPABILITIES, WE'VE SEEN A
MASSIVE GROWTH IN EXPERIENCES
BUILT ON THE WEB.  ACCELERATED
MOBILE PAGES OR AMP PAGES MAKE
IT REALLY EASY FOR PUBLISHERS
TO
CREATE FAST ARTICLES.  SINCE
LAUNCH WE'VE SEEN THIS GROW
FROM
OVER 2 BILLION AMP PAGES FROM
ACROSS 900,000 DOMAINS.  BEYOND
AMP PAGES, THE MODERN MOBILE
WEB
ALSO ALLOWS DEVELOPERS TO BUILD
DEEP, RICH MOBILE EXPERIENCES
WITH SOMETHING WE CALLED
PROGRESSIVE WEB APPs OR PWA.
PWAs.  PWAs ARE ABOUT
HELPING DEVELOPERS LEVERAGE
BUILD HIGH-CLASS EXPERIENCES
THAT FEEL IMMERSIVE.  THEY CAN
LOAD QUICKLY AND WORK OFFLINE
AND CAN EVEN SEND NOTIFICATIONS
TO USERS.  WE'VE SEEN A NUMBER
OF AMAZING EXPERIENCES TAKING
ADVANTAGES OF THESE NEW
CAPABILITIES.  AS JUST ONE
EXAMPLE, THERE'S TWITTER WHO
RECENTLY REBUILT THEIR MOBILE
WEB EXPERIENCE.  HERE THEY HAVE
A POLISHED, FAST, IMMERSIVE
EXPERIENCE THAT WORKS ON ANY
CONNECTION TYPE.  AND IT CAN
SEND USERS NOTIFICATIONS AND
IT'S COMPLETELY BUILT ON THE
MOBILE WEB, SO IT'S ALREADY
ACCESSIBLE ON BILLIONS OF
DEVICES.
AND WITH AN IMMERSIVE
EXPERIENCE
LIKE THIS, WE ALSO WANT TO MAKE
SURE THAT USERS CAN GET BACK TO
IT EASILY.  ADD TO HOME SCREEN
HAS ALWAYS ALLOWS USERS TO ADD
ANY EXPERIENCE TO THEIR HOME
SCREEN.  BUT WITH OUR IMPROVED
ADD TO HOME SCREEN FLOW, WHEN
YOU ADD A PWA TO YOUR HOME
SCREEN, IT'S FULLY INTEGRATED
INTO THE PLATFORM.  SO TO
USERS,
IT FEELS LIKE ANY OTHER APP
EXPERIENCE ON THEIR DEVICE.
IT WILL APPEAR IN THE ANDROID
LAUNCHER ALONGSIDE YOUR ANDROID
APPS, AND IT WILL EVEN APPEAR
IN
ANDROID STORAGE SETTINGS.  BUT
SINCE IT'S A PWA, IT'S
INHERENTLY SMALLER WITH
TWITTER'S PROGRESSIVE WEB APP
AT
UNDER 1 MEGABYTE.  SO USERS ARE
GETTING A COMPARABLE EXPERIENCE
THAT REQUIRES SIGNIFICANTLY
LESS
STORAGE SPACE.  AND THE FACT
THAT IT'S SO SMALL DOESN'T JUST
REDUCE ITS STORAGE SIZE BUT
ALSO
MEANS THAT IT LOADS ALMOST
INSTANTLY ON ANY CONNECTION
TYPE.
AND THIS FAST, INTEGRATED,
IMPROVED ADD-TO-HOME SCREEN
FLOW
IS ROLLING OUT NOW.
WITH ALL OF THESE NEW
CAPABILITIES, WE'VE ALSO BEEN
WORKING TO MAKE SURE IT'S
REALLY
EASY FOR WEB DEVELOPERS TO
BUILD
THESE EXPERIENCES.  WE'LL BE
GOING INTO A LOT MORE DETAIL ON
HOW TO DEVELOP PWAs THROUGHOUT
THE MOBILE WEB TRACK OVER THE
NEXT FEW DAYS.  BUT NO MATTER
HOW YOU'RE BUILDING OUR WEB
APP,
LIGHTHOUSE IS A TOOL THAT CAN
SHOW YOU HOW TO IMPROVE YOUR
WEB
EXPERIENCE.
LIGHTHOUSE IS A CHROME
EXTENSION
AND COMMAND LINE TOOL THAT RUNS
ALMOST 100 AUDIOS ON YOUR SITE
TO -- AUDITS ON YOUR SITE TO
IMPROVE YOUR APP'S PERFORMANCE,
ACCESSIBILITY, AND PROGRESSIVE
WEB APPYNESS.
AND WE'RE EXCITED TO ANNOUNCE
THAT LIGHTHOUSE WILL BE
INTEGRATED DIRECTLY DO
DEVTOOLS.
SO NOW YOU CAN QUICKLY SEE HOW
YOUR WEB SITE IS DOING AND WHAT
TO DO NEXT DIRECTLY IN CHROME.
[ CHEERS AND APPLAUSE ]
AND WITH ALL OF THESE TOOLS,
WE'VE SEEN JUST HOW EASY IT CAN
BE FOR COMPANIES TO TAKE
ADVANTAGE OF THESE NEW
CAPABILITIES FOR THEIR WEB
EXPERIENCE.  TO GIVE ONE,
THERE'S WEGO, ONE OF THE
BIGGEST
TRAVEL PLAYERS IN THE SOUTHEAST
ASIA AND MIDDLE EAST THAT BUILT
ONE OF THE MOST POLISHED PWAs
WE'VE SEEN.  THEIR EXPERIENCE
WORKS QUICKLY, WHETHER YOU'RE
ONLINE OR OFFLINE.  THEY LINK
OFF TO AMP PAGES TO ENSURE THAT
PAGES LOAD QUICKLY AS WELL.
AND THEY LEVERAGE SOME OF THE
NEWEST WEB APIs TO MAKE
PAYMENTS AND IDENTITY REALLY
EASY FOR THEIR USERS.  BUT
WHAT'S REALLY REMARKABLE IS
THAT
THIS CORE PWA EXPERIENCE WAS
BUILT IN JUST OVER TWO MONTHS
BY
A SINGLE ENGINEER WHO WAS NEW
TO
WEB DEVELOPMENT.
AND THIS IS JUST ONE EXAMPLE OF
MANY.  LEVERAGING THE MODERN
MOBILE WEB IS NOW THE NORM
AROUND THE WORLD.  WE'VE SEEN
COMPANIES EVERYWHERE BUILDING
PROGRESSIVE WEB APPS AND SEEING
A TANGIBLE IMPACT ON THEIR KEY
METRICS.  WITH THE MODERN
MOBILE
WEB, IT'S POSSIBLE TO EASILY
BUILD IMMERSIVE, FULLY CAPABLE
EXPERIENCES THAT CAN REACH
BILLIONS OF PEOPLE AROUND THE
WORLD TODAY.
AND NOW LET'S TURN OUR FOCUS TO
WHAT WE'RE DOING TO HELP MAKE
IT
EASIER TO DEVELOP APPS AND GROW
YOUR BUSINESS.  PLEASE JOIN ME
IN WELCOMING BEN.
[ APPLAUSE
]
Ben Galbraith:  THANKS, TAL.
HEY, EVERYONE.
LAST YEAR AT I/O, WE INTRODUCED
AN EXPANDED FIREBASE, A MOBILE
DEVELOPMENT PLATFORM THAT HELPS
YOU WITH THINGS LIKE STORING
DATA IN THE CLOUD AND
SYNCHRONIZING IT ACROSS
DEVICES,
PINPOINTING APP CRASHES,
SENDING
TARGETED NOTIFICATIONS TO JUST
THE RIGHT USERS, SERVING ADS IN
YOUR APPS, AND MORE.
ALL OF THIS IS BUNDLED TOGETHER
IN A SINGLE EASY-TO-USE
CROSS-PLATFORM SDK.  FIREBASE
ALSO INCLUDES A POWERFUL FREE
AND UNLIMITED ANALYTICS TOOL
PURPOSE-BUILT FOR THE NEEDS OF
NATIVE APPS AND NEW THIS YEAR,
ANALYTICS GIVES YOU REALTIME
VIEWS INTO WHAT'S HAPPENING
INSIDE OF YOUR APP WHICH OPENS
UP SORT OF A LIVE WINDOW INTO
WHAT'S HAPPENING RIGHT NOW.
FIREBASE IS ALSO INTEGRATED
WITH
THE GOOGLE CLOUD PLATFORM WHICH
MEANS IT SCALES WITH YOU AS
YOUR
NEEDS GROW.  FOR EXAMPLE,
ANALYTICS CONNECTS SEAMLESSLY
WITH BIGQUERY WHICH MEANS YOU
CAN
EXECUTE FAST SQL-LIKE QUERY
AT DATA AT SCALE.  SINCE LAST
YEAR'S LAUNCH OVER A MILLION
DEVELOPERS ARE USING FIREBASE.
WE ARE SO HUMBLED THAT SO MANY
OF YOU HAVE TAKEN THIS JOURNEY
WITH US AND HAVE CHOSEN TO USE
US IN YOUR APP.
WE'RE DEEPLY COMMITTED TO
FIREBASE, AND WE'RE DOUBLING
DOWN ON OUR EFFORTS TO SIMPLIFY
MORE EVERYDAY DEVELOPER
CHALLENGES.  TO THAT END, IN
JANUARY, THE FABRIC TEAM JOINED
GOOGLE.  SINCE FIRST LAUNCHING
CRASH LYTICS
IN 2011, THE FABRIC
TEAM HAS BEEN A SIMILAR MISSION
TO OUS AND HAVE BUILT
REMARKABLE
SET OF PRODUCTS THAT HAVE
ACHIEVED WIDESPREAD DEVELOPER
ADOPTION.  THE FIREBASE AND
AFRICA TEAMS ARE HARD AT WORK
INTEGRATING THESE TWO PLATFORMS
TOGETHER IN A THOUGHTFUL WAY TO
BRING YOU THE BEST OF BOTH.
WE'LL HAVE MORE TO SHARE ON
THIS
FRONT IN THE COMING MONTHS.
OVER THE PAST YEAR, WE'VE BEEN
CONTINUOUSLY IMPROVING AND
EXPANDING FIREBASE.  AND TODAY
I
WANT TO HIGHLIGHT A COUPLE OF
OF
THE ENHANCEMENTS THAT WE'VE
MADE
STARTING WITH CLOUD FUNCTIONS.
ONE OF OUR GOALS WITH FIREBASE
IS FREEING YOU FROM HAVING TO
THINK ABOUT SERVERS AND
INFRASTRUCTURE SO YOU CAN FOCUS
ON CREATING GREAT APPS.  BUT
SOMETHING'S BEEN MISSING FOR US
TO TRULY ACCOMPLISH THIS GOAL,
AND IT'S A GAP THAT WE'RE NOW
ABLE TO FILL WITH CLOUD
FUNCTIONS FOR FIREBASE, WHICH
WE
JUST RECENTLY RELEASED INTO
BETA.
CLOUD FUNCTIONS GIVES YOU AN
EASY WAY TO DEPLOY JAKE WHARTON
CODE INTO THE CLOUD AND THIS --
GENTLEMAN HAVE ASCRIPT CODE
INTO
THE CLOUD AND IT CAN INTEGRATE
INTO FIREBASE EVENS.  THESE
FUNCTIONS RUN IN AN MAD NODE.JS
ENVIRONMENT SO YOU CAN EASILY
TAP INTO THE VAST NODE APACHEJ
ECOSYSTEM.  YOU CAN USE THESE
FUNCTIONS TO DO THINGS LIKE
RESPOND TO A DATABASE UPDATE BY
SENDING NOTIFICATION WITH CLOUD
MESSAGING OR YOU CAN RESIZE
IMAGES UPLOADED BY YOUR USERS
BEFORE SAVING THEM WITH CLOUD
STORAGE.
AND TODAY, WE'RE OPENING UP A
NEW INTEGRATION BETWEEN
FUNCTIONS AND FIREBASE HOSTING.
NOW, HOSTING LET'S YOU SERVE
STATIC CONTENT LIKE HTML AND
CSS
FILES THAT ARE AUTOMATICALLY
BACKED BY A GLOBAL CACHING
NETWORK, BY COMBINING THOSE
WITH
CLOUD FUNCTIONSES, YOU CAN NOW
GENERATE DYNAMIC WEB CONTENT
THAT YOU CAN SERVE ON OUR OWN
DOMAIN WITH A STATIC CONTENT
AND
IS BOTH ACCELERATED BY THIS
GLOBAL CACHING NETWORK.
SO AS WITH CLOUD FUNCTIONS, YOU
CAN DEPLOY INDIVIDUAL UNITS OF
CODE AS YOU NEED THEM, WHICH
GIVES YOU A REALLY ELEGANT WAY
TO FACTOR CODE OUT FROM YOUR
APPS AND SHARE THEM ACROSS YOUR
WEB AND NATIVE APPS AS YOU NEED
WITHOUT HAVING TO WORRY ABOUT
APP SERVERS OR SERVER-SIDE
APPLICATIONS.  AND IT ENABLES
TRUE SERVERLESS DEVELOPMENT.
WE
ARE REALLY EXCITED ABOUT THIS.
ALL RIGHT.  I HAVE GOT ONE MORE
THING I WANT TO SHARE WITH YOU.
AND THIS HAS TO DO WITH YOUR
NATIVE APPS QUALITY.  AS
DEVELOPERS, WE SPEND A LOT OF
TIME OPTIMIZES AND TESTING OUR
APPS TO GET THEM TO FORM
PERFORM
JUST RIGHT.  WHEN WE RELEASE
THEM INTO THE WILD IT'S REALLY
OWN OUR USERS THAT HOE HOW THEY
ARE PERFORMING.  IT'S HARD TO
KNOW EXACTLY HOW THEY ARE
BEHAVING ACROSS A HUGE ARRAY OF
DEVICES AND VARIED NETWORK
CONDITIONS ACROSS THE WORLD.
AND NOT HAVING THEY
WILL.PERFORM
WELL IS FRUSTRATING FOR
EVERYONE.  WE ARE RELEASING A
NEW PRODUCT TO HELP CALLED
FIREBASE PERFORMANCE
MONITORING.
AFTER YOU ADD FIREBASE
PERFORMANCE -- THANK YOU.
PERFORMANCE WITH YOUR APP WITH
ONE LINE OF CODE, FIREBASE
PERFORMANCE AUTOMATICALLY
PROVIDES INSIGHTS INTO TWO OF
THE MOST CRITICAL ASPECTS OF
APP
PERFORMANCE, STARTUP TIME AND
NETWORK RESPONSIVENESS.
YOU CAN THEN USE IT'S SIMPLE
API --
[ APPLAUSE ]
THANK YOU.  YOU CAN USE ITS
SIMPLE API TO MEASURE VIRTUALLY
ANYTHING IN YOUR APP AS YOU SEE
ON THE SLIDE, YOU JUST INVOKE A
FUNCTION AT THE BEGINNING AND
THEN AT THE END AND FIREBASE
PERFORMANCE DOES THE HEAVY
LIFTING OF COLLECTING ALL OF
THE
PERFORMANCE METRICS FOR YOU
ACROSS ALL OF YOUR APP
INSTANCES.
AND THEN YOU CAN FILTER THESE
METRICS BY COUNTRY, DEVICE
TYPE,
OS, AND APP VERSION TO GET A
CLEAR VIEW OF WHERE YOU NEED TO
FOCUS YOUR EFFORTS.
THE BETA VERSION OF FIREBASE
PERFORMANCE IS AVAILABLE TODAY.
[ APPLAUSE ]
THANK
YOU.
WE HOPE THIS MAKES A BIG
DIFFERENCE IN YOUR EFFORTS TO
CREATE HIGH-PERFORMING NATIVE
APPS.
WE HAVE A BUNCH OF OTHER
FIREBASE ANNOUNCEMENTS TODAY AT
SESSIONS HERE AT I/O, INCLUDING
SUPPORT FOR PHONE NUMBER
AUTHENTICATION AND WE'RE OPEN
SOURCING MANY OF OUR FIREBASE
SDKs.
[ CHEERS AND APPLAUSE ]
THANKS TO NEW ENHANCEMENTS WE'VE
ALSO MADE THE TEST LAB FOR
ANDROID AND OUR RECENTLY
RELEASED UNITY AND CPU CPU C++
DEVELOPERS, TOO.  WE WANT
FIREBASE TO BE THE BEST PLACE
FOR YOU TO START YOUR NEXT APP,
FREEING YOUR ENERGIES TO FOCUS
ON MAKING YOUR APP AWESOME
WHICH
IS WHERE YOU SHOULD BE SPENDING
ALL YOUR TIME.
THANK YOU.  AND NOW I WOULD
LIKE
TO BRING JASON BACK UP.
[ APPLAUSE ]
Jason Titus:  THANKS, BEN.
AS YOU CAN SEE, AT GOOGLE,
WE'VE
BEEN WORKING ACROSS A RANGE OF
TEAMS TO MAKE IT EASIER TO
BUILD
PRODUCTS.  DURING I/O, YOU'LL
HAVE AN OPPORTUNITY TO GO DEEP
INTO A NUMBER OF THESE, WITH 14
CONTENT TRACKS AND OVER 140
BREAKOUT SESSIONS, COVERING
EVERYTHING FROM ANDROID TO THE
CLOUD TO VR.
WE ALSO HAVE SANDBOXES TO HELP
YOU GET HANDS-ON EXPERIENCE
WITH
OUR PRODUCTS AS WELL AS OVER 70
CODE LABS TO GET YOU UP AND
RUNNING WITH OUR LATEST APIs
TODAY.
IN ADDITION, THE GOOGLERS THAT
BUILT THESE PRODUCTS ARE HERE
SO
GRAB THEM FOR ONE-ON-ONE
CONSULTATIONS IN OFFICE HOURS
OR
AT THE SANDBOXES.  NOT ONLY CAN
THEY HELP YOU UNDERSTAND OUR
PRODUCTS BUT MORE IMPORTANTLY
THEY CAN GET YOUR FEEDBACK ON
HOW WE'RE DOING.
I DO HAVE ONE OTHER
ANNOUNCEMENT
BEFORE WE GO OUT TO BREAKOUT
SESSIONS.  AS YOU CAN TELL,
WE'RE REALLY EXCITED ABOUT THE
FUTURE OF AI AND PARTICULARLY
OUR GOOGLE ASSISTANT PLATFORM.
AND SO TO GET YOU RAMPED UP,
WE'RE HOSTING OUR FIRST-EVER
ACTIONS ON GOOGLE DEVELOPER
CHALLENGE BY BUILDING CREATIVE,
USEFUL OR SIMPLY FUN APPS FOR
THE GOOGLE ASSISTANT, YOU CAN
COMPETE TO WIN ONE OF OVER 20
PRIZES.
AND FOR THOSE OF YOU HERE AT
SHORELINE, WE'RE GIVING YOU A
GOOGLE HOME DEVICE AND $700 OF
CLOUD CREDIT TO GET YOU
STARTED.
[ CHEERS AND APPLAUSE ]
WE CANNOT WAIT TO SEE WHAT YOU
BUILD!
SO SUNDAR TALKED ABOUT THE
TECHNOLOGICAL SHIFT TO AI. AS
WELL AS THE POWER OF OPEN
PLATFORMS.  THIS IS A REALLY
EXCITING TIME IN COMPUTING.  WE
HOPE YOU'RE AS INSPIRED AS WE
ARE ABOUT THE FUTURE.  AND,
REMEMBER, ALL OF US HERE AT
GOOGLE ARE HERE TO HELP YOU
THIS
WEEK.  SO PLEASE TAKE ADVANTAGE
OF IT.
AND LET'S BUILD GREAT THINGS
TOGETHER.  THANK YOU AND HAVE
FUN!  PLUS PLUS
[ APPLAUSE ]
[ CHEERS AND APPLAUSE ]
Chet Haase:  HELLO, AND  WELCOME
TO WHAT'S NEW IN  ANDROID, OR,
AS
I, THE ONLY  PERSON, LIKE TO
REFER TO IT  AS THE ANDROID
KEYNOTES.  I'M  CHET HAASE FROM
THE ANDROID  UI TOOLKIT TEAM.
Romain Guy:  ROMAIN GUY FOR  THE
GRAPHICS TEAM.
Dan Sandler:  AND I'M DAN
SANDLER, FROM THE SYSTEM UI
TEAM.
AND WE DON'T HAVE A LOT OF
TIME,
SO LET'S GET TO IT.
ARE YOU READY FOR WHAT'S NEW  IN
ANDROID?
HERE'S WHERE WE LEFT OFF LAST
TIME.  API 25.  SO WE'RE JUST
GOING TO GRAP THAT THERE, POP
IT
INTO GIT DIFFICULT AND OFF  WE
GO.
YOU'RE GOING TO WANT TO WRITE
THIS DOWN.
[ LAUGHTER ]
OKAY.  NEXT.
YEAH, THAT WAS A GOOD ONE.
OKAY.
Chet Haase:  I LOVE THOSE.
Dan Sandler:  REMEMBER, WE
ALMOST NAD THAT AN ENUM?  IT
WAS
HILARIOUS.
YOU GOT THAT?  YOU THINK  THIS
IS WHAT PEOPLE CAME FOR?   I
DON'T KNOW WHY WE DIDN'T  THINK
OF THIS BEFORE.
SO WE'VE BEEN DOING THIS  TALK,
TELLING YOU WHAT'S NEW  FOR
YEARS, AND YOU CAN SEE  THAT --
I
FORGOT MY BALLET
BLAZER.   I HAD
A LOVELY RED BLAZER,  BUT
SOMEBODY BORROWED IT FOR  THE
KEYNOTE.
BUT THIS YEAR WAS A LITTLE
DIFFERENT.  HAD YOU THE
DEVELOPER PREVIEWS WELL IN
ADVANCE, SO YOU'VE SEEN A LOT
OF
THESE APIs BEFORE.  YOU  HAD
THE GOOGLE KEYNOTE WHERE  WE
SHOWED OFF A LOT OF REALLY
EXCITING STUFF.  WE HAD A
DEVELOPER KEYNOTE, WHERE YOU
LEARNED ABOUT EVEN MORE
DEVELOPER STUFF.
SO WHAT ARE WE DOING HERE?
WHAT
IS THE POINT OF WHAT'S  NEW IN
ANDROID?
Chet Haase: EXISTENTIAL  CRISIS.
Dan Sandler:  SO -- DID YOU
TEST
THIS CLICKER?
Chet Haase:  I DID, I DID.
Dan Sandler:  THINK OF THIS
TALK
LIKE A WINE TASTING OR A
WHISKEY
FLIGHT OR ONE OF  THOSE SODA
MACHINES THAT YOU  CAN PUSH ALL
THE BUTTONS ON.
THIS IS AN ARTISINAL,
HAND-PICKED SELECTION OF  THINGS
YOU MAY HAVE  OVERLOOKED IN THE
NEW RELEASE  OF ANDROID.  THINGS
YOU'RE  GOING TO NEED TO DO NO
MATTER  WHAT TO BE PART OF
ANDROID O.   AND, WELL,
HONESTLY,
JUST  THINGS WE'D LIKE TO TALK
ABOUT, AND WE'RE ONSTAGE.
SO WITH THAT, THIS IS REALLY
WHAT'S NEW IN ANDROID,
SPECIFICALLY, WHAT YOU MIGHT
HAVE MISSED IN THE DEVELOPER
PREVIEW OR THE I/O KEYNOTE OR
THE OTHER KEYNOTE, AND WHY  YOU
SHOULD CARE.
ONE LAST THING THAT I WANT TO
MAKE SURE WE GET TO TODAY IS
THIS.  EVERYBODY'S ALWAYS
EXCITED ABOUT THIS.
WE'RE GOING TO HOLD THAT FOR
THE
END.
(GROANING).
Speaker: IT'S GOING TO BE  GOOD.
Dan Sandler:  LET'S GET
STARTED,
ROMAIN, AND TALK  ABOUT UI AND
GRAPHICS.
Romain Guy:  YES, LET'S  START.
THE FIRST FEATURE WE WANT TO
TALK ABOUT IS ONE THAT YOU  SAW
THIS MORNING IN ONE OF  THE
KEYNOTES.  CHET, THIS  CLICKER
DOES NOT WORK.  YOU  DIDN'T TEST
IT.
[ LAUGHTER ]
Chet Haase:  YOU KNOW, YOU
KNOW -- WASTING TIME.
I'M GOING TO STAND BACK HERE
AND
DO THE SLIDES FOR YOU.
Romain Guy:  ALL RIGHT.  GO  TO
THE NEXT SLIDE.
Dan Sandler:  THIS IS WHY  THEY
DIDN'T WANT TO GIVE US A
CLICKER.
[ LAUGHTER ]
Romain Guy:  SO IF YOU --
Dan Sandler:
Chet Haase:  IT WORKS FOR ME.
Romain Guy:  JUST GO BACK
THERE.
I DON'T WANT TO SEE  YOU.
SO THE FIRST FEATURE THAT YOU
SAW THIS MORNING IN ONE OF  THE
KEYNOTES, PICTURE IN  PICTURE,
IS
NOT JUST FOR TV  ANYMORE.  IT'S
ALSO FOR YOUR  PHONE.   HERE WE
HAVE AN  EXAMPLE WITH
THIRD-PARTY
APPLICATION, NETFLIX, RUN
ONGOING YOUR PHONE, PICTURE  IN
PICTURE.
GIVE ME THAT CLICKER.
Chet Haase:  LET'S MOVE BACK.
THERE WE GO.
Romain Guy:  IT'S REALLY EASY
TO
IMPLEMENT IN YOUR  APPLICATION.
YOU JUST HAVE  TO MODIFY YOUR
MANIFEST.  AND  STOP PLAYING THE
ANIMATION,  PLEASE.
YOU JUST HAVE TO SAY SUPPORT
PICTURE IN PICTURE TRUE, YOU
DON'T NEED TO RESIZE THE
ACTIVITY PICTURE TRUE  ANYMORE,
AND YOU SHOULD ALSO  TEST
CONFIGURATION CHANGES.
AND IN YOUR CODE, WHEN YOU  WANT
TO ENTER THE PICTURE IN  PICTURE
CODE, YOU HAVE ONE  CALL, YOU
CALL ENTER PICTURE  IN PICTURE.
SUPER SIMPLE AND  IT'S GOING TO
MAKE YOUR USERS  SUPER HAPPY.
A FEATURE DEAR TO MY HEART,
MANAGEMENT, ADDING SUPPORT --
IT
WILL ONLY BE ON DEVICES  THAT --
WE'LL ENABLE IT FOR  YOUR
APPLICATION.  ADDING  SUPPORT
FOR
16-BIT PNG FILES,   WIDER
COLORS,
MORE SATURATED.   WE SUPPORT ICC
PROFILES,  COLORS IN --
IF WILL ENSURE ACCURATE
RENDITION OF COLORS ACROSS
MULTIPLE SCREENS.
WE ALSO HAVE A BUNCH OF NEW
APIs WHICH WE'RE GOING TO  TALK
ABOUT MORE AT THE END OF  THE
WEEK IN A DIFFERENT TALK.
SO BECAUSE A PICTURE IS WORTH  A
THOUSAND WORDS, THIS IS  COLOR
MANAGEMENT AND HOW IT  WORKS.
HOPE IT'S CLEAR.
.
[ LAUGHTER ]
BUT, REALLY, THE COLOR
MANAGEMENT IS ABOUT SOMETHING
YOU'VE PROBABLY EXPERIENCED
WITH
YOUR OWN APPLICATION,  YOUR
COLORS LOOK DIFFERENT  ACROSS
DEVICES, SO WE HAVE  SOLUTIONS
FOR YOU IN ANDROID  O.  SO IF
YOU
WANT TO KNOW  MORE, THERE'S
GOING
TO BE A  TALK THAT I'M GOING TO
GIVE  ON FRIDAY AT 11:30 ONSTAGE
2.   IT'S CALLED UNDERSTANDING
COLOR.
NEXT, WE'RE ALSO ADDING  SUPPORT
FOR MULTIPLE  DISPLAYS.  IF RUR
APPLICATION   IF YOUR
APPLICATION
IS ALREADY --  CLICKER IS
HORRIBLE -- IF  YOUR APPLICATION
SUPPORTS  MULTIPLE WINDOWS
ALREADY, THE  MULTIWINDOW MODE,
IT ALREADY  SUPPORTS MULTIPLE
DISPLAY IN  O.
WHEN THE PHONE IS CONNECTED  OR
AN ANDROID DEVICE IS  CONNECTED
TO MULTIPLE  DISPLAYS AND YOU
HAVE AN  APPLICATION THAT IS
COMPATIBLE, THE USER CAN SEND
THE APPLICATION ON A  DIFFERENT
DISPLAY.  WHEN THIS  HAPPENS,
YOU'RE GOING TO GET  RESIZING
CONFIGURATION  CHANGE.  YOU CAN
ALSO CONTROL  ON WHAT DISPLAY
YOUR ACTIVITY  SHOWS UP.  YOU
CAN
USE THE  ACTIVITY OPTIONS FOR
THAT.
AND YOU SHOULD REALLY TEST  YOUR
APP IF YOU WANT TO  SUPPORT THIS
FEATURE.
TO HELP YOU WITH TESTING, WE
HAVE TWO NEW DEVELOPER TOOLS,
YOU CAN RUST ABD SHELL  DUMPSYS.
IF YOU CALL ABD  SHELL START
WITH
YOUR  ACTIVITY INTENT.  YOU
CAN --  IT'S A VERY EASY WAY FOR
YOU  TO TEST THIS.
THERE'S A LOT MORE TO THOSE
APIs, SO WE ENCOURAGE YOU  TO
GO TO  THE OFFICE HOURS ON
FRIDAY AND THURSDAY, THE  OFFICE
HOURS FOR WINDOWS AND
ACTIVITIES.
NEXT, MEDIA.
[ LAUGHTER ]
SO WE HAVE A LOT OF VERY  USEFUL
CLASSES IN THE MEDIA  PACKAGE,
THE RECORDER, THE  EXTRACTOR AND
THE CODEC, WE  ADDED A NEW GET
METRICS API,  IT HELPS TO QUERY
ABOUT THE  MEDIA YOU'RE DEALING
WITH,  THE BIT RATE, THE CODEC,
THE  DURATION, THIS KIND OF DATA
.   IT'S SUPER EASY TO USE, JUST
THOSE
OBJECTS AND YOU GET THE
PERSISTIBLE BUNDLE AND YOU  CAN
LOOK UP THE DOCUMENT ON
DWEP.ANDROID.COM TO KNOW WHAT
KIND OF QUERIES ARE  AVAILABLE.
PLAYBACK IS ALSO MUCH  IMPROVED.
YOU NOW HAVE  CONTROL OVER THE
BUFFERING  NEW APPLICATION.  SO
YOU CAN  SPECIFY A LOW AND A
HIGH
WATERMARK.
SO THE PLAYBACK OF THE VIDEO
WILL NOT START UNTIL YOU  REACH
THE LOW WATERMARK, AND  THE
SYSTEM WILL DO ITS BEST  TO KEEP
CACHED DATA BETWEEN  THE SLOW
AND
THE HIGH  WATERMARK.  AND YOU
CAN
SPECIFY THE WATERMARKS IN
DURATION OR AMOUNT OF DATA IN
SIZE.
WE ALSO IMPROVED SEEKING.   SO
WHEN YOU SEEK INTO A  VIDEO, YOU
CAN NOW CHOOSE THE  BEHAVIOR, DO
YOU WANT TO SEEK  TO THE CLOSEST
FRAME, THE  NEXT KEY FRAME, TO
THE  PREVIOUS KEY FRAME, OR TO
THE  CLOSEST SYNC FRAME.
FINALLY, WE MADE THE DRM PLAY
PLAY  BACK IN WIDEVINE A LOT
EASIER  IN ALL OF YOUR
APPLICATIONS.
FOR RECORDING, UNTIL NOW, THE
MEDIA MIXER ONLY LETS YOU
HAVE -- SORRY, ADD ONE VIDEO
TRACK AND/OR ONE AUDIO TRACK.
NOW YOU CAN HAVE AS MANY  AUDIO
ENGINEER TRACKS AS YOU  WANT.
YOU CAN ALSO CREATE  CUSTOM
TRACKS.  THE  (INDISCERNIBLE)
HAS
TO START  WITH APPLICATION
SLASH,
AND  IT'S BASICALLY A SIDE BAND
WHERE YOU CAN INVOKE ANY KIND
OF
DATA YOU WANT.  TO -- TO
REPLACE
UP TO 16 VIDEO OR  SOMETHING
LIKE
THAT.
WEBVIEW COMES WITH  REALLY
USEFUL NEW APIs.  WE'VE  ADDED
THE ABILITY TO DO SAFE  BROWSING
THAT YOU KNOW AND  LOVE FROM
CHROME THAT DETECTS  MALWARES
AND
UNSECURE WEB  PAGES.  SO IF YOU
ADD THIS  TAG IN YOUR MANIFEST,
THIS  METADATA TAG, IT'S GOING
TO
USE THE SAME BACK END AND API
THAT CHROME ITSELF USES TO
SECURE THE BROWSING  EXPERIENCE
FOR YOUR USERS.
THE WEBVIEW USES NOW MULTIPLE
PROCESSES.  AND, IN  PARTICULAR,
THERE'S A RENDER  PROCESS.  WE
HAVE A NEW API  TO DEAL WITH
THESE MULTIPLE  PROCESSES.  IF
THE RENDERS  PROCESS CRASHES,
YOU
CAN USE  THE TERMINATION HANDLE
API TO  DETECT THE CRASH AND
DECIDE  WHAT TO DO IN YOUR
APPLICATION.  YOU CAN CRASH
YOUR
APPLICATION IF YOU  WANTED.  YOU
CAN TRY TO  RESTART THE WEBVIEW,
OR YOU  CAN JUST LOG SOMETHING
AND  SHOW A MESSAGE TO THE USER.
BEFORE.
YOU CAN USE THE RENDER
(INDISCERNIBLE) API TO BETTER
DEAL WITH THE LOW MEMORY
SITUATIONS.  SO WHEN THE  SYSTEM
IS LOW ON MEMORY, IT'S  GOING TO
TRY TO RECLAIM RAM  FROM
SOMEWHERE, AND YOU CAN  TELL THE
SYSTEM WHETHER YOUR  WEBVIEW IS
VERY IMPORTANT OR  NOT THAT
IMPORTANT TO YOUR  APPLICATION.
SO IF THE WEBVIEW IS CRITICAL
TO
YOUR APPLICATION, YOU  SHOULD
DEFINITELY TAKE A LOOK  AT THIS
API.
Chet Haase:  SO YOU KNOW IT'S
THE RIGHT BUTTON; RIGHT?
Romain Guy:  YES, I KNOW  THAT.
[ LAUGHTER ]
Chet Haase:  SO THERE WERE A
COUPLE OF LONG-REQUESTED
FEATURES FOR ANIMATORS,
SPECIFICALLY FOR ANIMATOR  SETS.
CEPTIVELY TRICKY TO  IMPLEMENT,
SO IT TOOK A  WHILE.  IN ANDROID
O, WE HAVE  THE CAPABILITY IN
ANIMATOR  SETS OF HAVING
SEEKING.
IF  YOU HAVE AN ANIMATOR THAT'S
A
COLLECTION OF CHILD  ANIMATORS,
YOU CAN SEEK  WITHIN THOSE CHILD
ANIMATORS  IN THE OVERALL
ANIMATORSET.   SO YAY.
WE ALSO HAVE THE ABILITY  --
[ LAUGHTER ]
-- TO REVERSE.
Romain Guy:  DIDN'T YOU TRY  TO
IMPLEMENT THOSE APIs A  WHILE
AGO?
Chet Haase:  MAYBE.
Romain Guy:  UH-HUH.  AND WHO
IMPLEMENTED THE APIs IN THE
END?
Chet Haase:  NOT ME.
Romain Guy:  EXACTLY.
[ LAUGHTER ]
Chet Haase:  OKAY.  SO NEW
CAPABILITY, AGAIN, IN
ANIMATORSET TO REVERSE.  SO  YOU
NO LONGER HAVE TO ,YOU  KNOW,
SET
UP A SEPARATE  ANIMATORSET WITH
ALL THAT  FUNCTIONALITY AND GET
A
LISTEN AND ALL THAT.  WE DO  ALL
OF THAT TEDIOUS WORK FOR  YOU.
SO YAY.
AUTOFILL, BECAUSE IT'S REALLY
TEDIOUS TO GET ALL THIS
INFORMATION CORRECT OVER AND
OVER, WE SAW THIS IN THE
KEYNOTE
EARLIER.  IT'S THE  ABILITY TO
--
YOU'VE GOT A  FORM TO FILL IN.
THERE'S A  PROVIDER THAT CAN
GIVE
YOU  THAT INFORMATION.  SO WHEN
YOU GET THOSE TEXT FIELDS, WE
CAN AUTOMATICALLY ENTER THAT
INFORMATION FOR YOU.  AND  THERE
ARE A COUPLE OF  DIFFERENT
ASPECTS TO THIS.   ONE IS THAT
YOU CAN CERTAINLY  IMPLEMENT
YOUR
OWN SERVICE  AND PROVIDE THAT
CAPABILITY  OR DEPEND ON SERVICE
THAT  QUEER PROVIDING -- THE
STANDARD VIEWS JUST WORK, IF
YOU'RE USING TEXTVIEW, IF
YOU'RE
USING EDIT TEXT, WE  KNOW HOW TO
RECEIVE THIS  INFORMATION,
INTERACT WITH  THE SERVICE
ALREADY.  SO YOU  DON'T NEED TO
DO ANYTHING FOR  STANDARD VIEWS.
IF YOU'RE USING CUSTOM VIEWS  OR
IF YOU WANT TO PROVIDE  MORE
INFORMATION ABOUT  STANDARD
VIEWS, WE HAVE  APIs FOR
PROVIDING HINTS TO  US ABOUT
WHAT
THE VALUE TYPES  ARE, AS WELL AS
APIs TO  TELL US MORE ABOUT
YOUR  CUSTOM VIEWS AND HOW YOU
WANT  TO INTERACT WITH THAT.
ALSO, IF YOU HAVE A CUSTOM  VIEW
HIERARCHY, LET'S SAY YOU  HAVE A
SURFACEVIEW, WHERE YOU  HAVE
VIEWS INSIDE OF THERE,  BUT ALL
WE KNOW IS THAT  THERE'S A
SURFACEVIEW, THEN  THERE ARE
APIs FOR YOU TO  TELL US ABOUT
THE VIRTUAL  HIERARCHY THAT YOU
WANT US TO  INTERACT WITH.
THERE IS GOING TO BE MORE  ABOUT
THIS IN A SESSION ON  FRIDAY
MORNING.  SO GO TO  THAT IF YOU
WANT TO LEARN  MORE ABOUT
AUTOFILL.
AND NOW LET'S TALK A LITTLE  BIT
ABOUT TEXT.  THERE'S BEEN  A
BUNCH OF STUFF GOING ON IN  THE
TEXT ARENA THIS TIME.  I  THINK
WE CAN REWRITE THIS.   THERE WE
GO.
[ LAUGHTER ]
I ONLY USE THAT FONT BECAUSE  IT
HURTS DAN.  IT JUST  PHYSICALLY
HURTS HIM.  IT'S  AWESOME.
Romain Guy:  I THINK YOU  BROKE
HIM.
Chet Haase:  ALL RIGHT.  SO,
FIRST OF
ALL, YOU CAN USE XML  TO
DECLARE FONT INFORMATION  USING
SORT OF A NEAT HACK  WITH DATA
BINDING.  BUT IT'S  KIND OF
TRICKY TO DO.  AND  WHY
SHOULDN'T
WE ACTUALLY  PROVIDE THAT
CAPABILITY FOR  YOU?
SO NOW WE DO.  SO YOU CAN NOW
ACTUALLY PUT A FONT FILE
DIRECTLY IN THIS NEW RESOURCE
FONT DIRECTORY.
[ CHEERS AND APPLAUSE ]
YAY, INDEED.
SO, PUT THAT IN THE  DIRECTORY,
OR YOU CAN TELL US  ABOUT THE
FONT FAMILY SO YOU  CAN PROVIDE
SEVERAL FONTS  WITH INFORMATION
ABOUT THE  STYLES OF EACH.  AND
THEN YOU  CAN JUST USE THOSE
DIRECTLY  AS YOU COULD ANY OTHER
AND FROM CODE, YOU JUST SAY,
GIVE ME THAT RESOURCE, AND  AWAY
YOU GO.
DOWNLOADABLE FONTS.  NOW WE
HAVE
THE CAPABILITY FOR YOU  TO
DECLARE A FONT THAT YOU  WANT TO
USE THAT WE WILL THEN  DOWNLOAD
AND CACHE ON THE  SYSTEM FOR YOU
IF IT IS NOT  THERE YET OR IF IT
IS ON    THE SYSTEM, THEN WE'LL
USE IT  FROM THE CACHE.
YOU CAN DO THIS FROM CODE OR
FROM XML AND USE IT AS A
RESOURCE, JUST LIKE YOU DID  IN
XML FONTS ON THE PREVIOUS
EXCITING SLIDE.
AND WE ALSO HAVE A FONT
PROVIDER
THAT WE ARE  PROVIDING IN A NOT
YET  RELEASED VERSION OF GOOGLE
PLAY SERVICES.  THERE IS A  BETA
VERSION OF THAT  AVAILABLE AT
THE
CONFERENCE  THIS WEEK.  I DON'T
KNOW THE  DETAILS ON THAT.  BUT
THERE'S  A SESSION WHERE YOU CAN
LEARN  THE DETAILS, OR YOU
SHOULD
BE  ABLE TO GO TO THE PLAY
SERVICES WEB SITE TO LEARN  MORE
ABOUT THAT.
AND THIS GIVES YOU ACCESS TO
ALL
THE OF GOOGLE FONTS.  SO  IF YOU
JUST WANT TO USE ONE  OF THE
STANDARD ONES, SUCH AS  THAT
BEAUTIFUL FONT I USED TO  KICK
OFF THIS SECTION, MAYBE  THAT'S
IN THERE, THEN YOU CAN  ASK
FOR
THAT DIRECTLY FROM  THE SERVICE.
ALSO, THERE'S THE ABILITY TO
HAVE AUTO-SIZING TEXTVIEW.   SO
TYPICALLY, IF YOU RESIZE A
TEXTVIEW --
[ CHEERS AND APPLAUSE
]
Dan Sandler:  YOU NEVER KNOW
WHAT'S GOING TO BE THE HIT;
RIGHT?
Chet Haase:  TEXT, TEXT IS
COOL.
Dan Sandler:  TEXT.
Chet Haase:  ESPECIALLY WHEN
IT'S IN THE RIGHT FONT.
SO WHAT YOU GET NOW IS THE
BEHAVIOR ON THE LEFT THERE,
WHERE WE'RE JUST RESIZING THE
VIEW ITSELF, THERE'S NO  CHANGE
TO THE   FONT.  BUT ON  THE
RIGHT, IF YOU OPT INTO  THE
AUTO-SIZING TEXTVIEW  BEHAVIOR,
THEN WE'RE GOING TO  RESIZE THE
FONT FOR YOU.  AND  YOU CAN
SPECIFY THE BEHAVIOR,  THE STEP
INCREMENTS THAT YOU  WANT TO
USE,
OR THE SPECIFIC  SIZE THAT YOU
WANT TO SNAP TO  AS IT RESIZES.
SO THERE'S  APIs FOR THAT.
THERE'S  APIs IN BOTH XML, AS
WELL  AS JAVA PROGRAMMING
LANGUAGE  CODES.  SO KNOCK
YOURSELF  OUT.
AND FOR ALL OF THESE TEXT
FEATURES, XML FONTS,
DOWNLOADABLE FONTS, AND
AUTO-SIZING TEXTVIEW, THEY'RE
TALKING ABOUT ALL OF THESE IN
THE WHAT'S NEW SUPPORTED
LIBRARY
SESSION.  AREN'T THEE  O
PLATFORM
APIs?  YES, THEY  ARE, AND THEY
ARE ALSO IN  SUPPORT LIBRARIES.
[ CHEERS AND APPLAUSE ]
SO YOU CAN USE ALL OF THESE
CAPABILITIES GOING BACK ON
EARLIER RELEASES.
ACCESSIBILITY SERVICE
UTILITIES.
IF YOU'RE WRITING  AN
ACCESSIBILITY SERVICE,  GREAT
THING TO DO, WE HAVE  NOW
CAPABILITIES THAT YOU CAN  TAKE
ADVANTAGE OF, LANGUAGE
DETECTION, THE ABILITY TO PUT  A
BUTTON IN THE NAVIGATION  BAR,
ALONG WITH THE OTHER  BUTTONS
THERE, TO MAKE IT  EASIER TO
ACCESS YOUR STUFF,  SEPARATE
VOLUME CONTROL FOR
ACCESSIBILITY
VOLUME SO  YOU'RE NOT CONFLATING
THAT  VOLUME WITH THE VOLUMES ON
THE DEVICES.  AND ALSO THE
ABILITY TO DEFINE CUSTOM
GESTURES, FINGERPRINT  GESTURES.
IF YOU WANT TO  LEARN ANYTHING
MORE ABOUT  THESE, THERE'S A
SESSION THIS  AFTERNOON ON
ACCESSIBILITY  THAT YOU SHOULD
CHECK OUT.
FINALLY, ONE OF MY FAVORITE
REALLY TINY CHANGES, I'M  GOING
TO SAY TINY BECAUSE  IT'S ONE
LINE OF CODE FOR THE  API.  BUT
THE ACTUAL CLs  THAT WENT IN TO
FIX ALL THE  CODE THAT WAS
DEPENDENT UPON  THE FORMER
IMPLEMENTATION WAS  HUGE.  SO I
DON'T WANT TO  DETRACT FROM THE
WORK FROM  IT.  BUT API-WISE,
KIND OF  TINY, HIDDEN, KIND OF
LOOKS  LIKE THE SAME THING FROM
THE  OUTSIDE.
THE WAY FINDVIEWBYID, AND  THEN
YOU CALL THAT, YOU PASS  IN YOUR
RESOURCE ID AND GET  BACK A
VIEW,
AND THEN YOU  IMMEDIATELY CAST
IT
INTO WHAT  YOU WANT.   SO
TEXTVIEW, YOU  HAVE TO TELL IT
TO
TEXTVIEW  ON BOTH THE LEFT AND
THE  RIGHT AND THERE'S
PARENTHESES  AND IT'S A BIG
BOTHER.   PEOPLE USE HELPER
LIBRARIES  JUST TO GET AROUND
THE
FACT  THAT THIS LOOKS SO
HORRIBLE.
SO NOW --
[ CHEERS AND APPLAUSE ]
-- WE HAVE THIS.
I CALL THIS FEATURE CASTAWAY.
I
THINK I AM THE ONLY ONE  THAT
DOES SO.
[ LAUGHTER ]
Dan Sandler:  ALL RIGHT.  MY
FIRST SLIDE.  I'M GOING TO
TALKS
A LITTLE BIT ABOUT SOME  OF THE
UI SYSTEM STUFF YOU'RE  GOING TO
LOOK AT.
IF YOU HAVE AN APP, YOU'RE
GOING
TO NEED TO KNOW ABOUT  ADAPTIVE
ICONS.  I THINK THIS  GOT BARELY
A MENTION IN ONE  OF STEPH'S
SLIDES EARLIER  TODAY.  BUT,
ESSENTIALLY,  THIS IS -- WE'RE
TRYING TO  SAVE YOU TIME AND
MONEY.   THERE ARE SO MANY
LAUNCHERS  OUT THERE, AND EACH
ONE OF  THEM HAS A DIFFERENT
RECOMMENDATION FOR THE SHAPE  OF
YOUR ICON.  SO ADAPTIVE  ICONS
IS
A NEW PIECE OF  TECHNOLOGY THAT
WE HAVE  BROUGHT TO YOU IN O
THAT
ALLOWS YOU TO SAY, HERE'S MY
BACKGROUND, HERE'S MY
FOREGROUND.  CUT IT OUT TO
WHATEVER SHAPE YOU LIKE.  SO
EVEN IF THE LAUNCHER HAS A
CIRCLE OR IT'S GOT A ROUND
RECTANGLE OR IT'S GOING
SOMETHING AWFUL, YOU HAVE AN
ICON THAT MATCHES EXACTLY THE
LOCAL -- THE LOCAL FLAVOR.
THERE'S GOING TO BE A TON  MORE
INFORMATION ABOUT  ADAPTIVE
ICONS
AT A TALK ON  THURSDAY.  AND
DEFINITELY GO  TO THAT ONE.
ALL RIGHT.  LET'S TALK ABOUT
SHORTCUTS AND WIDGETS,  BECAUSE
LAUNCHER IS ALSO PART  OF SYSTEM
UI.  PREVIOUSLY TO  GET
SHORTCUTS
AND WIDGETS ON  THE USER'S
SCREEN, THERE'S A  BROADCAST FOR
SHORTCUTS THAT  SORT OF, KIND OF
WORKS.  AND  FOR WIDGETS, YOU
HAVE TO BEG  THE USER, PLEASE,
PLEASE, SEE  IF YOU CAN FIND OUR
WIDGET  INSIDE THE LAUNCHER.
IN O, YOU CAN NOW ACTUALLY
REQUEST ONE OF THESE THINGS
TO BE PINNED TO THE USER'S
WORK SPACE USING SHORTCUT
MANAGER FOR SHORTCUTS, USING
APP MANAGER FOR WIDGETS.  AND
THE USER THEN GETS THE
OPPORTUNITY TO SAY NO, I
DON'T WANT THAT ON MY DESKTOP
OR YES I DO AND IN FACT I
WILL PLACE IT EXACTLY WHERE I
WANT IT OR THEY CAN SAY SURE,
I WANT TO FIND THE EXACT SPOT
FOR IT.  NOW YOU DON'T HAVE
TO SEND THEM INTO THIS LONG
FLOW.  IT'S SUPER CONVENIENT.
LOOK AT ALL THE USERS
YOU'RE GOING TO HAVE ON YOUR
WIDGETS.
[ CHEERS AND APPLAUSE ]
FOR AP APPLAUSE WHEN I'M REALLY
FUTZING WITH THE CLICKER
HERE.  THIS WE'LL TALK ABOUT
ON THURSDAY AT 4:30.
ALL RIGHT.  NOTIFICATIONS,
YOU KNEW IT WAS COMING.
THEY'RE SUPER USEFUL.
THEY'RE GREAT FOR GEAMENT,
USERS LOVE THEM.  ENGAGEMENT
THEY MAY
BE A LITTLE OUT OF CONTROL.
THERE'S A LOT BEING USED IN
THE NOTIFICATION STREAM RIGHT
NOW AND IT'S HARD FOR THE
USER TO MANAGE THE INFLOW OF
DEMANDS ON THEIR ATTENTION.
IF IT'S OUT OF CONTROL NOW
THE USER SHOULD ALWAYS BE IN
CONTROL.  THAT'S BEEN A
PRINCIPLE OF OURS SINCE THE
BEGINNING.   WEEDED THE
WE WE ADDED THE
ABILITY TO BLOCK, IN NOWGHT
WE NOUGAT
WE REFINED IT.  BUT THE
NUMBER ONE  REQUEST WE GET
FROM USERS IS, OKAY, BUT CAN
I JUST BLOCK SOME OF AN APP'S
NOITIONZ?  ON THE OTHER HAND
THE NUMBER ONE REQUEST WE GET
FROM DEVELOPERS IS COULD THE
USER JUST BLOCK SOME OF MY
NOTIFICATIONS.  IT'S THE SAME
THING.  EVERYBODY HAS BEEN
ASKING FOR THE SAME THING.
AND THIS IS WHERE
NOTIFICATION CHANNELS COME
FROM.  IT'S A NEW API IN O.
A CHANNEL IS A NAME CATEGORY
OF NOTIFICATIONS FROM ONE APP
THAT SHARES THE SAME
BEHAVIOR.  VIBRATION, SOUND,
LIGHT, SO THEY POP UP ON THE
SCREEN SO THE USER HAS
EXPLICIT AND FINE-GRAINED
CONTROL.
[ APPLAUSE
]
SO IT'S AN APP, YOU'LL GET TO
SET UP ALL THE CHANNELS,
DEFINE THE DEFAULT BEHAVIOR
FOR O AND A PRIVATE MESSAGE
SHOULD POP UP AND IN O, MAYBE
A TAG DOESN'T POP UP OR HAS A
LOWER PRIORITY.  AND USERS,
WHEN THEY LONG PRESS A
NOTIFICATION OR USE THE NEW
SLIDE GESTURE TO LOOK AT IT
THEY CAN SEE WHAT CHANNEL
IT'S ON AND MAKE CHANGES
RIGHT THERE IN LINE.
ONCE YOU TARGET O, IF YOU
TAKE NOTHING ELSE AWAY FROM
MY TWO MINUTES HERE, TAKE
AWAY THIS, YOU HAVE TO USE
CHANNELS FOR EVERY
NOTIFICATION OR THEY WILL BE
DROPPED.  SO UNTIL YOU TARGET
O, YOU CAN START, LIKE,
SLOWLY EVOLVING YOUR
NOTIFICATION SYSTEM OVER TO
CHANNELS.  ONCE YOU TARGET O,
THEY HAVE TO ALL BE
CHANNELIZED BECAUSE WE'RE
TRYING TO GET TO A CONSISTENT
EXPERIENCE WHERE THE HEUFER
KNOWS
GOING TO GET AND WOORS GOING TO
TALK ABOUT THAT AND A LOT OF
OTHER GREAT STUFF, ALL THE
CODE I DIDN'T PUT UP THERE,
WHATEVER THE LITTLE BLINKY
THING IS UP THERE ON THIS
TALK AT 4:30 TOMORROW.
THRAZ A LOT OF
THERE'S'S A LOT OF OTHER
GREAT STUFF.  IT RAN OFF
HERE.  I LIKE DOING THAT WITH
SLIDES.  AND I ENCOURAGE YOU
VERY MUCH TO CHECK OUT THE
DEVELOPER PREVIEWS AND PLAY
WITH THE BETA SNAWLG
INSTALLER.  WE'RE REALLY
PROUD OF IT.
Romain Guy:  AS DEVELOPERS,
WE EXPANDED ON THE STRICT
MODE API THAT I'M SURE YOU'RE
ALL USING IN YOUR DEBUGGING
SO NOW ON THE THREAD POLICY
YOU CAN USE IT WHEN YOU HAVE
UNBUFFERED I/O.  SO WHEN YOU
HAVE A INPUT/OUTPUT, YOU'LL
GET A FLASH OR WHATEVER IT
IS, THE TRIGGER WARNING YOU
SET.  ON THE VM POLICY IF YOU
DON'T TAG YOUR SOCKETS, YOU
CAN GET WARNED.  TAGGING
SOCKETS IS REALLY IMPORTANT
FOR TRAFFIC DEBUGGING IN
ANDROID STUDIO.  AND IF YOU
SET AN INTENT OUTSIDE YOUR
APPLICATION AND YOU NEED TO
GRANT PERMISSION, YOU CAN
ALSO BE WARRANTED.  SO IT'S
FAIRLY EASY TO USE.  IT LOOKS
LIKE THE PREVIOUS APIs WE
HAD.
MEDIA FILE ACCESS.  SO WE
INTRODUCED A DOCUMENT PRIFERS
A WHILE AGO, A COUPLE
RELEASES AGO AND THEY'RE
EXTREMELY USEFUL EXCEPT WHEN
YOU HAVE LARGE DOCUMENTS.  IF
YOU HAVE A LARNG DOCUMENT YOU
NEED IT TO DOWNLOAD THE
ENTIRE DATA BEFORE YOU CAN
PASS IT TO THE USERS OF THE
DOCUMENT PROVIDER.  SO NOW
YOU CAN USE SEEKABLE FILE
SCRIPTERS.  IT'S USEFUL FOR
VIDEO, AUDIO OR ANY CONTENT.
YOU GET THE STORAGE MANAGER,
YOU OPEN THE PROXY FILE
SCRIPTER, YOU INVOKE A CALL
BACK TO REQUEST SOME AMOUNT
OF DATA IN THE BAT ARRAY, AND
THEN WE'RE GOING TO TELL TELL
YOU WHEN TO CLOSE IT.
CACHED DATA.  SO THIS IS NEW
API THAT THE SYSTEM GIVES YOU
TO BE A BETTER CITIZEN.  SO
EACH APP HAS A CERTAIN AMOUNT
OF DATA IT CAN USE IN THE
CACHE PARTITION.  AND WHEN
THE SYSTEM RUNS OUT OF SPACE,
OUT OF STORAGE SPACE, IT'S
GOING TO START DELETING SOME
OF YOUR CACHED DATA.  SO IF
YOU STAY BELOW THE QUOTA THAT
YOU'RE GIVEN, YOU CAN AVOID
YOUR DATA BEING DELETED.
FOR THIS YOU CAN USE THE
STORAGE MANAGER.  YOU CAN
QUERY THE NUMBER OF BYTES
THAT ARE ALLOCATED TO YOUR
APP.  YOU SHOULD QUERY THAT
FROM TIME TO TIME BECAUSE THE
QUOTA CAN CHANGE DEPENDING ON
HOW MUCH OF THE QUOTA YOU USE
OR HOW OFTEN THE USER USES
THE APPLICATION.  THEN WHEN
YOU WANT TO ALLOCATE DATA YOU
CAN JUST USE ALLOCATE BYTES.
YOU CAN DO IT YOURSELF.  YOU
CAN CREATE A FILE, CREATE AN
OUTPUT STREAM BUT IT'S MUCH
BETTER TO DO IT THIS WAY
BECAUSE WHEN YOU GO THROUGH
ALLOCATE BYTES IF NEEDED IT
WILL DELETE ANOTHER APPS
CACHED DATA TO MAKE SPACE FOR
YOUR DATA.  SO THAT MEANS IT
COULD BE BIGGER THAN THE FREE
SPACE THAT'S LEFT ON THE
DEVICE.
YOU CAN ALSO USE SOMETHING
CALLED SET CACHE BEHAVIOR
TOMBSTONE.  SO THIS IS VERY
USEFUL TO -- FOR YOUR APP TO
BE ABLE TO TELL THE
DIFFERENCE BETWEEN A FILE
THAT WAS NEVER CACHED AND A
FILE THAT WAS CACHED BUT
DELETED.
SO WHEN YOU SET THAT BEHAVIOR
AND THE SYSTEM DELETES SOME
OF YOUR FILES IN YOUR KAMP,
CACHE
IT WILL TRUNCATE THE FILE.
SO THE FILE WILL STILL BE
THERE BUT THE SIZE WILL BE
SET TO ZOA.  THAT TELLS
ZERO.  THAT TELLS YOU
IT WAS DELETED BY THE SYSTEM.
Dan Sandler:  THERE'S A LOT
GOING ON IN ANDROID SECURITY
IN THIS RELEASE AND WE ONLY
HAVE A LITTLE BIT OF TIME TO
TALK ABOUT T I WANT TO
HIGHLIGHT SOME OF THE PRIVACY
IMPROVEMENTS THAT ARE NEW IN
ANDROID O.  IF YOU HAVE BEEN
USING ANDROID I.D., YOU NEED
TO KNOW NOW THAT IT IS GOING
TO BE DIFFERENT FOR EVERY
APP, FOR EVERY USER ON THE
DEVICE.  SO IT CAN'T BE USED
TO TRACK USERS BETWEEN APPS
ON THE SAME DEVICE ANYMORE.
SIMILARLY, IF USB YOU'VE BEEN
REFLECTING IN THE SYSTEM
PROPERTIES TO GET NET.HOST
NAME, IT IS EMPTY NOW.  SO IF
YOU ARE SAYING I REALLY NEED
ADVERTISING IDs TO BE ABLE
TO SEND USERS THE CORRECT
CONTEXTUAL ADVERTISEMENTS,
THAT IS WHAT THE ADVERTISING
ID API IN PLAY GOOGLE PLAY SFS
IS
FOR SO GO CHECK IT OUT IN
GOOGLE PLAY BUT YOU CANNOT
USE AN ANDROID ID.  YOU CAN'T
TRUST IT ANYMORE IN THE SAME
WAY YOU MIGHT HAVE DONE.
I HAD A SLIDE HERE ABOUT
WEBVIEW BUT THEN ROMAIN TOOK
IT.  ONE THING I WANTED TO
MENTION ABOUT SAFE BROWSING
IN WEBVIEW IS BECAUSE WEBVIEW
IS NOW PUSHED TO THE PLAY
STORE EVERY SIX MONTHS YOU'LL
BE ABLE TO OPT INTO SAFE
BROWSING FEATURES AS FAR ACAS
BACK
AS LOLLYPOP WHICH IS
FANTASTIC.
WE ALSO SAW IN THE KEYNOTE
SOMETHING CALLED GOOGLE PLAY
PROTECT WHICH IS A LOT OF THE
TECHNOLOGIES WE HAD IN PLACE
BEFORE BUT NOT GIVEN THE
VISIBILITY THEY TRULY DESERVE
BECAUSE WE ARE WATCHING OUT
FOR PEOPLE ALL THE TIME.  SO
ANY APP THAT GETS UPLOADED TO
PLAY IS PRESCREENED AND
CONTINUOUSLY RESCREENED FOR
EACH NEW VERSION THAT'S
UPLOADED.  AND EVERY TIME YOU
INSTALL AN APP WHERE YOU HAVE
PLAY PROTECT SET UP, THAT APP
IS GOING TO BE SCREENED AS
WELL EVEN IF YOU GOT IT FROM
ANOTHER STORE OR FROM, YOU
KNOW, ADB INSTALL.  AND WE'RE
REALLY EXCITED ABOUT THIS.
THERE IS SO MUCH MORE TO TALK
ABOUT, SO MUCH MORE TO TALK
ABOUT IN ANDROID SECURITY,
THEY GAVE ME A WHOLE, LIKE,
SLIDE DECK OF STUFF SO I SAID
WHY DON'T YOU HAVE YOUR OWN
TALK.  I ACTUALLY DIDN'T SAY
THAT.  THEY HAD THEIR OWN
TALK ANYWAY.  ON THURSDAY AT
WHAT'S NEW IN ANDROID
SECURITY EVERYTHING FROM SOUP
TO NUTS.
Romain Guy:  LANGUAGE AND
RUNTIME.  I THINK YOU ALREADY
KNOW WHAT I'M GOING TO SAY.
SO THIS MORNING WE ANNOUNCE
OFFICIAL SUPPORT FOR KOTLIN.
[ CHEERS AND APPLAUSE
]
YOU SAW STEPH ON STAGE, AND I
SEE HERE SITTING RIGHT THERE
IN THE HALLWAY.  SO IF YOU
SEE HER AT I/O, GO SAY
THANKS.  SO STEPH AND THE
WHOLE TEAM BEHIND HER DID AM
MAIGZ WORK OVER THE PAST, YOU
KNOW, HOWEVER MUCH TIME TO
BRING YOU THIS.  SO GO THANK
HER.  SHE'LL PASS YOUR THANKS
ALONG TO THE WHOLE TEAM.  SO
IT'S AVAILABLE TODAY IN
ANDROID STUDIO 3.0.  THERE'S
A LOT OF DOCUMENTATION
ONLINE.  I COULD SPEND HOURS
TALKING ABOUT KOTLIN AND WHY
IT'S GOOD FOR YOU, WHY IT'S
GOOD FOR US.
Chet Haase:  HE DOES, IN
FACT.
Romain Guy:  BUT
UNFORTUNATELY WE DON'T HAVE
THAT MUCH TIME IN THIS
SESSION.  SO INSTEAD I INVITE
YOU TO COME ON FRIDAY AT
10:30 HERE ON THIS STAGE.
THERE'S GOING TO BE A TALK
CALLED INTRODUCTION TO KOTLIN
FROM ANDREY BRESLAV, THE TECH
-- LEAD LANGUAGE DESIGNER AT
JETBRAINS, AND HADI, VP AT
JETBRAINS.
AND THEN IN THE AFTERNOON --
AND THEN IN THE AFTERNOON ON
STAGE 4, WE'LL HAVE LIFE IS
GREAT AND EVERYTHING WILL BE
OKAY, KOTLIN IS HERE, BY
CHRISTINA LEE FROM PINTEREST
AND JAKE WHARTON FROM SQUARE.
[ CHEERS AND APPLAUSE ]
AND THIS IS IMPORTANT TO US
BECAUSE THE REASON WHY WE
BROUGHT YOU KOTLIN IS BECAUSE
YOU THE COMMUNITY IS USING
KOTLIN.  WE LISTENED, WE
HEARD YOU.  WE'RE BRINGING
YOU WHAT YOU WANTED SO WE
WANTED TO HAVE YOU THE
COMMUNITY ON STAGE TO TALK
ABOUT IT BETTER THAN WE CAN.
ALSO, IF YOU HAVE QUESTIONS
YOU CAN COME TO THE DEVELOPER
SANDBOX AT THE ANDROID CORE
PLATFORM BOOTH TODAY FROM
3:00 TO 4.30 ON THURSDAY FROM
TWO TO FOUR, AND ON FRIDAY
FROM NOON TO 2:00 P.M, ANDREY
THE LANGUAGE DESIGNER WILL BE
THERE TO ANSWER YOUR
QUESTIONS.  SO ANYTHING YOU
WANT TO KNOW ABOUT KOTLIN,
PLEASE GO THERE AND ASK YOUR
QUESTIONS.
NOW, LIKE STEPH MENTIONED
WE'RE ALSO DOUBLING DOWN ON
THE OTHER LANGUAGES, SO THE
JAVA PROGRAMMING LANGUAGE AND
WE ALSO 72C AND COMPLUS SOY
FOR THE JAVA PROGRAMMING
LANGUAGE WE HAVE JAVA.TIME
THAT MAKES MANIPULATING TIME
AND DATES EASY AND IT MAKES
SENSE.  IT MAKES A LOT MORE
SENSE THAN THE OTHER APIs.
IT'S ABOUT TIME.  WE'RE ALSO
BRINGING YOU JAVA.NOI.FILE.
IT IMPROVES ON THE.  IT GIVES
YOU THE ATTRIBUTES OF THE
FILE.  IT LETS YOU EASILY
MANIPULATE PATHS.  WIELDS
GIVE YOU AN EXAMPLE.  AND
SLIGHT REFOR EXAMPLE, THIS IS
AN APPROXIMATION BUT IT'S
REALLY COOL BECAUSE IT LET'S
YOU TRANSFORM AND WRAP METHOD
HANDLES IN YOUR APPLICATION.
SO HERE'S AN EXAMPLE OF THE
NEW FILES API.  SO YOU CAN
USE THE PATH CLASS TO GET A
PATH.  AND THEN YOU CAN JUST
CALL FILES THAT LINES, IT
WILL READ THE ENTIRE CONTENT
OF THE FILE.  YOU ARE GOING
TO GET A STREAM.  SO IN THIS
EXAMPLE I AM USING
(INDISCERNIBLE) AND STRING
STRING APIs TO REMOVE ALL
THE LINES THAT START WITH THE
POUND SIGN AND I COLLECT
EVERYTHING BACK INTO A SINGLE
STRING AT THE END.  SO IT'S A
LOT EASIER THAN IT WAS
BEFORE.
Chet Haase:  WE HAVE SOME
CHANGES IN RUNTIME.  WE HEARD
ABOUT SOME OF THESE THIS
MORNING AND.  NEW CONCURRENT
COPYING COLLECTOR MAKING
EVERYTHING FASTER AND BETTER.
IT MEANS NO PAUSE TIME EXCEPT
WHEN THERE'S A FULL TPUS C SO
IT CAN DO ALL THE STUFF IT
NEEDS TO DO THE BACKGROUND
WHILE YOU'RE DOING OTHER
STUFF.  IN PARTICULAR, ONE OF
THE REALLY COOL THINGS THAT
IT CAN DO IS ACTUALLY COMPACT
THE HEAP IN THE FOREGROUND.
SO PREVIOUSLY IN R, I BELIEVE
IN THE PREVIOUS RELEASE, IT
HAD THE ABILITY TO COMPACT
THE HEAP, IT CAN MAKE THE
HEAP SMALLER, IT CAN MAKE
ALLOCATIONS AND COLLECTIONS
FASTER BUT ONLY WHEN
ACTIVITIES WERE IN THE
BACKGROUND.  SO IT WILL GO
INTO AN IDLE STATE AND DO IT
WHEN IT WAS IN THE IDLE STATE
BUT WHEN IT WAS IN THE
FOREGROUND, THERE WAS NOTHING
IT CAN DO.  NOW IT CAN
COLLECT AND DEFRAG IN THE
FOREGROUND AND EVERYTHING IS
FASTER.  THERE'S ALSO A NEW
FASTER MECHANISM FOR
ALLOCATIONS SO IT CAN US J DO
BUMP POINTER ALLOCATIONS
WHICH IS MUCH, MUCH FASTER.
COLLECTIONS ARE FASTER AND
ALL OF THIS ESSENTIALLY
RESULTS IN LESS JANK FOR YOU.
SO FASTER TO ALLOCATE STUFF,
FASTER TO COLLECT STUFF MEANS
THAT JUST DEALING WITH
GARBAGE AND MEMORY IN GENERAL
IS MUCH FASTER USING ART IN
THE O RELEASE.
VARIOUS
OPTIMIZATION SES.
DALVIK WITH REN JAITD WITH
MEMORY SCYTHE TIGHT
CONSTRAINTS.  EVERYTHING WAS
ABOUT SAVING MEMORY WITH
DALVIK WHICH MEANS IT CAN
ONLY DO SO MUCH OPTIMIZE MIEZ
SAYINGS.  WHEN ART CAME
ONLINE THEY PUT IN A PLATFORM
UPON WHICH WE COULD BUILD
FUTURE OPTIMIZATIONS.  SO
WE'RE STARTING TO REAP THOSE
BENEFITS NOW WHERE WITH EVERY
RELEASE, INCLUDING O AND
FUTURE RELEASES, WE'RE GOING
TO BE ABLE TO DO MORE AND
MORE.  AND THERE'S A BUNCH OF
THEM IN THIS RELEASE AND YOU
SHOULD CHECK OUT A SESSION
LATER IN THE WEEK FOR MORE
INFORMATION ON THAT.  ALSO
THERE'S DEX LOCALITY.  THIS
IN PARTICULAR IMPROVES LAUNCH
TIME FOR ACTIVITIES BECAUSE
WE CAN COLLECT ALL THE MEMORY
IN THE SAME SPACE.  SO IT'S
EASIER AND FASTER TO ACCESS
AS YOU'RE APPLICATION IS
STARTING UP.
SO THERE'S A SESSION ON
FRIDAY MORNING, PERFORMANCE
AND MEMORY IMPROVEMENTS.  SO
CHECK THAT OUT FOR MORE
PARTICULARS THERE.
SO BEYOND THE PLATFORM, WE
HAVE SUPPORT LIBRARY, WE HAVE
OTHER MECHANISMS FOR
DELIVERING THINGS THAT AREN'T
JUST ABOUT THE O RELEASE.  WE
WANTED TO CALL OUT SOME OF
THOSE.  THERE'S THE v26
BETA RELEASE THAT COMES OUT
WITH DEVELOPER PREVIEW TWO.
THE STUFF WE ALREADY TALKED
ABOUT IN TEXT.  FONTS IN XML,
DOWNLOADABLE FONTS AS WELL AS
AUTO SIZING TEXTVIEW.  THOSE
ARE ALL IN THERE.  YOU CAN
CHECK THOSE OUT.  IN ADDITION
THERE'S SOMETHING WE CALL
MOIJ COMPAT.  SO
EMOJICOMPAT.  ONE OF THE BIG
PROBLEMS WE HAVE WITH EMOJIS
IF YOU HAVE FRIENDS SENDING
YOU SOMETHING FROM EMOJIS
FROM A FUTURE STANDARD,
YOU'RE NOT GOING TO SEE THOSE
AND YOU'RE GOING TO SEE TOFUS
INSTEAD.  WHICH GIVEN SOME OF
THE EMOJIS, MAY BE MORE
ATTRACTIVE BUT NOT VERY
MEANINGFUL.  SO WOULDN'T IT
BE GREAT IF YOU COULD GET
UPDATED MOIDGES ON YOUR
DEVICE.  SO NOW WE HAVE TWO
MECHANISMS THAT DEVICES CAN
USE TO GET UPDATED EMOJIS.
ONE IS IT CAN BUNDLE WITH
UPDATED MOIFNLINGS SO THEY
CAN UPDATE THE APPS TO THE
PLAY STORE AND THEN TO THEIR
USERS SO THE USERS GET MORE
TIMELY UPDATES OF THESE
EMOJIS.  THE OTHER, AND
PROBABLY BETTER CERTAINLY
LONG-TERM SOLUTION, IS TO
ACTUALLY USE A SERVICE WE CAN
PROVIDE THROUGH DOWNLOADABLE
FONTS WE TALKED ABOUT EARLIER
WHERE THEY CAN AUTOMATICALLY
GET UPDATED FONTS THROUGH
DOWNLOADABLE FONTS; RIGHT?
SO THEY CAN -- THE APP CAN
BUILD IN THE CAPABILITY TO
USE THE DOWNLOADABLE FONTS
CAPABILITY TO HAVE UPDATED
EMOJIS AS WE PROVIDE THEM
INTO THE SERVICE.
SO AGAIN, GO TO THE WHAT'S
NEW IN SUPPORT LIBRARY TALK
TOMORROW MORNING TO LEARN
MORE ABOUT ALL OF THOSE.
WE ALSO HAD MORE STUFF GOING
ON IN ANIMATION BESIDES THE
SMALL STUFF IN ANIMATORSET I
TALKED ABOUT EARLIER.  WE
HAVE THE ABILITY TO NOW HAVE
PHYSICS-BASED ANIMATION
STUFF.  SO IF WE WANT TO SEE
THAT IN ANIMATION FORM.  THE
ABILITY TO HAVE ESSENTIALLY
ANIMATIONS DRIVEN THROUGH
VELOCITY, ALL THE ANIMATION
ABILITIES WE HAVE IN THE
PLATFORM TO DATE HAVE BEEN
DRIVEN AROUND THE IDEA OF A
DURATION.  YOU TELL IT HOW
LONG YOU WANT IT TO RUN FOR,
BUT MANY ANIMATIONS, YOU
REALLY WANT TO DRIVE IT BY
THE VELOCITY IN PARTICULAR,
ANIMATIONS THAT ARE DRIVEN BY
USER INTERACTIONS.  YOU'RE
DRAGGING SOMETHING ON THE
SCREEN AND YOU LET GO.
WOULDN'T IT BE NICE IF IT
TOOK OFF FROM YOUR FINGER AT
THE SAME VELOCITY THAT YOU
ARE WERE CRAGGING IT DRAGGING
IT WHEN YOU
LET GO.  SO FLINGS, SCROLLS,
ALL THAT STUFF, IT REALLY
REQUIRES A VELOCITY-BASED
ANIMATION SYSTEM INSTEAD.
YOU CAN DO THAT WITH THE
ANIMATORS BUT IT'S REALLY
TEDIOUS.  IT REQUIRES MATH.
MATH IS HARD.  AND SO WE
BAKED IN THAT CAPABILITY TO
THIS NEW PHYSICS ANIMATION
SYSTEM THAT IS MORE NATURAL,
MORE INTERACTIVE AND MORE
INTERRUPTIBLE BECAUSE IT WAS
REALLY INTENDED TO WORK WITH
THAT USER INTERACTIVITY
MODEL.  HERE IS A DEMO OF
THIS.  SO AS WE'RE DRAGGING
THE TOP THING AROUND, THE
OTHER CIRCLES ARE HINGED TO
THE TOP ONE THROUGH SPRINGS
YOU DEFINE SO THEY FOLLOW IT
IN SPACE.  THEY'RE NOT LOCK
STEP FOLLOWING IT BUT THEY'RE
BASICALLY ON SPRINGS THAT ARE
ATTACHED AND THEY IMMEDIATELY
BENEFIT FROM THAT INTERACT
ACTIVITY.  SO THERE'S A TALK
BASED ON THIS FRIDAY
AFTERNOON, ALL ABOUT THE NEW
PHYSICS BASED ANIMATION
STUFF.  PLEASE COME THAT IF
YOU WANT TO KNOW MORE ABOUT
THAT.
ART-BASED, THIS WAS MENTIONED
IN THE KEYNOTES.  WE THOUGHT
SOMETIMES ANDROID DEVELOPMENT
IS A LITTLE HARDER THAN IT
NEEDS TO BE SO WE TOOK A STEP
BACK AND SAID OKAY WHAT ARE
SOME OF THE MAJOR PROBLEMS WE
SHOULD TAKE ANOTHER RUN AT TO
START TO SIMPLIFY THIS TO FOR
APP VERLTS AND A COUPLE OF
THESE WE HAVE TAKEN RUNS AT
RIGHT NOW ARE AROUND LIFE
CYCLE.  IT'S APPARENTLY HARD
TO DEAL WITH THE FACT THAT
YOUR ACTIVITIES CAN DIE
ANYTIME WHEN YOU ROTATE THE
STREEN OR GOES IN THE
BACKGROUND OR WHATEVER AND
FINDING OUT EXACTLY WHAT
STATE YOU'RE IN CAN BE A BIT
TEDIOUS.  IT IS AN ONGOING
ISSUE ALL APP DEVELOPERS NEED
TO DEAL WITH SO WE'VE TAKEN
ANOTHER APPROACH TO THAT TO
MAKE IT MUCH EASIER AND IN
ADDITION TO THAT WE'VE TAKEN
A LOOK AT PERSISTENCE SO.  SO
WE HAVE A NEW WAY OF DOING
THAT THAT BUILDS ON THAT
CAPABILITY AND MAKES IT
EASIER AND MORE POWERFUL.
AND WE'RE GOING TO YOU CAN AT
THAT ABOUT ALL OF THOSE THIS
WEEK.  WE'RE GOING TO HAVE AN
INTRODUCTION TO ARCHITECTURE
COMPONENTS I WOULD ENCOURAGE
YOU TO GO TO THIS AFTERNOON.
THAT'S ACTUALLY IMMEDIATELY
AFTER THIS SESSION.  AND THEN
TOMORROW MORNING WE'RE GOING
TO HAVE ONE ON THE LIFE CYCLE
PROBLEM AND HOW WE'VE SOLVED
THAT AND WE'RE ALSO GOING TO
HAVE ONE ON PERSISTENCE AND
OFFLINE.  AND ALL OF THESE
ARE BITS THAT YOU CAN
ACTUALLY TRY OUT IN AN EARLY
RELEASE FORM ALREADY.  SO
CHECK THOSE OUT.  HOPEFULLY
IT WILL MAKE YOUR DEVELOPER
LIVES EASIER.
THERE ARE SOME BEHAVIOR
CHANGES SOME OF WHICH YOU'RE
GOING TO CARE ABOUT MORE THAN
OTHERS.  THERE HAVE BEEN SOME
CHANGES TO THE BEHAVIOR OF
BACKGROUND APPLICATIONS; IN
PARTICULAR, ROGUES LOCATION.
IF YOU
ARE RUNNING AS A BACKGROUND
APPLICATION YOU ARE ONLY
GOING TO GET COARSE GRAINED
LOCATION INFORMATION.  ALL OF
THESE THINGS ARE BEING DONE
NOT TO NEIGHBORING IT HARDER
BUT TO MAKE THE DEVICE
BETTER.  IF ALL APPLICATIONS
HAVE LOCATION AT ANY TIME AND
THEY CAN DO WHATEVER THEY
WANT TO AT ANY TIME THEN
ESSENTIALLY YOU'RE GOING TO
RUN THE BATTERY DOWN BECAUSE
EVERYBODY USING BARYT BATTERY
ALL
THE TIME.  SO WE'RE TRYING TO
BE JUDICIOUS ABOUT WHICH
APPLICATION NEEDS IT AT WHAT
TIME SO YOU CAN MAKE THE
EXPERIENCE FOR YOUR USERS
MUCH BETTER AS HE WILL.  SO
ONE OF THOSE IS IN LOCATION,
COARSE GRAINED INFORMATION
WHEN YOU'RE IN THE
BACKGROUND.  ANOTHER ONE IS
ONEBOX.  WE
WAKELOCKS.  WE NOTICED IT IS
COMMON FOR AN APPLICATION TO
GO INTO A CACHE STATE AND TO
WOULD JUST KEEP THAT WAKELOCK
AND IT WOULD HOLD IT FOR A
REALLY LONG TIME AND THAT
REALLY RUNS THE BATTERY YOU
DOWN.
SO NOW SOMETIME AFTER YOU GO
INTO A CACHE STATE THE
WAKELOCK IS AUTOMATICALLY
RELEASED SO IT DOESN'T PUT
THE DEVICE INTO THAT UNSEEMLY
STATE.
AND ALSO THERE ARE LIMITS TO
EXECUTION WHEN YOU'RE RUNNING
IN THE BACKGROUND.  THERE
HAVE ALSO BEEN CHANGES TO
ALERT WINDOWS.  IN
PARTICULAR, THERE'S THIS NEW
TYPE OF WINDOW CALLED TYPE
APPLICATION OVERLAY.  IF YOU
ARE TARGETING THE O SDK, THEN
THIS IS THE WINDOW TYPE YOU
MUST USE IF YOU WANT TO HAVE
AN ALERT WINDOW CAPABILITY.
IF YOU'RE ON EARLIER
RELEASES, OBVIOUSLY THAT
DIDN'T EXIST, YOU'RE NOT
GOING TO USE THIS.  JUST KNOW
THAT WHATEVER WINDOW TYPE
YOU'RE USING IS GOING TO BE
LAYERED UNDER ONE OF THESE
TYPE OVERLAY WINDOWS BECAUSE
WE HAVE A MORE CLEARLY
DEFINED LAYERING POLICY NOW
WITH THAT.
THERE IS MORE INFORMATION
ABOUT THIS THIS AFTERNOON AT
5:00, BACKGROUND CHECK AND
OTHER INSIGHTS.  SO PLEASE
COME TO THAT IF YOU WANT TO
KNOW ALL THE DETAILS ABOUT
THAT.
AND THEN FINALLY, WE PROMISED
TO GET BACK TO THIS, DIDN'T
WE?
Dan Sandler:  WE DID.  THIS
IS ONE ONE MORE THING; RIGHT?
Chet Haase:  SO WE WERE GOING
TO TALK ABOUT "THIS."  AND I
MEAN, WE HAVE TO HAVE A DRUM
ROLL, DON'T WE?  HOW ABOUT
LIKE A THIGH ROLL?  CAN WE
HAVE A THIGH ROLL?
ALL RIGHT.
Dan Sandler:  THAT SOUNDS
NICE.
Chet Haase:  UNFORTUNATELY
I'M LOOKING AT THE TIMER ON
STAGE AND I'M GOING TO SAY
THAT O STANDS FOR -- OH, NO,
WE'RE OUT OF TIME.
THANK YOU.!
[ APPLAUSE
]
(SINGING HAPPY
BIRTHDAY).
HAPPY BIRTHDAY DEAR ROMAIN,
HAPPY BIRTHDAY TO YOU.
Romain Guy:  THANK YOU!
[ CHEERS AND APPLAUSE
]
ES
[ APPLAUSE ]
Sridhar Ramaswamy:  THANK YOU.
GOOD AFTERNOON, EVERYBODY.  MY
NAME IS SRIDHAR.  THANK YOU FOR
JOINING ME HERE TODAY.
IT'S REALLY GREAT TO HAVE I/O
RIGHT IN OUR BACKYARD AT
SHORELINE AGAIN.
IT'S A REAL HIGHLIGHT FOR ME.
I
GET TO MEET OTHER ENGINEERS,
DEVELOPERS, AND PRODUCT
WORLD
AND CHECK OUT ALL THE AMAZING
THINGS THAT YOU ARE BUILDING.
I
HAVE HAD A CHANCE TO TALK TO
SOME OF YOU.  AND I'M IN AWE OF
ALL THE CREATIVITY THAT iOS
SEEN. I'VE
SEEN.
YOU REPRESENT THE BEST
DEVELOPERS THAT ARE OUT THERE.
I'M SURE THAT THE CREATORS OF
THE NEXT POKEMON GO, FLIPKART,
OR AIRBNB ARE RIGHT HERE IN
THIS
AUDIENCE.  BUT CREATING A
SUCCESSFUL BUSINESS TAKES MORE
THAN JUST AN AWESOME PRODUCT.
ALL OF YOU KNOW THAT.
I KNOW OF MANY GREAT PRODUCTS
THAT, LIKE, AREN'T REALLY
AROUND
BECAUSE THEY ARE NOT ABLE TO
GET
ENOUGH USERS OR MAKE ENOUGH
MONEY.
SO FOR MY TEAM HERE AT GOOGLE,
OUR MISSION IS CRYSTAL CLEAR.
WHAT CAN WE DO TO HELP YOU TURN
YOUR AMAZING PRODUCTS INTO
PROFITABLE BUSINESSES?  TODAY
WE'RE GOING TO DISCUSS THREE
THINGS YOU NEED TO FOCUS ON TO
GET THERE.
NUMBER ONE IS DEVELOPING
SEAMLESS PAYMENT EXPERIENCES.
NUMBER TWO, EARNING MORE FROM
YOUR APPS.  AND NUMBER THREE,
GROWING BY FINDING MORE OF YOUR
BEST CUSTOMERS.
WE'LL SHARE NEW PRODUCT
INNOVATIONS IN EACH OF THESE
AREAS TO HELP YOU DELIGHT YOUR
CUSTOMERS AND MAKE YOUR
BUSINESSES MORE SUCCESSFUL.
YOU'VE ALL HEARD THE SAYING,
"THE CUSTOMER IS ALWAYS RIGHT."
THEY ARE!  CONSUMER
EXPECTATIONS
ARE HIGHER THAN EVER BEFORE.
CONSUMERS ARE LOOKING FOR MORE
USEFUL AND MORE DELIGHTFUL
EXPERIENCES EVERY SINGLE DAY.
AND WITH BILLIONS OF MOBILE
USERS GLOBALLY, THE OPPORTUNITY
IN FRONT OF US IS PRETTY
AMAZING.  BUT THE SAME IS TRUE
FOR ALL OF YOUR COMPETITION,
TOO.  AND PEOPLE HAVE WAY MORE
CHOICE NOW THAN EVER BEFORE.
OVER 5 MILLION APPS, MANY, MANY
MORE SITES THAN THAT, HUNDREDS
OF TV CHANNELS, SOCIAL MEDIA,
IT
GOES ON AND ON.  SO HOW ARE YOU
GOING TO STAND OUT IN THIS SEA
OF AMAZING CHOICES?
JIM LYSKI, THE CMO OF CARMAX,
RECENTLY PUT IT THIS WAY:
CONSUMERS USED TO EVALUATE
THEIR
EXPERIENCES IN SILOS.  I'LL
COMPARE CARMAX AGAINST ALL
OTHER
USED CAR DEALERS, AND I'LL
COMPARE NORDSTROM AGAINST ALL
OTHER CLOTHING RETAILERS.
LET'S GO BACK ONE SLIDE,
PLEASE,
ONE SLIDE FORWARD.
BUT NOW PEOPLE ARE CLEARLY
TAKING THOSE BEST EXPERIENCES
FROM ONE INDUSTRY AND DEMANDING
THAT THEY RECEIVE THE SAME OR
BETTER EVERYWHERE.  IF THEY CAN
ORDER A VERY SPECIFIC CUP OF
COFFEE AND GET IT EVERY
MORNING,
WHY CAN'T THEY HAVE AN
EXPERIENCE THAT'S BESPOKE AND
CUSTOMIZED FOR THEM WHEN THEY
BUY A CAR?  THAT MAKES SENSE.
WITH SO MUCH COMPETITION AND
INCREASING CUSTOMER
EXPECTATIONS, YOU CAN'T WIN
CUSTOMERS WITH A ONE SIZE FITS
ALL APPROACH.
THIS REALLY CALLS FOR NEW
STRATEGIES THAT PUTS THE FOCUS
ON EACH INDIVIDUAL CUSTOMER.
IT
MEANS UNDERSTANDING YOUR
CUSTOMERS AND HOW THEY DIFFER.
IT MEANS CREATING GROWTH AND
MONETIZATION STRATEGIES THAT
REFLECT THOSE INSIGHTS.
AND IT MEANS USING TOOLS THAT
ARE POWERFUL AND FLEXIBLE
ENOUGH
TO ACT ON THAT INFORMATION.
AND THIS IS WHERE WE THINK WE
CAN HELP.  ONLY GOOGLE CAN
PROVIDE YOU WITH THE TOOLS AND
TECHNOLOGY THAT HELP YOU PUT
YOUR CUSTOMERS AT THE CENTER OF
HOW YOU DEVELOP, EARN, AND GROW
FROM YOUR PRODUCT.
TO START WITH, WE'RE HELPING
YOU
DEVELOP EASIER WAYS TO PAY FOR
YOUR PRODUCTS AND SERVICES.
HOW
MANY OF YOU HAVE ABANDONED A
SHOPPING CART ONLINE?  I DID
JUST YESTERDAY.  SOMETIMES IT
TAKES REALLY LONG TO CHECK OUT
OR YOU DON'T HAVE YOUR CREDIT
CARD HANDY.  EITHER WAY, IT'S A
PRETTY FRUSTRATING EXPERIENCE,
BOTH FOR YOU, YOU DIDN'T GET
WHAT YOU WANT DONE, AND FOR THE
BUSINESS THAT LOST YOUR MONEY.
PAYING ONLINE SHOULD BE EASY.
AND THAT'S ONE OF THE REASONS
WHY WE'VE MADE THIS A TOP
PRIORITY FOR GOOGLE.  OUR OPEN
PLATFORM APPROACH MAXIMIZES THE
WAY IN WHICH PEOPLE CAN PAY AND
THE WAYS YOU CAN GET PAID.  WE
WANT TO PROVIDE A SEAMLESS,
CONSISTENT EXPERIENCE ACROSS
DEVICES AND ACROSS PLATFORMS.
HUNDREDS OF MILLIONS OF PEOPLE
HAVE ALREADY SAVED THEIR
PREFERRED PAYMENT METHOD, LIKE
A
CREDIT CARD OR A DEBIT CARD, TO
THEIR GOOGLE ACCOUNT.  AND
TODAY
WE'RE GOING TO ANNOUNCE A
DEVELOPER SOLUTION THAT WILL
ALLOW PEOPLE TO USE THESE SAVED
CARDS WHEN CHECKING OUT IN YOUR
APPS, SITES, AND MORE WITH JUST
ONE SINGLE BUTTON.
PAYMENTS ARE A CRITICAL PART OF
THE CONVERSION PROCESS, AND WE
WANT TO HELP YOU MAKE IT AS
QUICK AND AS EASY AS POSSIBLE.
AND WHEN YOU MAKE IT EASIER FOR
PEOPLE TO PAY FOR WHAT THEY
WANT, YOU WIN.
IT'S REALLY THAT SIMPLE.
NEXT UP, EARNING MORE FROM YOUR
APPS.
WHILE SOME OF YOUR USERS MIGHT
MAKE IN-APP PURCHASES, LET'S
FACE IT, THE MAJORITY NEVER
REALLY DO.  AND THAT'S WHY
EARNING MONEY WITH IN-APP ADS
IS
THE MOST COMMON REVENUE MODEL
FOR MOBILE BUSINESSES.
ADMOB HELPS YOU DO THAT.
TODAY,
OVER A MILLION APPS USE ADMOB
TO
MAKE MONEY ON iOS AND ON
ANDROID.  IN FACT, TO DATE,
WE'VE PAID OUT OVER $3.5
BILLION
IN ADS REVENUE TO ADMOB
DEVELOPERS, LIKE YOU, MORE THAN
ANY OTHER AD NETWORK.
AND A TRULY CUSTOMER-CENTRIC
MONETIZATION STRATEGY MEANS YOU
MONETIZE DIFFERENT USER GROUPS
IN DIFFERENT WAYS.  FOR THAT,
YOU NEED A SOLUTION THAT'S
POWERED BY INSIGHTS, ONE THAT
OFFERS GREAT AD FORMATS,
EASY-TO-USE TOOLS, AND HELPS
YOU
SCALE TO MEET INCREASING GLOBAL
DEMAND.
AND TODAY WE'RE GOING TO SHOW
YOU A COMPLETELY REIMAGINED
ADMOB, REBUILT FROM THE GROUND
UP, BASED ON YOUR FEEDBACK TO
GIVE YOU ALL OF THAT AND MORE
FOR YOUR APPS.
AND LAST, BUT NOT LEAST,
GROWING
YOUR USER BASE.  FINDING
VALUABLE USERS ISN'T EASY.  LET
ME EXPLAIN.  I STILL LOVE
PLAYING WORDS WITH FRIENDS.  I
KNOW!  AND PART OF WHAT I LOVE
ABOUT THE APP IS THAT MY WIFE
AND I PLAY AGAINST EACH OTHER
PRACTICALLY EVERY DAY.  USUALLY
HAVE MULTIPLE GAMES GOING ON ON
ANY GIVEN MOMENT.  AND AFTER
PLAYING A TURN IN ONE GAME, YOU
HAVE TO VIEW AN AD BEFORE BEING
ABLE TO PLAY A TURN IN ANOTHER
GAME.
MY WIFE, WHO IS BLESSED WITH A
LOT OF PATIENCE, WILL WAIT
BETWEEN EACH GAME.  ON THE
OTHER
HAND, I PAID FOR THE PREMIUM
VERSION OF THE GAME THAT LET ME
SWITCH BETWEEN UNLIMITED GAMES.
MY WIFE AND I ARE TWO USERS WHO
INTERACT WITH APPS IN VERY
DIFFERENT WAYS, BOTH VALUABLE
BUT QUITE DIFFERENT.
AND AS A DEVELOPER, YOU NEED TO
VALUE US DIFFERENTLY.  TO THAT
END, YOU NEED A MARKETING TOOL
THAT KNOWS AND CAN HELP YOU PAY
THE RIGHT AMOUNT WHEN ACQUIRING
NEW CUSTOMERS WHO ARE LIKE ME
OR
LIKE MY WIFE.
THAT'S WHY WE INTRODUCED
UNIVERSAL APP CAMPAIGNS, WE
CALL
IT UAC FOR SHORT.  UAC MAKES IT
EASY TO FIND USERS WHO NOT ONLY
INSTALL YOUR APP BUT ACTUALLY
TAKE ACTIONS WITHIN THE APP.
UAC REACHES USERS ACROSS iOS
AND ANDROID ON EACH OF GOOGLE'S
BILLION-USER PROPERTIES LIKE
GOOGLE PLAY, GOOGLE SEARCH,
YOUTUBE, GMAIL, AS WELL AS THE
MILLIONS OF SITES AND APPS THAT
ARE ON OUR DISPLAY NETWORK.
AND RATHER THAN HAVING TO
MANAGE
MULTIPLE CAMPAIGNS AND MANUALLY
OPTIMIZING EACH ONE ACROSS
THESE
CHANNELS AND CONTEXTS, UAC DOES
THIS AUTOMATICALLY WITH ONE
SINGLE CAMPAIGN.
IT USES MACHINE LEARNING, AND
AI, TO IMPROVE AND MAKE YOUR
CAMPAIGN SMARTER WITH EVERY
SINGLE APP.  AND IT LEARNS FROM
COUNTLESS SIGNALS LIKE WHERE
PEOPLE ARE ENGAGING MOST WITH
YOUR APP AND WHICH CREATIVE
WORKS BEST, ALL IN REALTIME.
AND WITH OVER HALF A DOZEN
BILLION-USER PROPERTIES, WE
HAVE
THE POWER TO FIND YOUR USERS
WITH BOTH SIMPLICITY AND
MASSIVE
SCALE.  AND IT'S WORKING.
AT I/O LAST YEAR WE ANNOUNCED
THAT OUR APP ADS HAD DELIVERED
OVER 2 BILLION APP INSTALLS.
THIS YEAR, I'M PRETTY EXCITED
TO
SHARE THAT THIS HAS GROWN BY A
FACTOR OF 2.5 TO OVER 5 PLUS
BILLION APP INSTALLS.
BETTER YET, WE'RE NOW HELPING
ADVERTISERS DRIVE OVER 3
BILLION
IN-APP ACTIONS PER QUARTER.
THESE ARE REAL PEOPLE TAKING
REAL ACTIONS INSIDE YOUR APP.
UNIVERSAL APP CAMPAIGNS ARE
TRANSFORMING THE WAY DEVELOPERS
AND MARKETERS REACH AND ACQUIRE
THE RIGHT USERS, AND WE TRULY
THINK THIS IS THE FUTURE OF APP
GROWTH.
AND TO DELIVER MORE VALUE TO
DEVELOPERS AND MARKETERS, WE
ARE
BUNDLING ALL FUTURE APP GROWTH
INNOVATIONS RIGHT INTO UAC,
MAKING IT A ONE-STOP SHOP TO
GET
STUFF DONE.
I'M AN ENGINEER.  I'M REALLY
PROUD OF THESE NEW INNOVATIONS.
AND I'M EXCITED ABOUT HOW THEY
CAN HELP YOU UNDERSTAND AND
BETTER SERVE YOUR CUSTOMERS IN
ORDER TO STAND OUT IN WHAT'S A
REALLY COMPETITIVE ECOSYSTEM.
SO WITH THAT, I'D LIKE TO BRING
UP MY TEAM TO DIVE DEEPER INTO
THESE INNOVATIONS.  AND WE'RE
GOING TO KICK IT OFF WITH PALI
BHAT.  THANK YOU.
[ APPLAUSE ]
Pali Bhat:  THANKS, SRIDHAR.
HELLO, EVERYONE.  I'M PALI, AND
I'M THE PRODUCT LEAD FOR
PAYMENTS AT GOOGLE.  TODAY I
WANT TO SHARE HOW YOU CAN MAKE
IT EASY FOR YOUR CUSTOMERS TO
PAY FOR YOUR PRODUCTS AND
SERVICES WHILE GIVING THEM A
DELIGHTFUL EXPERIENCE.
NOW, YOUR CUSTOMERS EXPECT TO
ENGAGE WITH YOU WHEREVER THEY
ARE, WHETHER IT'S ON YOUR
MOBILE
WEB SITE OR ON YOUR APP OR IN
THE FUTURE THROUGH THE
ASSISTANT.
NOW, ACROSS ALL THESE SURFACES,
THEY EXPECT CHECKOUT TO BE FAST
AND EASY.  UNFORTUNATELY, THE
CHECKOUT SCREEN IS A SINGLE
BIGGEST SOURCE OF FRICTION IN
THE PURCHASE EXPERIENCE TODAY.
IN FACT, THE PROBLEM IS EVEN
MORE ACUTE ON MOBILE WHERE
CONVERGENCE ARE A FULL 1/3
LOWER
RELATIVE TO DESKTOP.  AND A
LARGE REASON FOR THAT IS
BECAUSE
THE EXISTING DESKTOP CHECKOUT
EXPERIENCE, WHICH HAS BEEN
OPTIMIZED OVER A PERIOD OF
20 YEARS, SIMPLY DOESN'T WORK
WELL ON MOBILE.
NOW, LAST YEAR WE ANNOUNCED OUR
FIRST SET OF SOLUTIONS TO THIS
COMPLEX ISSUE WITH ANDROID PAY
SERVING AS YOUR PASSPORT TO
GIVE
YOUR CUSTOMERS A STREAMLINED
CHECKOUT EXPERIENCE.  WE HAVE
SEEN TREMENDOUS PROGRESS OVER
THE LAST TEN MONTHS WITH
ANDROID
PAY NOW BEING AVAILABLE IN TEN
MARKETS AROUND THE WORLD.
I'M EXCITED TO ANNOUNCE THAT WE
ARE GOING TO BE BRINGING
ANDROID
PAY TO EVEN MORE MARKETS OVER
THE NEXT FEW MONTHS, INCLUDING
BRAZIL, CANADA, RUSSIA, SPAIN,
AND TAIWAN.
[ CHEERS AND APPLAUSE ]
WE HAVE ALSO SEEN TREMENDOUS
MOMENTUM ON THE APP SIDE WITH
THOUSANDS OF TOP DEVELOPERS
HAVING ADOPTED ANDROID PAY TO
DELIVER A SEAMLESS CHECKOUT
EXPERIENCE FOR THEIR USERS.
BUT WE HAVE THE OPPORTUNITY TO
BRING THIS EXPERIENCE TO EVEN
MORE USERS, AND WE CAN DO THAT
IN PARTNERSHIP WITH ALL OF YOU
IN THE PAYMENTS ECOSYSTEM.  SO
I'M EXCITED TO SHARE ONE OF THE
FIRST COLLABORATIONS THAT IS
GOING TO DELIVER A VERY, VERY
MEANINGFUL NUMBER OF USERS A
MUCH, MUCH BETTER CHECKOUT
EXPERIENCE.  WE'VE DONE THIS IN
COLLABORATION WITH OUR FRIENDS
AT PAYPAL WHERE PAYPAL USERS
ARE
GOING TO GET THE STREAMLINED
ANDROID PAY EXPERIENCE SIMPLY
BY
LINKING THE PAYPAL ACCOUNT TO
ANDROID PAY.  SO VERY EXCITED
ABOUT THIS.
SO LET ME SHOW YOU HOW THIS IS
GOING TO WORK ON THE MOBILE
WEB.
SO THINKING THROUGH WHAT I'M
GOING TO SHOW YOU ALL IN TERMS
OF, LIKE, BUYING SOMETHING,
USING PAYPAL AND ANDROID PAY IN
ACTION, I THOUGHT OF MY
8-YEAR-OLD.  EARLIER THIS WEEK
HE HAD A "DRESS YOUR COLOR" DAY
AT SCHOOL.  "DRESS YOUR COLOR"
MEANS YOU HAVE TO PICK YOUR
FAVORITE COLOR AND WHERE YOUR
ENTIRE OUTFIT IN THAT COLOR.
HIS FAVORITE COLOR IS BLUE.  SO
HE HAD ON BLUE JEANS.  HE HAD A
BLUE TOP.  HE HAD A BLUE
HOODIE.
AND, OF COURSE, BECAUSE IT
WASN'T BLUE ENOUGH, HE EVEN HAD
A HOMEMADE BLUE CAPE.  THE ONLY
THING THAT WAS MISSING WAS BLUE
SHOES.  SO I FIGURED I WOULD
SURPRISE HIM AND BUY HIM SOME
BLEW SHOES TODAY ON NIKE.COM.
LET ME SHOW YOU HOW THIS WORKS.
LET ME SWITCH TO THE PHONE,
PLEASE, FOR PAYPAL.
WONDERFUL.
SO I'M GOING TO BRING UP
NIKE.COM ON THE CHROME BROWSER.
AND I'VE ALREADY PICKED OUT THE
SHOES.  I'VE GOT SOME SUEDE
BLUE
SHOES.  WHEN I'M READY TO CHECK
OUT, I'M GOING TO CHECK OUT
WITH
PAYPAL AS USUAL.  AND YOU'LL
NOTICE THAT THAT GETS ANDROID
PAY GOING.  AND INSTEAD OF
HAVING TO HAVE TO ENTER MY USER
NAME OR PASSWORD, ALL I NEED TO
DO IS USE MY FINGERPRINT,
AUTHORIZE, AND I'M DONE.;
RIGHT?
NO MORE ENTERING YURN
USERNAMES OR
PASSWORDS OR HAVING TO CREATE
AN
ACCOUNT.  YOU SIMPLY HAVE TO
USE
YOUR FINGERPRINT.  NOW, THIS
EXPERIENCE IS GOING TO BE
COMING
TO MANY OF THE PAYPAL'S
MILLIONS
OF SITES OVER THE COMING FEW
MONTHS AND EVENTUALLY ROLL OUT
TO ALL OF THEIR SITES THAT HAVE
IMPLEMENTED PAYPAL.
NOW, LET'S SWITCH BACK TO THE
SCREEN.
THE SLIDES,
PLEASE.
CAN YOU SWITCH BACK TO THE
SLIDES, PLEASE?
HMM.
AWESOME.
WE WANT TO BRING THE SAME
EXPERIENCE TO VISA CHECKOUT AND
MASTERPASS USERS.  VERY EXCITED
ABOUT THAT.  AS EXCITED AS WE
ARE WITH ALL OF THE PROGRESS
THAT WE'VE SEEN IN ANDROID PAY,
WE KNOW THAT OUR OVER 1 BILLION
PLUS GOOGLE USERS DON'T ALL
HAVE
ANDROID PAY.  OR FOR THAT
MATTER, ANY DIGITAL WALLET.
HOWEVER, THESE GOOGLE USERS
FREQUENT POPULAR GOOGLE
PRODUCTS
LIKE GOOGLE PLAY AND YOUTUBE,
AND AS SRIDHAR MENTIONED HAVE
SAVED HUNDREDS OF MILLIONS OF
CREDIT CARD AND DEB AT THIS
TIME
CARDS TO THEIR GOOGLE ACCOUNTS.
SO TODAY WE WANT TO ANNOUNCE A
SIMPLE API FOR ALL OF YOU
DEVELOPERS OUT THERE TO BE ABLE
TO ACCEPT ALL OF THESE PAYMENT
METHODS THROUGH
GOOGLE.
AND DEVELOPERS WHO ADOPT THIS
API CAN ENABLE AN EASY-TO-USE
CHECKOUT EXPERIENCE FOR THEIR
CUSTOMERS.  AND, OF COURSE, AS
WE DISCUSSED EARLIER, REDUCE
THE
AMOUNT OF FRICTION WHICH CAN
LEAD TO HIGHER CONVERGENCE AND
MORE REVENUES.  BEST OF ALL,
THIS NEW DEVELOPER API, WHICH
WE
CALL THE GOOGLE PAYMENT API, IS
GOING TO BE FREE FOR
DEVELOPERS.
[ APPLAUSE
]
NOW, USERS DON'T NEED TO DO ANY
ADDITIONAL SETUP IF THEY'VE
ALREADY SAVED THEIR PAYMENT
METHOD TO GOOGLE.  THEY SIMPLY
SIGN IN AND GET THIS
STREAMLINED
CHECKOUT EXPERIENCE.  NOW,
WE'VE
BUILT THIS GOOGLE PAYMENT API
ON
TOP OF THE PAYMENT REQUEST
STANDARD WHICH IS NOW A W3C
SPEC.
NOW, DEVELOPERS CAN SIMPLY ADD
THIS PAYMENT GOOGLE BUTTON TO
THEIR FAVORITE WEB SITES OR
APPS
BY INTEGRATING WITH THE GOOGLE
PAYMENT API.
I WANT TO SHARE WITH YOU A
LITTLE STORY ABOUT THIS PAYMENT
GOOGLE BUTTON THAT YOU SEE
HERE.
THIS BUTTON IS VERY SIMILAR TO
THE SIGN-IN WITH GOOGLE BUTTON
THAT USERS ARE ALREADY USED.
TO.
AND OUR TEAM WAS BRAINSTORMING
ALL OF THE DIFFERENT VARIATIONS
THAT WE COULD POSSIBLY HAVE ON
THIS BUTTON, AND ONE OF MY
ABSOLUTE FAVORITE VARIANTS WAS
"TREAT YOURSELF WITH GOOGLE."
[ LAUGHTER
]
NOW, WE DIDN'T LAND ON THAT,
BUT
I THINK WE'VE GOT A REALLY GOOD
ALTERNATIVE WITH "PAY WITH
GOOGLE."
SO SPEAKING OF TREATING MYSELF,
I WANTED TO BUY SOME COOL NEW
HEADPHONES.  AND WISH IS
EXACTLY
THE PLACE TO GET IT.  SO WE'VE
BEEN DOING SOME WORK WITH OUR
FRIENDS OVER AT WISH TO ENABLE
THIS COOL PAYMENT GOOGLE
EXPERIENCE.  LET ME SHOW YOU
HOW
IT WORKS WITHIN THE APP.
CAN WE SWITCH TO THE WISH
PHONE,
PLEASE?  THANK
YOU.
SO LET ME BRING UP THE WISH
APP.
I'VE ALREADY ADDED THE COOL
BLACK HEADPHONES THAT I WANTED
TO MY CART.
AND WHENEVER I'M
READY TO PAY, I SIMPLY NEED TO
PICK MY FORM OF PAYMENT AND
HERE'S THE SPECIAL PART; RIGHT?
METHODS ALREADY ATTACHED TO MY
GOOGLE ACCOUNT.  YOU SEE THAT
PAYPAL ACCOUNT THAT I JUST USED
TO BUY THOSE COOL BLUE SHOES, I
HAVE THAT.  I HAVE THE
MASTERCARD THAT I HAVE ADDED TO
ANDROID PAY AND, OF COURSE, I
HAVE MY AMERICAN EXPRESS THAT I
HAVE SAVED TO MY GOOGLE
ACCOUNT.
SO I'M GOING TO CONTINUE AND
THAT'S IT.  I SLIDE TO PAY.;
RIGHT?  I DON'T NEED TO ENTER
ANY USERNAMES, REMEMBER
PASSWORDS, OR HAVE TO CREATE A
NEW ACCOUNT ON THE WISH SITE.
PAY WITH GOOGLE MAKES IT THAT
SIMPLE.  NOW, THE WISH TEAM IS
GOING TO BE ROLLING OUT THIS
"PAY WITH GOOGLE" EXPERIENCE TO
ALL OF THEIR USERS IN THE
COMING
WEEKS.  BUT WE'VE ALSO BEEN
WORKING WITH A LOT OF THE TOP
DEVELOPERS TO ENABLE THIS PAY
WITH GOOGLE EXPERIENCE TO MORE
USERS.  SO LET'S SWITCH TO THE
SLIDES, PLEASE.
SO I'M EXCITED TO ANNOUNCE
THAT
WE ARE SOON GOING TO  HAVE
AIRBNB, DELIVEROO,  DOORDASH,
AND
E24, INTEGRATED  WITH THE PAY
WITH GOOGLE  EXPERIENCE, AND
MANY
MORE  DEVELOPERS ARE GOING TO BE
COMING SOON.
SO AS YOU SAW, THIS  EXPERIENCE
IS SOMETHING  THAT'S GOING TO BE
AVAILABLE  NOT JUST IN THE
UNITED
STATES, BUT ALSO
INTERNATIONALLY.  SO WE'RE  VERY
EXCITED ABOUT THAT.
AND IF YOU'RE INTERESTED IN
THIS
API, YOU CAN SIGN UP FOR  EARLY
ACCESS.
SO THAT WAS PAY WITH GOOGLE,  IN
ACTION ACROSS   BOTH THE  MOBILE
WEB AND WITHIN APPS.
BUT WE ALSO TALKED ABOUT HOW
THE
ASSISTANT IS GOING TO BE  A HUGE
NEW PLATFORM FOR  COMMERCE.
SO ONE OF THE THINGS WE'VE  DONE
IS WORK CLOSELY WITH THE
ASSISTANT TEAM TO BRING THE
SAME
GREAT PAY WITH GOOGLE
EXPERIENCE
TO THE GOOGLE  ASSISTANT.
NOW, IF YOU WERE AT THE
KEYNOTE,
I THINK YOU MIGHT  HAVE SEEN A
DEMO ALREADY OF  HOW THIS
ORDERING EXPERIENCE  WOULD LOOK
ON PANERA.  NOW,  LET'S SEE THAT
DEMO IN ACTION  AGAIN.
SO LET'S SWITCH TO THE DEMO
THAT
WE HAVE.
FOR THE  ASSISTANT.
AND NOW, I'M GOING TO BE  TRYING
THIS ON THE ASSISTANT.   IT'S A
LITTLE BIT NOISY IN  HERE, SO IF
EVERYONE CAN BEAR  WITH ME AND
KEEP REAL QUIET,  WE'RE GOING TO
DO THIS LIVE.   OKAY?
SO I'M GOING TO BRING UP THE
ASSISTANT AND THEN TRY TO  ORDER
A SANDWICH AND SOME  SMOOTHIES
FROM PANERA.
YOU YOU HAD.
Google:  THESE CAME BACK FROM  A
SEARCH.
Pali Bhat:  TALK TO PANERA.
Google:  I FOUND A COUPLE OF
PLACES.
Pali Bhat:  I THINK IT'S A  BIT
NOISY.  SO I'M GOING TO  TRY
AGAIN.
TALK TO PANERA.
Google:  I FOUND A COUPLE OF
PLACES.
Pali Bhat:  MM.
FEELS LIKE WE HAVE A LOT OF
NOISE IN HERE.  MAYBE WE CAN
ALL
DO IT TOGETHER.
LET ME TRY ONCE MORE, 'CAUSE
THIS DEMO IS REALLY COOL.
TALK TO PANERA.
Google:  I FOUND A COUPLE OF
PLACES.
Pali Bhat:  AHH!
THE DEMO GODS ARE NOT SMILING
ON
US.
SO, YOU KNOW, WE'RE GOING TO
GIVE IT ONE MORE SHOT,  BECAUSE
ALL OF YOU, I THINK,  WILL BE
INTERESTED IN THIS.   AND THEN
WE'LL SWITCH TO A  COOL VIDEO WE
HAVE IN CASE  THIS EXACTLY
HAPPENED.
TALK TO PANERA.
Google:  I FOUND A COUPLE OF
PLACES.
Pali Bhat:  SO YOU KNOW WHAT?
WHY DON'T WE ACTUALLY SWITCH  TO
THE VIDEO, AND I'LL SHOW  YOU A
LITTLE BIT OF HOW THIS  WORKS ON
THE VIDEO.
SO THE COOL THING ABOUT THIS
IS,
IF YOU'RE ACTUALLY IN A  LESS
NOISY ENVIRONMENT THAN  THE
SHORELINE AMPHITHEATER,  WHICH
HOPEFULLY NOT MANY OF  YOU ARE
TRYING TO ICANN USE THE
ASSISTANT IN, THEN YOU CAN
ACTUALLY GET THIS EXPERIENCE
WHERE YOU CAN INTERACT WITH  THE
ASSISTANT ACROSS BOTH  VOICE OR
BY INTERACTING WITH  YOUR TOUCH
SCREEN.
AND THE COOL THING ABOUT IT  IS,
YOU CAN SWITCH SEAMLESSLY
BETWEEN BOTH THE VOICE AND
USING
THE PROMPTS THAT THE  ASSISTANT
GIVES YOU.
SO IN THIS PARTICULAR  EXAMPLE,
I
COULD ACTUALLY  START ORDERING,
LET'S SAY,  THE STRAWBERRY POPPY
SEED  SALAD WITHOUT CHICKEN, AND
THEN SWITCH TO PICKING OUT MY
FAVORITE SMOOTHY, AND THEN
CHECKING OUT.
AND WHAT WE'VE DONE IS
INTEGRATED THE PAY WITH  GOOGLE
EXPERIENCE INTO THE  ASSISTANT,
SO DEVELOPERS LIKE  YOU CAN HAVE
A SEAMLESS  EXPERIENCE FOR ALL
OF
YOUR  CUSTOMERS.
AND, OF COURSE, JUST LIKE YOU
SAW WITH BOTH THE PAYPAL
PURCHASE I SHOWED YOU AND THE
WISH PURCHASE I SHOWED YOU, I
SIMPLY CONFIRM WITH A
FINGERPRINT, AND YOU'RE DONE.
SO WE'RE VERY EXCITED ABOUT  ALL
OF THESE NEW EXPERIENCES  THAT
WE
ARE BRINGING TO  DEVELOPERS LIKE
YOU.  SO WE  LOOK FORWARD TO
SEEING ALL OF  YOU INTEGRATING
PAY WITH  GOOGLE INTO YOUR WEB
SITES,  APPS, OR EXPERIENCING IT
THROUGH THE ASSISTANT.
WITH THAT, I'D LIKE TO  WELCOME
SISSIE HSIAO, WHO'S  GOING TO
TELL YOU A LITTLE  BIT MORE
ABOUT
HOW YOU CAN  MONETIZE AND GROW
YOUR APPS.
THANK YOU.
[ APPLAUSE ]
Sisie Hsiao:  HI, EVERYONE.   MY
NAME IS SISSIE, AND I AM  SUPER
EXCITED TO BE HERE  TODAY TO
SHARE WITH YOU HOW  GOOGLE WILL
HELP YOU BUILD A  MORE
SUCCESSFUL
MOBILE APPS  BUSINESS.
AS SRIDHAR TALKED ABOUT
EARLIER,
THERE ARE OVER 5  MILLION APPS
ACROSS ANDROID  AND iOS.  AND
IF I TELL YOU  THAT THE VAST
MAJORITY ARE  FREE, I'M SURE
MOST
OF YOU  WON'T BE SURPRISED.
SO WHAT DOES IT MEAN FOR YOU,
TRYING TO BUILD A GREAT
BUSINESS
THAT USERS WANT BOTH  FREE AND
AMAZING APPS?
IT MEANS THAT YOU NEED TO  THINK
VERY CREATIVELY ABOUT  HOW TO
MONETIZE YOUR APPS AND  MAKE
SURE
THAT YOU'RE USING  EVERYTHING IN
YOUR ARSENAL,  INCLUDING IN
IN-APP PURCHASES,
SUBSCRIPTIONS,
AND NOW,  INCREASINGLY,
ADVERTISING.
THOSE OF YOU WHO ARE USING
ADMOB
KNOW THAT PUTTING  IN-APP ADS IS
A PRIMARY AND  EFFECTIVE WAY TO
MONETIZE  YOUR APPS.  AND WE AT
GOOGLE  HAVE BEEN FOCUSED ON
CONNECTING YOU TO MILLIONS OF
GOOGLE ADVERTISERS AND OVER  40
AD NETWORKS.
BUT JUST PUTTING ADS INTO  YOUR
APPS ISN'T ENOUGH.  HOW  DO YOU
BUILD A PRODUCT THAT  DELIGHTS
YOUR USERS WITH ADS  EXPERIENCES
THAT ARE JUST AS  GOOD?
IN ORDER TO BE SUCCESSFUL,  YOU
NEED TO BE AS THOUGHTFUL  ABOUT
PUTTING ADS INTO YOUR  APP AS
THE
CORE USER  EXPERIENCE
ITSELF.
LET'S TAKE A MAJOR GAME
DEVELOPER, ZEPTOLAB.  I THINK
THEY MADE CUT THE ROPE, WHICH
I'M SURE MOST OF YOU HAVE
PLAYED
AT ONE POINT IN TIME.   AND THEY
HAVE A NEW AWESOME  GAME CALLED
CATS.  THEY'VE  BEEN USING THE
ADMOB PLATFORM  FOR OVER FIVE
YEARS TO  MONETIZE THEIR APPS.
AND  THEY USE OUR FULL SUITE OF
FORMATS, INCLUDING
INTERSTITIALS, REWARDED VIDEO
ADS, AND NOW NATIVE ADVANCED.
AND WHEN THEY'RE DOING THAT
ADVERTISING, THEY'RE VERY,  VERY
CAREFUL TO MAKE SURE  THAT THE
ADS ARE NATIVE TO  THE GAME AND
THAT THEY'RE  BLENDING
SEAMLESSLY
SO THAT  USERS WHO ARE PLAYING
ARE  STILL HAVING A DELIGHTFUL
AND  FUN EXPERIENCE AND IT'S
WORKING FOR THEM.
SINCE THEY'VE ADDED REWARDED  AD
UNITS TO CATS, THEY HAVE  MORE
TRIPLED THEIR ADMOB  REVENUE IN
THE PAST FEW
MONTHS.
ZEPTO LABS IS JUST ONE  EXAMPLE.
APPS USING ADMOB  ACROSS ANDROID
AND iOS TO  MONETIZE THEIR
APPS.  AND WE  HAVE PAID OUT
MORE
THAN $3.5  BILLION TO DATE TO
APP
DEVELOPERS, MORE THAN ANY AD
NETWORK.
BUT WE KNOW YOU NEED MORE.
WE'VE BEEN LISTENING TO YOUR
FEEDBACK VERY CLOSELY, AND
WE'VE
HEARD THAT YOU NEED  MORE FROM
THIS PRODUCT.  YOU  NEED THREE
THINGS.
NUMBER ONE, YOU WANT A  HOLISTIC
PICTURE OF YOUR  REVENUE, NOT
JUST ADS, BUT  HOW DOES ADS
RELATE TO THE  OTHER REVENUE
STREAMS, LIKE  IN-APP PURCHASES
AND  SUBSCRIPTIONS.
NUMBER TWO, YOU WANT  INTEGRATED
APP ANALYTICS.   YOU WANT TO SEE
HOW ADS WORKS  AND HOW THEY
AFFECT THE CORE  USER EXPERIENCE
OF YOUR APP  ITSELF.
AND, FINALLY, NUMBER THREE,  YOU
WANT BETTER AND MORE  POWERFUL
TOOLS TO MANAGE AND  MAXIMIZE
YOUR REVENUE.
BECAUSE OF THESE NEEDS,  THAT'S
WHAT SPURRED MY  ENGINEERING
TEAM
TO EMBARK ON  A MISSION AND
REBUILD ADMOB  FROM THE GROUND
UP.
AND THAT'S WHY TODAY I AM
INCREDIBLY EXCITED TO SHARE
WITH
YOU THE LAUNCH OF A  COMPLETELY
REBUILT,  REIMAGINED
ADMOB.
[ APPLAUSE ]
THANK YOU.
WE WANTED TO GIVE YOU THE  TOOLS
YOU NEED TO BUILD A  SUCCESSFUL
MOBILE APPS  BUSINESS.  AND
WE'RE
FOCUSED  ON BUILDING AN
END-TO-END  MONETIZATION
PLATFORM
THAT  WORKS FOR YOU.
OUR GOALS HERE ARE PRIMARY
TWOFOLD.  NUMBER ONE, WE WANT
TO
GIVE YOU DEEPER INSIGHTS  INTO
HOW YOUR ADS BEHAVE AND  HOW
THEY
AFFECT THE REST OF  YOUR CORE
APP.  AND I'LL SHOW  YOU THAT IN
A SECOND.
AND NUMBER TWO, WE BUILT
ADVANCED CONTROLS SO THAT YOU
CAN -- AND REPORTING, SO THAT
YOU CAN MAXIMIZE AND OPTIMIZE
YOUR ADS REVENUE.
AND, FINALLY, WE BUILT ALL OF
THESE FEATURES ON A CLEAN AND
MODERN, REDONE USER  INTERFACE.
HOWEVER, INSTEAD  OF JUST
TALKING
ABOUT IT,    LET ME SHOW YOU A
FEW SCREENS  FROM THE REAL --
REALLY NEW
ADMOB.
LET ME STORY TELL FOR A  SECOND.
AT
A MID-SIZED  COMPANY, BUILDING
HEALTH AND  FITNESS APPS.  AND
WHEN I  FIRST LOG INTO THE NEW
ADMOB,  I SEE A COMPLETELY
DIFFERENT  USER EXPERIENCE.  AND
WHAT I  SEE HERE IS A HOME
DASHBOARD.   THIS HOME DASHBOARD
IS A  QUICK SNAPSHOT OF ALL THE
APPS IN MY ADMOB ACCOUNT.   AND
IT'S TELLING ME IMPORTANT
INFORMATION ABOUT HOW MUCH  I'M
MAKING IN EACH OF THESE  APPS
ACROSS MY ENTIRE  BUSINESS.
IF YOU SEE AT THE TOP, I'M
SHOWING A NEW SCORECARD,  WHICH
IS TELLING ME HOW MUCH  I'VE
MADE
TODAY, THIS WEEK,  YESTERDAY,
THIS WEEK, AND  THIS MONTH.  SO
IT SEEMS TO  BE A REALLY USEFUL
WAY FOR ME  TO CHECK HOW MY
BUSINESS IS  DOING.
IF I SCROLL DOWN, I'M GOING  TO
SEE A NEW CARD ON THE LEFT
CALLED THE APP PERFORMANCE
CARD.
AND HERE, WE'RE  BREAKING OUT
EACH OF THE APPS  IN THIS
ACCOUNT
AND TELLING  ME HOW MUCH MONEY
I'M MAKING  ACROSS MY BUSINESS.
IF I LOOK CAREFULLY, THOUGH,  IT
LOOKS LIKE FITMOBBER,  WHICH IS
MY BEST APP, HAS  BEEN TANKING.
IT'S DROPPED  OVER $200
YESTERDAY, WHICH IS  A DISASTER,
BECAUSE THIS IS  THE ONE THAT'S
GROWING THE  BEST.  I NEED TO
FIGURE OUT  EXACTLY WHAT'S GOING
ON.
I DIG IN, I DRILL IN AND  CLICK
ON THAT.  AND LET ME  JUMP OUT
OF
STORY FOR A SEC  TO EXPLAIN WHAT
YOU'RE SEEING  NOW.
YOU'RE NOW SEEING A  COMPLETELY
NEW APP OVERVIEW  DASHBOARD.
AND
THIS APP  OVERVIEW DASHBOARD IS
A
DASHBOARD DESIGNED TO SHOW  YOU
EXACTLY WHAT'S GOING ON  WITHIN
A
PARTICULAR APP.  IN  THIS CASE,
IN OUR DEMO, THIS  IS THE
FITMOBBER APP.  AND  YOU CAN SEE
ON BOTH THE  LEFT-HAND AND THE
TOP THAT  IT'S SHOWING YOU THAT
ALL THE  NUMBERS YOU'RE SEEING
ARE  RELATED TO FITMOBBER.
AND FURTHERMORE, IN THE  MIDDLE,
I SEE TWO NEW  REPORTS.  ON THE
LEFT, WITH  THE COLORED BARS, A
TOTAL  REVENUE REPORT.  AND THIS
IS  SHOWING ME NOT JUST ADS
REVENUE FROM ADMOB.  IT'S  ALSO
LAYERING IN IN-APP  PURCHASES,
SUBSCRIPTIONS, OR  OTHER IN-APP
MONETIZATION  MODELS RIGHT INTO
THAT BAR  CHART, SO YOU CAN SEE
AT A  GLANCE HOW MY OVERALL
REVENUE  IS TRENDING ACROSS ALL
OF  THESE DIFFERENT REVENUE
STREAMS.
ON THE RIGHT, I SEE ALSO A
COMPLETELY NEW USER METRICS
CARD.  AND THIS CARD IS  SHOWING
ME IMPORTANT HEALTH  METRICS OF
MY CORE APP,  INCLUDING SESSIONS
AND
RETENTION.
WHAT WE'VE DONE TO ENABLE  THIS
IS WEAVE TOGETHER GOOGLE
ANALYTICS FOR FIREBASE  DIRECTLY
INTO THE CORE OF  ADMOB.  WE
KNOW
THAT ADS ARE  A CRITICAL PART OF
YOUR  USERS' EXPERIENCE.  YOU
CANNOT BUILD AN AMAZING APP
WITHOUT UNDERSTANDING HOW ADS
BEHAVE IN THE APP.  AND YOU
CAN'T MONETIZE WELL WITHOUT
UNDERSTANDING HOW USERS  BEHAVE
IN YOUR APP.
SO FOR THE FIRST TIME EVER,
ADMOB AND FIREBASE CAN SHARE
DATA ACROSS THESE TWO  PLATFORMS
TO HELP YOU GAIN  DEEPER
INSIGHTS
AND BUILD A  MORE SUCCESSFUL
MOBILE APPS  BUSINESS.
COOL.  LET ME GET BACK TO MY
STORY AND TELL YOU HOW I CAN
USE
THIS TO FIX MY FITMOBBER  ISSUE.
SO IF I LOOK AT THESE NUMBERS
ON
THE LEFT, IT LOOKS LIKE  THE
BLUE
BARS HAVE BEEN  SHRINKING.  AND
THE BLUE BARS  ARE ACTUALLY MY
ADS REVENUE.   SO THAT MAKES
SENSE.  THAT'S  WHY I SAW THE
$200 DROP  YESTERDAY.
AND IF I LOOK ON THE RIGHT,
USER
METRICS HAVE ALSO TAKEN  A TURN
FOR THE WORSE.  IN  FACT,
SESSIONS PER USER AND  SESSION
DURATION ARE BOTH  DOWN.  THAT
MEANS THAT USERS  ARE USING THE
APP LESS AND  WALKING AWAY MORE.
I GO TALK TO MY TEAM AND ASK
THEM WHAT IS GOING ON.  AND I
LEARN THAT THEY PUT A NEW AD
UNIT RIGHT AT THE SCREEN IN  THE
APP THAT IS RIGHT BEFORE  USERS
WORK OUT, WHICH MEANS  THAT THEY
WERE JUST DETERRED  ENOUGH TO
STOP WORKING OUT  AND STOP
SUBSCRIBING TO MY  APP.  THAT
WAS
A REALLY BAD  PLACEMENT FOR THAT
AD FOR  SURE.
I MOVE IT, AND I WAIT A WEEK.
I HOP BACK INTO THE SAME  SCREEN
IN THE NEW MACINTOSH.   AND,
ADMOB.   AND, WOW, EVERYTHING IS
BACK  AND UP TO THE RIGHT.
BUSINESS IS NOW BOOMING AT
FITMOBBER, AND I AM A GLOBAL
COMPANY.  I'M ALSO USING AN
ADVANCED FEATURE CALLED
MEDIATION.  AND MEDIATION IS
VERY SIMPLE.  IT'S BASICALLY  A
SET OF RULES THAT ALLOW ME  TO
SEND MY AD UNITS TO  DIFFERENT
AD
NETWORKS.
AND IF YOU'RE A BIGGER APP
PUBLISHER BUSINESS, THIS IS
REALLY IMPORTANT FOR YOU TO  USE
AND TO MAXIMIZE YOUR  REVENUE.
MANAGING MEDIATION IN THE NEW
ADMOB IS EASIER THAN EVER,  WITH
A FEATURE CALLED  MEDIATION
GROUPS.    AND WHAT  MEDIATION
GROUPS LETS YOU DO  IS IT LETS
YOU SET UP A  SINGLE SET OF
MEDIATION RULES  AND THEN APPLY
IT ACROSS  APPS, AD UNITS, OR
GEOGRAPHIES.
I'LL GIVE YOU AN EXAMPLE.
LET'S SAY THAT FITMOBBER IS
DOING REALLY WELL, ESPECIALLY
IN
JAPAN.  AND IN JAPAN
ESPECIALLY,
YOU WANT TO SEND  YOUR ADS TO
DIFFERENT  REGIONAL AD NETWORKS,
BECAUSE  THERE ARE A FEW AD
NETWORKS  THERE THAT WANT TO BUY
ADS  JUST FOR USERS THERE.
USING MEDIATION GROUPS, IT'S
NOW
VERY EASY TO DO THIS.  I  SET UP
ONE MEDIATION GROUP  FOR JAPAN
WITH MY RULES.  AND  AFTER THAT,
IT'S QUITE  TRIVIAL TO ADD AD
UNITS.  I  CAN ADD AD UNITS TO
THIS  GROUP, AND IT WILL START
AUTOMATICALLY OBEYING THE
RULES.
I CAN ALSO, IF I CHANGE MY  MIND
AND WANT TO REORDER OUR  ADD
DIFFERENT -- NEW AD  NETWORKS,
ADD THAT IN ONE  PLACE OR CHANGE
IT IN ONE  PLACE AND HAVE IT
AUTOMATICALLY APPLY TO ALL OF
MY
ADS IN MY JAPAN APP.
VERY SIMPLE AND VERY  POWERFUL.
AT THIS POINT, I'VE TALKED TO
YOU A LOT ABOUT HOW GOOGLE IS
HELPING YOU BUILD A GREAT
IN-APP
ADVERTISING BUSINESS.
I WANT TO PIVOT COMPLETELY  AND
TALK ABOUT ANOTHER  EXTREMELY
CRUCIAL PART OF  BUILDING A
SUCCESSFUL  BUSINESS, MAYBE THE
MOST  CRUCIAL PART.  AND THAT IS
YOU CANNOT HAVE A SUCCESSFUL
MOBILE APPS BUSINESS WITHOUT
HAVING A SUCCESSFUL GROWTH
STRATEGY.  AND IN ORDER TO DO
THAT, YOU HAVE TO ANSWER TWO
QUESTIONS.  NUMBER ONE IS,  WHO
ARE MY BEST USERS?
AND NUMBER TWO IS, WHERE CAN  I
FIND THEM?  WHERE ARE THE  MOST
EFFECTIVE CHANNELS THAT  I CAN
SHOW THEM MY APP AND  GET THEM
TO
DOWNLOAD AND TRY  IT?
I'M EXCITED TO SHARE THAT
GOOGLE
HAS BEEN WORKING ON  THESE
PROBLEMS.  AND WE HAVE  QUITE A
FEW FEATURES TO SHARE  TO SOLVE
THESE GROWTH  CHALLENGES.
LET ME START WITH GOOGLE  PLAY.
ANDROID IS NOW ACTIVE  WITH OVER
2 BILLION MONTHLY  ACTIVE USERS
EVERY MONTH.   AND GOOGLE PLAY
IS
IN OVER  190 COUNTRIES AROUND
THE
WORLD.  PEOPLE TURN TO GOOGLE
PLAY EVERY DAY TO DISCOVER
GREAT
APPS AND GAMES TO  ENJOY.  AND
WE
FIND  INCREASINGLY, THAT BESIDES
WHICH THEY DEFINITELY STILL  DO,
THEY SEARCH FOR THE APPS  THAT
THEY WANT, THEY ARE ALSO
RESPONDING AND DOWNLOADING  APPS
THAT WE'RE RECOMMENDING  TO THEM
AS THEY'RE BROWSING  THE PLAY
STORE.
TO HELP YOU FIND THOSE USERS
WHO
ARE BROWSING AND  DISCOVERING
THEIR NEXT  FAVORITE APP IN THE
PLAY  STORE, WE ARE ANNOUNCING
NEW  AD PLACEMENTS IN THE HOME
AND  APP LISTINGS PAGES OF THE
GOOGLE PLAY
STORE.
THESE AD UNITS WILL ONLY BE
AVAILABLE EXCLUSIVELY TO
UNIVERSAL APP CAMPAIGNS.  AND
THEY'LL HELP YOU REACH USERS
RIGHT WHEN THEY'RE IN THAT  MODE
OF DISCOVERY IN THE PLAY
STORE.
OBVIOUSLY, BESIDES THE PLAY
STORE, THERE ARE MANY OTHER
CHANNELS THAT PEOPLE ARE
DISCOVERING THEIR NEXT  FAVORITE
APP.  AND THAT'S WHY  WE BUILT
UNIVERSAL APP  CAMPAIGNS, OR
UAC,
AS WE LIKE  TO CALL IT.  UAC
HELPS YOU  REACH PEOPLE ACROSS
MULTIPLE  BILLION-USER
PROPERTIES,  INCLUDING GOOGLE
PLAY, GOOGLE  SEARCH, YOUTUBE,
GMAIL, AND  MILLIONS OF APPS AND
WEB  SITES ACROSS THE GOOGLE
DISPLAY NETWORK.
IN ORDER TO USE UAC, IT'S  VERY
EASY.  YOU TELL US WHAT  APP YOU
WANT TO PROMOTE.  YOU  TELL US
THE PRICE THAT YOU  WANT TO PAY
PER INSTALL.  AND  YOU GIVE US A
LITTLE BIT OF  INFORMATION TO
HELP US CREATE  ADS, LIKE TEXT,
IMAGES,  VIDEOS.
WE THEN TAKE ALL OF THAT
INFORMATION IN UAC, AND WE  USE
MACHINE LEARNING TO  DELIVER THE
MAXIMUM NUMBER OF  INSTALLS TO
YOU AT THE PRICE  THAT YOU'VE
SPECIFIED.
AND WE DO THIS BY AUTOMATING
AND
OPTIMIZING EVERY SINGLE  BIT OF
THE ADVERTISING  ITSELF,
INCLUDING WHAT THE  ADS LOOK
LIKE, WHERE TO PUT  THE ADS, AND
ALSO, MORE  IMPORTANTLY, WHAT TO
BID FOR  EACH IMPRESSION AND
CLICK SO  THAT WE HIT THAT
TARGET
PRICE  THAT YOU WANT, WHILE
DELIVERING THE MAXIMUM NUMBER
OF
INSTALLS FOR YOU.
SO WHEREVER YOUR USERS ARE  AND
WHATEVER THEY'RE DOING,  WHETHER
THEY'RE SEARCHING    ON GOOGLE
OR
WATCHING VIDEOS  ON YOUTUBE,
ONLY
GOOGLE HAS  THE BREADTH OF
CHANNELS TO  HELP YOU FIND YOUR
MOST  VALUABLE USERS RIGHT WHEN
THEY WANT TO DOWNLOAD YOUR  APP.
UNIVERSAL AD CAMPAIGNS HAS  BEEN
HELPING COMPANIES LIKE  HEAD
SPACE, WHICH IS A VERY  POPULAR
MEDITATION APP,  IMPROVE HEALTH
AND HAPPINESS  AROUND THE WORLD.
AND  ACCORDING TO ROBERT FROM
HEAD  SPACE, UNIVERSAL APP
CAMPAIGNS HAS SAVED THEIR  TEAM
TIME AND DRIVEN RESULTS.
TRANSLATION:  MORE USERS THAT
USE AND LOVE THE APP IN LESS
TIME.
HOWEVER, LIKE HEADSPACE, WE  ALL
KNOW THAT GROWTH ISN'T  JUST
ABOUT INSTALLS.  MANY  USERS
WILL
INSTALL YOUR APP  AND NOT GO
ALONG AND SPEND OR  ENGAGE OR
POTENTIALLY EVEN  OPEN IT.  YOU
NEED TO SPEND  YOUR ACQUISITION
DOLLARS  WISELY TO FIND YOUR
MOST
VALUABLE USERS, THE ONES THAT
WILL ENGAGE AND SPEND AND
ACTIVATE AND ENJOY YOUR APPS.
BECAUSE OF THAT, I'M ALSO
EXTREMELY HAPPY THAT WE'RE
ANNOUNCING TWO NEW BIDDING
OPTIONS IN UNIVERSAL APP
CAMPAIGNS, TARGET CPA, OR  COST
PER ACQUISITION, AND  TARGET
ROAS, OR RETURN ON AD  SPEND.
AND THESE BIDDING STRATEGIES
WILL HELP YOU PROFITABLY
ACQUIRE
HIGH-VALUE USERS.  OR  PUT MORE
SIMPLY, HELPS YOU  PAY MORE FOR
USERS WHO WILL  PAY YOU MORE AND
PAY LESS FOR  USERS WHO WE THINK
WILL PAY  YOU SO I GIVE YOU A
VERY
CONCRETE EXAMPLE.  MY HUSBAND
AND I LESS ARE BOTH MOBILE
GAMERS,
AND WE BOTH LOVE THIS NEW
GAME BY NINTENDO CALLED FIRE
EMBLEM HEROES.  I DON'T KNOW
IF YOU PLAYED IT OR NOT.
IT'S TACTICAL RP TPUS AND
BASICALLY IN THIS GAME YOU
COLLECT HEROES AND THE WAY
YOU COLLECT HEROES IS THROUGH
EXCHANGING A VIRTUAL CURRENCY
CALLED ORBS.  NOW, I'M SURE
MOST OF YOU WHO PLAY GAMES
KNOW THE WAY TO GET ORBS IS
BASICALLY TWO WAYS.  ONE IS
YOU BUY THEM WITH REAL MONEY,
AND NUMBER TWO IS YOU CAN
SORT OF GRIND IT OUT IN THE
GAME AND EARN THEM OVER THE
COURSE OF PLAYING.
NOW, I AM REALLY VERY
IMPATIENT AND ALSO VERY
COMPETITIVE, SO I HAVE NO
ISSUES SPENDING OVER A
HUNDRED DOLLARS BUYING ORBS
TO COLLECT MY FAVORITE
HEROES.
MY HUSBAND, ON THE OTHER
HAND, IS MORE PRINCIPLED AND
WANTS TO GRIND IT OUT, AND
HE'S JUST A LITTLE CHEAP, SO
HE'S WILLING TO SPEND MAYBE,
AT MOST, $5.
FOR AN APP DEVELOPER LIKE
NINTENDO, THEY SHOULD BE
THINKING ABOUT ACQUIRING
PLAYERS LIKE ME AT THE HIGH
PRICE POINT, AT A HIGHER
PRICE POINT THAN PLAYERS LIKE
MY HUSBAND WHO SPEND A LOWER
PRICE POINT.  AND WITH THESE
NEW BIDDING STRATEGIES, THEY
CAN DO EXACTLY THAT.
AND FINALLY, AT THE CORE OF
ANY SMART GROWTH STRATEGY IS
MEASURING WHETHER YOU'RE
SPENDING YOUR ACQUISITION
DOLLARS WISELY.  AND WHEN WE
KNOW THAT MANY OF YOU ARE
USING THIRD-PARTY MEASUREMENT
PROVIDERS TO MEASURE THE
ATTRIBUTION OF YOUR INSTALLS.
AND THAT'S WHY TODAY I'M
HAPPY TO ANNOUNCE THAT GOOGLE
IS LAUNCHING A COMPLETELY NEW
APP ATTRIBUTION PROGRAM.  AND
WHAT THIS PROGRAM DOES IS
IT'S DESIGNED TO INTEGRATE
DATA FROM THESE SEVEN GLOBAL
COMPANIES THAT YOU SEE ON
THIS SLIDE RIGHT INTO
ADWORDS.  AND OUR GOAL IS TO
CREATE CONSISTENCY AND
RELIABILITY OF THE DATA
INTEGRATION AND THE RESULTS
THAT YOU'LL GET.
WE HAVE ALSO STREAMLINED THE
FLOW, SO IT'S INCREDIBLY EASY
NOW TO GET THESE APP
MEASUREMENT COMPANIES UP AND
RUNNING IF YOU'RE USING
ADWORDS.
WITH THAT, I WANT TO THANK
YOU ALL FOR THE OPPORTUNITY
TO BE HERE AND SHARE ALL OF
THESE GREAT FEATURES THAT MY
TEAM HAS BEEN WORKING ON.
PLEASE TRY THEM OUT AND
PLEASE SHARE YOUR FEEDBACK
WITH US.
AND WITH THAT, I'D LIKE TO
TURN IT BACK TO SRIDHAR TO
CLOSE WITH HIS FINAL
THOUGHTS.
THANK YOU.
[ APPLAUSE ]
Sridhar Ramaswamy:  THANK
YOU, SISSIE.
YOU KNOW, IT'S REALLY
EXCITING ABOUT PRESENTING TO
YOU ALL OF YOU?  WE KNOW THAT
WE HAVE THE MOST INNOVATIVE
THINKERS IN THE APP WORLD
RIGHT HERE.  WE KNOW THAT
MANY OF THE PRODUCTS THAT
REDEFINE HOW WE COMMUNICATE,
SHOP, STAY ENTERTAINED, ARE
GOING TO BE DONE BY YOU.
THAT'S WHY WE FIND IT SO
EXCITING.
AND WE ALSO KNOW THAT IN
ORDER TO TURN THESE PRODUCTS
INTO SUCCESSFUL BUSINESSES,
IT'S MORE IMPORTANT THAN EVER
BEFORE FOR YOU TO FIGURE OUT
HOW TO SIMPLIFY THE PAYMENTS
PROCESS, HOW TO TAILOR YOUR
AD EXPERIENCES TO GENERATE
THE MAXIMUM AMOUNT OF
REVENUE, AND TO FIND THE
RIGHT USERS FOR YOUR APP.
AND THOSE OF YOU THAT DO THIS
ARE REALLY THE ONES THAT ARE
GOING TO BE SUCCESSFUL.
WE HAVE A NUMBER OF GREAT
FOLLOW-UP SESSIONS, INCLUDING
ONE ON PAYMENTS RIGHT AFTER
THIS.  THEY'RE UP HERE.
THANK YOU ALL FOR LISTENING
TO US.
TAKE CARE.
[ APPLAUSE
]
SESSION:
4:00 THE
MOBILE WEB:  STATE OF THE
UNION.
Rahul Roy-Chowdhury:.
RAHUL
.
%%%TSTART
- - - -
HE
Rahul Roy-Chowdhury:  HELLO,
EVERYONE!
[ APPLAUSE ]
MY NAME IS RAHUL, I'M THE
PRODUCT LEAD ON CHROME, AND
I'M EXCITED TO BE BACK UP
HERE AGAIN THIS YEAR TO TELL
YOU ABOUT ALL THE AMAZING
PROGRESS WE'VE MADE OVER THE
LAST 12 MONTHS.
THE THEME OF TODAY, AND
SOMETHING YOU'RE GOING TO
HEAR AGAIN AND AGAIN, IS THAT
THE MODERN MOBILE WEB IS NOW
MAINSTREAM.  AND THIS IS
REALLY AN AM AMAZING SHIFT.  SO
I'M GOING TO TELL YOU ALL
ABOUT WHAT HAS BEEN HAPPENING
AND WHAT IT MEANS FOR YOU.
IT'S THE MOBILE WEB STATE OF
THE UNION.  SO LET'S DIVE
RIGHT
IN.
THE WEB HAS INCREDIBLE REACH.
JUST CHROME ALONE RUNS ON
OVER 2 BILLION DEVICES FROM
PHONES TO TABLETS TO PCs.
AND THE WEB IS MUCH BIGGER
THAN CHROME.  THERE ARE OVER
5 BILLION DEVICES OUT THERE
THAT CAN ACCESS WEB CONTENT.
5 BILLION!  THAT IS A LARGE
NUMBER.  AND THIS DIDN'T
HAPPEN BECAUSE OF LUCK.  THIS
WIDE REACH IS A DIRECT
CONSEQUENCE OF HOW THE WEB
OPERATES.  IT IS AN OPEN,
DECENTRALIZED PLATFORM.  IT
HAS NO GATEKEEPERS.
DEVELOPERS GET WIDE REACH.
USERS GET LOW FRICTION.
AND ON THE CHROME TEAM, OUR
MISSION HAS ALWAYS BEEN TO
MOVE THE WEB PLATFORM
FORWARD.  WE SPEND A LOT OF
TIME WORKING ON MAKING THE
WEB PLATFORM BETTER.  LOTS OF
THINGS ON THE FOUNDATIONS.
THINGS THAT JUST HAPPEN UNDER
THE HOOD THAT YOU MAY NOT
EVEN RECOGNIZE, BUT AT EVERY
SEARCH CHANGE, THE WEB
PLATFORM JUST GETS BETTER.
TO TAKE ONE EXAMPLE, OVER THE
LAST YEAR, WE FOCUSED OUR
JAVASCRIPT PERFORMANCE ON
REAL-WORLD WEB USAGE.  IT'S
SORT OF LIKE WHAT KIND OF CAR
WOULD YOU RATHER DRIVE?  A
CAR THAT'S BEEN ROAD TESTED
IN REAL-WORLD DRIVING
CONDITIONS OR A CAR THAT'S
BEEN TESTED IN AN ARTIFICIAL
LAB SETTING?
WE WANT OUR CAR, AND OUR
JAVASCRIPT ENGINE IS
LITERALLY CALLED V8, WE WANT
OUR CAR TO BE GREAT ON THE
ROADS THAT PEOPLE ACTUALLY
DRIVE ON.  AND CURRENTLY WE
THINK THE SPEEDOMETER
BENCHMARK BEST CAPTURES THIS
REAL-WORLD USAGE SO I'M
PLEASED TO ANNOUNCE THAT
CHROME ON ANDROID IS NOW 35%
FASTER ON THE SPEEDOMETER
BLARK COMPARED TO A
BENCHMARK COMPARED TO A YEAR
AGO.
[ APPLAUSE ]
AND WE'VE SEEN SIMILAR GAINS
ON OTHER OS'S AS WELL.
TO TAKE ANOTHER EXAMPLE, I'M
SURE ALL OF US HAVE
EXPERIENCED THE ANNOYANCE OF
LOADING A WEB PAGE AND
STARTING TO READ SOME CONTENT
ONLY TO HAVE IT JUMP TO A
DIFFERENT LOCATION.  AND THIS
USUALLY HAPPENS BECAUSE SOME
OFF-SCREEN CONTENT IS LOADED
IN AND PUSHED DOWN THE
VISIBLE CONTENT.
NOW, TO IMPROVE THIS USER
EXPERIENCE, WE LAUNCHED A NEW
FEATURE CALLED SCROLL
ANCHORING.  AND SCROLL
ANCHORING WORKS BY LOCKING
THE SCROLL POSITION TO AN
ELEMENT THAT IS VISIBLE ON
THE PAGE, SO THE USER SAYS IN
THE SAME POSITION EVEN AS OUR
SCREEN CONTENT GETS LOADED
IN.
SO TO SHOW YOU WHAT IT LOOKS
LIKE IN ACTION, ON THE LEFT
IS CHROME WITHOUT SCROLL
ANCHORING, AND ON THE RIGHT
IS CHROME WITH SCROLL
ANCHORING ENABLED.  AND THIS
IS A LONG PAGE, AND AS WE
SCROLL DOWN TO THE BOTTOM OF
THIS PAGE, YOU'LL SEE ON THE
RIGHT THE PAGE STAYS LOCKED
IN POSITION WHILE ON THE LEFT
THE PAGE IS JUMPING ALL OVER
THE PLACE AS OUR SCREEN
CONTENT GETS LOADED IN.
NOW, THIS IS A BIT OF A
CONTRIVED DEMO JUST TO SHOW
YOU EXACTLY WHAT'S GOING ON.
BUT SINCE WE LAUNCHED THIS
FEATURE, WHAT WE HAVE SEEN IS
THAT ON AVERAGE, SCROLL
ANCHORING PREVENTS THREE
JUMPS PER PAGE LOAD.  SO THIS
HAS HAD A HUGE IMPACT ON THE
QUALITY OF THE USER
EXPERIENCE.
AND THERE ARE MANY MORE SUCH
CHANGES.  THINGS THAT DON'T
NEED ANY ACTION FROM
DEVELOPERS OR USERS BUT THAT
JUST MAKE THE WEB PLATFORM
BETTER.
SO THAT'S THE FOUNDATION.
NEXT COME ALL OF THE FEATURES
AND APIs THAT ENABLE YOU
ALL TO DO GREAT THINGS, TO
BUILD GREAT EXPERIENCES ON
TOP OF THAT FOUNDATION.  AND
TODAY I'M GOING TO TALK ABOUT
THE AMAZING MOMENTUM WE'VE
SEEN ACROSS THE CORE PILLARS
OF THE MODERN MOBILE WEB.
I'M GOING TO TALK ABOUT WHAT
WE ARE DOING TO MAKE WEB APPS
MORE POLISHED AND FEEL FOR
INTEGRATED INTO THE DEVICE,
AND I'M GOING TO TALK ABOUT
ALL THE WAYS WE'RE WORKING ON
TO MAKE BUILDING WEB APPS
EASIER THAN EVER BEFORE.
SO LET'S START WITH MOMENTUM.
ONE OF THE CORE PILLARS OF
THE MODERN MOBILE WEB IS
ACCELERATED MOBILE PAGES OR
AMP FOR CONTENT-FOCUSED
EXPERIENCES.  NOW, WE ALL
KNOW THAT CONTENT EXPERIENCES
ON THE WEB CAN SOMETIMES BE
QUITE PAINFUL, AND WE
SPEARHEADED THE AMP PROJECT
LAST YEAR, THE OPEN SOURCE
AMP PROJECT LAST YEAR, TO
IMPROVE THIS EXPERIENCE.
AND THE BENEFITS THAT AMP
BRINGS ARE STARK.  ON
AVERAGE, AN AMP PAGE LOADS IN
LESS THAN A SECOND, AND IT
USES TEN TIMES LESS
DATA.
AND AS A RESULT, THE GROWTH
OF AMP HAS BEEN PHENOMENAL.
LAST YEAR AT THIS TIME, THERE
WERE 125 MILLION AMP
DOCUMENTS OUT THERE, AND
TODAY THERE ARE OVER 2
BILLION AMP PAGES FROM OVER
900,000 DIFFERENT
DOMAINS.
[ APPLAUSE
] AMAZING MOMENTUM
MANY AND MORE AND MORE
PLATFORMS ARE NOW LINKING OUT
TO AMPs.  AND THEY'RE DOING
THIS BECAUSE THEY FIND THAT
USERS ARE MORE ENGAGED WHEN
THEY CAN GET TO THE CONTENT
FASTER.
FOR EXAMPLE, LINKEDIN HAS
FOUND THAT PEOPLE SPEND 10%
MORE TIME READING AN ARTICLE
WHEN IT'S AN AMP PAGE VERSUS
WHEN IT'S NOT.
AND TODAY I'M EXCITED TO
ANNOUNCE THAT SEVERAL NEW
PARTNERS ARE GOING TO BE
SUPPORTING THE AMP PROJECT IN
THE COMING WEEKS.  TWITTER
WILL BEGIN LINKING OUT TO
AMPs ACROSS ALL OF THEIR
MOBILE WEB AND NATIVE APP
PROPERTIES.  TUMBLR WILL
BEGIN USING AMP FOR THEIR
BLOGS.  WE GOA AND
QZONE HAD
ALSO BEGIN LINKING OUT TO AMP
AS WELL.  AND FINALLY AMP IS
SEEING  SUCCESS IN NEW
VERTICALS LIKE eCOMMERCE
WITH COMPONENTS SUCH AS
AMP-BIND YOU CAN BUILD
ENGAGING EXPERIENCES AND MANY
MERCHANTS  ARE DOING JUST
THAT.
SO THAT'S AMP, A GREAT WAY TO
BUILD CONTENT-FOCUSED
EXPERIENCES FOR THE MODERN
MOBILE WEB.
THE SECOND PILLAR OF THE
MODERN MOBILE WEB IS
PROGRESSIVE WEB APPS OR
PWAs.  PROGRESSIVE WEB APPS
ARE A WAY TO BUILD AP-FOCUSED
EXPERIENCES THAT ARE
RELIABLE, FAST, AND ENGAGING.
AND WE WERE INSPIRED TO START
THIS JOURNEY BASED ON OUR
BELIEF THAT WEB EXPERIENCES
CAN AND SHOULD BE RADICALLY
BETTER.
AND USERS LOVE THESE
EXPERIENCES, WHICH MEANS THAT
THEY'RE MORE ENGAGED, WHICH
MEANS CONVERSIONS ARE HIGHER,
WHICH MEANS BUSINESS METRICS
ARE BETTER.  SO THIS IS JUST
A GOOD THING ALL AROUND.
BUT RATHER THAN ME TELL YOU
ABOUT HOW AWESOME OUR
PROGRESSIVE WEB APPS ARE,
LET'S TAKE A LOOK AT ONE THAT
JUST LAUNCHED RECENTLY.  IT'S
MY PLEASURE TO INVITE UP ON
STAGE PATRICK TRAUGHBER AND
KATIE SIEVERT FROM TWITTER.
[ APPLAUSE ]
Patrick Traughber:  THANK
YOU, RAHUL.
HELLO, GOOGLE I/O.  MY NAME
IS PATRICK TRAUGHBER, AND I'M
THE PRODUCT MANAGER FOR
TWITTER LITE.
Katie Sievert:  AND I'M KATIE
SIEVERT, ENGINEER ON THE
TWITTER LITE TEAM.
Patrick Traughber:  JUST FIVE
WEEKS AGO WE LAUNCHED TWITTER
LITE FOR THE GOAL OF
DELIVERING A GREAT USER
EXPERIENCE AT
SCALE.
SORRY.  SORRY.  ONE SECOND.
WE SET OUT TO BUILD THE
TWITTER CLIENT THAT, ONE,
LOADS QUICKLY ON SLOW
NETWORKS; TWO, USES LESS
MOBILE DATA; AND, THREE,
WORKS ON ALL
SMARTPHONES.
EACH MONTH, MORE THAN 300
MILLION USERS COME TO TWITTER
TO FIND OUT WHAT'S HAPPENING
IN THE WORLD, AND OVER 80% OF
OUR USERS ARE ON MOBILE
DEVICES.
WE WERE SEEING HEALTHY GROWTH
IN MOBILE WEB USAGE AT
TWITTER SO WE WANTED TO MAKE
SURE THAT THIS EXPERIENCE WAS
TOP NOTCH.
BUT RATHER THAN JUST TELLING
YOU ABOUT TWITTER LITE, WHY
DON'T WE GIVE YOU A LIVE
DEMO.
KATIE, CAN YOU WALK US
THROUGH TWITTER LITE?
Katie Sievert:
SURE.
LET'S PULL IT UP.
WHEN USERS VISIT TWITTER LITE
ON ANDROID, THEY'RE PROMPTED
TO ADD IT TO THEIR HOME
SCREEN.  IN FACT, TWITTER
LITE RECEIVES A MILLION
VISITS EACH DAY VIA THE HOME
SCREEN ICON.
LET'S GO AHEAD AND LAUNCH IT.
AS YOU CAN SEE, IT INITIALLY
LAUNCHES US IN FULL-SCREEN
MODE JUST LIKE A NATIVE APP,
AND TWITTER LIGHT IS
OPTIMIZED FOR SPEED TAKING
ADVANTAGE OF THE
PRPL, AND IT
CONSUMES NO ADDITIONAL DATA.
AS YOU SCROLL THROUGH THE
TIMELINE IT'S FAST AND SMOOTH
LIKE A NATIVE APP, AND SINCE
MANY PEOPLE COME TO TWITTER
TO GET THE LATEST NEWS AND
TAP ON PUBLISHING LINKS WE
HAVE BEEN  BIG FANS OF AMP.
LET'S SEE WHAT OWEN IS
TWEETING.  HE USUALLY TWEETS
INTERESTING ARTICLES.
LET'S CHECK OUT THIS
ONE.
Patrick Traughber:  WE'RE
EXCITED TODAY TO ANNOUNCE
THAT TWITTER LITE LINKS --
NOW LINKS OUT TO AMP PAGES SO
THAT CONTENT LOADS ALMOST
INSTANDPOINTLY AND USES LESS
MOBILE DATA.
[ APPLAUSE ]
FOR EXAMPLE, YOU CAN SEE HERE
THAT WHEN KATIE TAPPED THE
LINK TO THE GUARDIAN POST ON
OWEN'S PROFILE PAGE, IT
LOADED INSTANTLY IN A NEW
TAB.
Katie Sievert:  NOW LET'S
SHOW OFF A COUPLE OF
ENGAGEMENT FEATURES.  ONE OF
THE KEY PIECES OF A POLISHED
EXPERIENCE IS MAKING SURE
USERS CAN CAPTURE MEDIA AND
TWEET IT.
SO TO MAKE THINGS A LITTLE
MORE INTERESTING SLASH
EXCITING, WHAT DO YOU SAY
ABOUT DOING A LIVE PHOTO
TWEET FROM ON STAGE?
[ CHEERS ]
ALL RIGHT.  IT'S LIKE YOU
KNEW I WAS ALREADY GOING DO
IT ANYWAY.
ALL RIGHT.  WITH A DISCLAIMER
THAT I'M NOT A PROFESSIONAL
PHOTOGRAPHER, ALTHOUGH YOU
DON'T NEED TO TO USE TWITTER.
EVERYONE STRIKE A POSE.
[ CHEERING
]
Katie Sievert:  ALL RIGHT.
CENTER THAT.  SO LET'S TYPE,
"TWITTER LITE LIVE DEMO AT
HASHTAG
IO17" TWEET.
AH, SUCCESS.  SO WE SEE THE
TWEET RIGHT THERE.  NOW HALF
OF THE FUN IS RECEIVING
RETWEETS --
[ APPLAUSE ]
OH, THANK YOU.  YES.
SUCCESSFUL DEMOS ARE ALL
APPLAUSE WORTHY.
HALF THE FUN IS SEEING THAT
LITE RETWEETED SOMETHING
AFTER YOU TWEETED SOMETHING
AND ONE IMPACT  HAS HAD A HUGE
IMPACT ON THIS IS PUSH
NOTIFICATIONS.  SO LET'S PULL
UP AN ENTIRELY NOT CANNED
TWEET.  SO MARIUS HAS DONE A
RETWEET.  CLICK ON IT, CLICK
ON THAT TWEET.   NOTIFYING
USERS ABOUT ACTIVITY IS KEY
TO BRINGING THEM BACK IN THE
APP AND THIS IS IMPORTANT FOR
US AND SINCE RECENTLY ADDING
IT WE HAVE BEEN SENDING MORE
THAN 10 MILLION PUSH WOITION
WOITION NOTIFICATIONS A DAY.
BUT I CAN KEEP GOING FOR A
PRETTY LONG TIME BUT IN THE
INTEREST OF TIME AND KEEPING
THINGS LIGHT, LET'S SEND IT
BACK TO PATRICK.
Patrick Traughber:  THANK
YOU, KATIE.
[ APPLAUSE ]
IT WAS IMPORTANT FOR US TO
DELIVER A FAST, ENGAGING
EXPERIENCE WHILE CONSUMING
LESS MOBILE DATA.  TWITTER
LITE ALREADY CONSUMES LESS
DATA AS COMPARED TO OUR
NATIVE APPS, BUT ON TOP OF
THAT WE LAUNCHED A NEW
FEATURE CALLED DATA SAVER.
WHEN A USER IS IN DATA SAVER
MODE THEY CAN SAVE UP TO AN
ADDITIONAL 70% ON THEIR DATA.
EVERYONE.
NOW, TWITTER LITE  DELIVERS
ALL OF THE KEY FEATURES AT A
FRACTION OF THE SIZE COMPARED
TO OUR NATIVE APPS.  HERE YOU
CAN SEE THE SIZE DIFFERENCE
OF TWITTER LITE COMPARED TO
OUR ANDROID AND iOS APPS.
AND OF COURSE THE MOBILE WEB
IS MORE THAN JUST A LANDING
PAGE.  WE'RE EXCITED TO
PROVIDE A FAST, FEATURE-RICH
EXPERIENCE AND OUR USERS FROM
AROUND THE WORLD, FROM
NIGERIA TO JAPAN TO ECUADOR,
THE PHILIPPINES, THEY LOVE IT
AS WELL.
AND WE SEE IT IN OUR METRICS,
TOO.  WE'RE SEEING INCREASES
IN PAGES-PER-SESSION AND
TWEETS SENT FROM TWITTER
LITE.  AND LIKE KATIE SAID,
WE'RE SEEING MORE THAN 1
MILLION LAUNCHES FROM THE
HOME SCREEN EVERY DAY.
MOST IMPORTANTLY, OUR USERS
ARE HAPPY.  TWITTER LITE IS
OUR NEW, STANDARD MOBILE WEB
EXPERIENCE, AVAILABLE TO ALL
USERS GLOBALLY ON ANDROID
AND iOS, AND WE HOPE YOU
CHECK IT OUT.
THANK YOU.
[ APPLAUSE ]
Rahul Roy-Chowdhury:  GREAT.
THANK YOU,  PATRICK AND KATIE.
TWITTER.COM IS A PWA, FOLKS.
THE MODERN MOBILE WEB IS TRULY
MAINSTREAM.  AND IT'S NOT JUST
TWITTER.  LAST YEAR WE TALKED
ABOUT SOME EARLY ADOPTERS OF
PROGRESSIVE WEB APPS.  AND
SINCE
THEN THE MOMENTUM AND GROWTH
HAS
BEEN PHENOMENAL.  THESE
LAUNCHES
ARE HAPPENING ALL OVER THE
WORLD
AND THEY'RE HAPPENING ACROSS
ALL
INDUSTRY SEGMENTS.
LARGE TRAVEL COMPANIES, LIKE
EXPEDIA AND TRIVAGO AND WEGO
HAVE ALL LAUNCHED PROGRESSIVE
WEB APPS.  PUBLISHERS LIKE
INFOBAE AND FORBES HAVE
LAUNCHED
PROGRESSIVE WEB APPS.  FORBES
HAS SEEN THEIR USER ENGAGEMENT
DOUBLE SINCE THE LAUNCH OF
THEIR
PROGRESSIVE WEB APP.
eCOMMERCE SITES LIKE FANDANGO,
RAKATAN AND ALIBABA ARE ALL
INVESTING IN PWAs.  AND EVEN
NEW SERVICES THAT WE TEND TO
THINK OF AS APP-ONLY LIKE RIGHT
SHARING SERVICES HAVE GOTTEN IN
ON THE ACTION.
LYFT LAUNCHED THEIR PROGRESSIVE
WEB APP LAST FALL AND OLA CABS,
INDIA'S LARGEST RIDE SHARING
SERVICE JUST RECENTLY LAUNCHED
THEIR PWA.  AND, IN FACT, OLA
WILL BE UP ON STAGE IN JUST A
BIT TO SHOW IT OFF TO YOU.
NOW, ONE REASON PROGRESSIVE WEB
APPS IS SO SUCCESSFUL IS THAT
MULTIPLE BROWSERS ARE COMMITTED
TO THEM.  SO WHILE DEVELOPER
ADOPTION IS GROWING, SO IS
BROWSER SUPPORT.  AND IF A
BROWSER YOU CARE ABOUT ISN'T ON
THIS LIST YET
, PROGRESSIVE WEB
APPS ARE DESIGNED TO WORK WELL
EVERYWHERE.  SO YOU CAN ALWAYS
COUNT ON REACHING THE USERS
THAT
ARE IMPORTANT TO YOU.  TAKE THE
EXAMPLE OF LUXURY COSMETICS
BRAND LANCOME.  LANCOME
RECENTLY
LAUNCHED A PROGRESSIVE WEB APP
AND IT WORKS GREAT ON ALL
BROWSERS AND THEY HAVE SEEN
GREAT STATS.  BUT WHAT I WANT
TO
CALL OUT HERE IS THAT iOS IS
PARTICULAR IMPORTANT FOR
LANCOME
BECAUSE 65% OF THEIR MOBILE WEB
USERS ARE ON iPHONES.  AND
WHAT LANCOME OBSERVED WAS THAT
THOSE iOS USERS HAVE A SESSION
LENGTH THAT IS NOW 53% HIGHER
THAN IT WAS BEFORE THEIR
LAUNCH.
AND THIS IS DESPITE THE FACT
THAT SOME PWA FEATURES ARE NOT
SUPPORTED ON THAT PLATFORM.
NOW, THE
PROGRESSIVE IN
PROGRESSIVE WEB APPS REALLY
REFERS TO PROGRESSIVE
ENHANCEMENT.  BUT WHAT IT
REALLY
MEANS IS YOU CAN COUNT ON
REACHING THE USERS THAT ARE
IMPORTANT TO YOU NO MATTER WHAT
BROWSER MIX YOU CARE
ABOUT.
SO THE MOMENTUM AND GROWTH
ACROSS THE CORE PILLARS OF THE
MODERN MOBILE WEB, ACROSS AMP
AND PROGRESSIVE WEB APPS HAS
BEEN TRULY INCREDIBLE OVER THE
LAST 12 MONTHS.
THE MODERN MOBILE WEB IS NOW
TRULY
MAINSTREAM.  NOW, WHILE
ALL OF THIS MOMENTUM IS
HAPPENING ALL AROUND US, WE
HAVE
BEEN HEADS DOWN WORKING ON
MAKING PROGRESSIVE WEB APPS
EVEN
BETTER.
OUR GOAL IS TO MAKE WEB APPS
FEEL MORE INTEGRATED INTO THE
OVERALL DEVICE SO USERS GET A
ROBUST NO-COMPROMISES
EXPERIENCE.
HOW ARE WE DOING THIS?  WE'RE
ADDING A LOT OF NEW APIs TO
THE WEB PLATFORM.  IN FACT, WE
ADDED 215 NEW APIs JUST SINCE
GOOGLE I/O LAST YEAR.
BUT WHAT'S REALLY IMPORTANT IS
NOT THE NUMBER OF APIs WE
SHIP.  WHAT'S REALLY IMPORTANT
IS WHAT USE CASES CAN THESE
APIs UNLOCK FOR YOU.  AND I
WANT TO TALK ABOUT THREE USE
CASES TODAY.
INSTALLING WEB APPS TO YOUR
DEVICE, PAYING FOR THINGS ON
THE
WEB, AND POLISHED MEDIA
EXPERIENCES.
LET'S START WITH
INSTALLABILITY.
WE ALREADY HAVE A WAY TO ADD
WEB
APPS TO YOUR HOME SCREEN.  BUT
WE'VE MADE IT A LOT BETTER.
NOW, FIRST OF ALL, WE'VE HEARD
FROM MANY OF YOU THAT YOU WOULD
LIKE THE INSTALL PROMPT TO BE
MORE RELIABLE AND PREDICTABLE.
AND WE'VE HEARD YOUR FEEDBACK
LOUD AND CLEAR.  SO I'M HAPPY
TO
REPORT THAT NOW YOU CAN SHOW
THE
INSTALL PROMPT TO YOUR USERS
WHEN YOU WANT.
[ APPLAUSE
]
AND ONCE A USER HAS INSTALLED
YOUR WEB APP TO THEIR DEVICE,
IT
SHOWS UP EVERYWHERE YOU EXPECT
AN APP TO SHOW UP.  THEY SHOW
UP
IN THE APP LAUNCHER, NOT JUST
THE HOME SCREEN.
[ APPLAUSE ]
THEY'RE INTEGRATED INTO ANDROID
SETTINGS.
THEY PARTICIPATE IN
THE ANDROID INTENTS SYSTEM LIKE
ALONGSIDE ANY OTHER NATIVE APP.
THEY CAN HANDLE NOTIFICATIONS
NATIVELY RATHER THAN THROUGH
CHROME.
AND WEB APPS CAN LAUNCH
IN FULL-SCREEN MODE JUST LIKE
ANY NATIVE ANDROID APP CAN AS
WELL.
SO IT'S EASIER THAN EVER BEFORE
TO INSTALL WEB APPLICATIONS TO
YOUR DEVICE.  SO FROM
INSTALLING
WEB APPS TO YOUR DEVICE, LET'S
LOOK AT OUR SECOND USE CASE:
PAYING FOR THINGS ON THE WEB.
MOBILE PAYMENTS ARE A BIG DEAL.
$123 BILLION LAST YEAR JUST IN
THE U.S. ALONE.  AND TO MAKE
PAYMENT FLOWS ON THE WEB
BETTER,
WE LAUNCHED A ONE-TAP PAYMENTS
API CALLED PAYMENT REQUEST.
AND IT WORKS WITH CREDIT CARDS,
AND IT WORKS WITH GOOGLE FORMS
OF PAYMENT SUCH AS ANDROID PAY.
AND MANY MERCHANTS ARE ACTIVELY
USING THIS API TODAY, BUT WE
KNOW THAT CREDIT CARDS ARE JUST
PART OF THE PUZZLE HERE.
PEOPLE
HAVE LOTS OF DIFFERENT WAYS TO
PAY FOR THINGS, AND WE WANT TO
MAKE SURE THAT A USER ON THE
WEB
CAN PAY FOR THINGS USING THE
PAYMENT APPS THEY ALREADY USE.
SO I'M VERY PLEASED TO ANNOUNCE
THAT NOW YOUR WEB SITE CAN
INTEGRATE WITH ANY SUPPORTED
PAYMENT APP USING PAYMENT
REQUEST.  SO IF A USER HAS A
NATIVE PAYMENT APP INSTALLED,
YOU CAN INTEGRATE THAT RIGHT
INTO YOUR PAYMENT PLOW ON THE
WEB -- FLOW ON THE WEB.  WE ARE
ALREADY WORKING WITH SAMSUNG
PAY
AND ALIPAY AND MANY OTHER
NATIVE
PAYMENT APPS WILL BE INTEGRATED
VERY SOON.  IT'S NOT JUST
NATIVE
PAYMENT APPS, WE WANT WEB APPS
TO BE INTEGRATED AS WELL.  WE
ARE ACTIVELY PARTNERING WITH
PAYPAL TO BRING THEIR WEB APP
RIGHT INTO PAYMENT REQUEST.
SO WE WANT TO MAKE SURE THAT
THE
ENTIRE THIRD-PARTY PAYMENT
ECOSYSTEM IS AVAILABLE FOR YOU
IN YOUR CHECKOUT FLOW ON THE
WEB.
SO FROM INSTALLING WEB APPS TO
YOUR DEVICE AND PAYMENTS, LET'S
LOOK AT OUR THIRD USE CASE:
MEDIA EXPERIENCES.
MEDIA IS IMPORTANT.  OVER 70%
OF
INTERNET TRAFFIC IS VIDEO, AND
SO IT'S IMPORTANT TO US THAT WE
DELIVER A COMPLETE SOLUTION FOR
MEDIA ON THE MOBILE WEB.
NOW, WE'VE BEEN WORKING ON
ADDING MANY NEW APIs, THINGS
LIKE THE MEDIA SESSIONS API,
BACKGROUND FETCH, FULL SCREEN
ORIENTATION AND MANY OTHERS.
AND WE PUT TOGETHER A SAMPLE
APP
TO SHOW YOU THE KIND OF MEDIA
EXPERIENCES THAT ARE POSSIBLE
USING THESE APIs.  AND SO LET
ME WALK YOU THROUGH SOME OF THE
HIGHLIGHTS.
FIRST, AS YOU CAN SEE, I HAVE
INSTALLED THE APP TO MY DEVICE.
AND WHEN I TAP ON IT, IT
LAUNCHES IN FULL-SCREEN MODE
WITH A SPLASH SCREEN.  AND APP
BRANDING IS FRONT AND CENTER.
THERE'S NO CHROME UI ANYWHERE
HERE.  AND WHEN I TAP ON A
VIDEO
TO PLAY IT -- OH, ACTUALLY,
WHEN
I SCROLL UP AND DOWN, YOU CAN
SEE THAT THE APP FEELS SMOOTH
AND FLUID AND JUST WORKS
REALLY -- JUST WORKS IN A VERY
POLISHED WAY.
AND WHEN I TAP ON A VIDEO TO
PLAY IT, IT PLAYS BACK
INSTANTLY.  AND THIS IS NOT
BECAUSE THE WiFi IS REALLY
GOOD.  IT'S BECAUSE WE PREFETCH
THE FIRST FEW SECONDS OF VIDEO
SO THAT WE CAN ENABLE INSTANT
PLAYBACK.
AND IF I JUST FLIP MY PHONE
OVER, IT WILL INSTANTLY ENTER
FULL-SCREEN MODE, AND YOU CAN
SEE THIS VIDEO HAS CUSTOM
CONTROLS, SO I CAN GO BACKWARDS
AND FORWARDS 30 SECONDS.  AND
AS
I USE THE SCROLL BAR, YOU SEE
THUMBNAILS START TO
APPEAR.
AND IF I LOCK THE DEVICE, YOU
CAN SEE THE BACKGROUND POSTER
IMAGE AND YOU CAN SEE MEDIA
CONTROLS APPEAR RIGHT ON THE
LOCK SCREEN.  AND THIS COULD BE
REALLY USEFUL, FOR EXAMPLE, IF
I'M LISTENING TO AUDIO ON MY
MORNING COMMUTE.
AND, FINALLY, THIS ALL WORKS
REALLY WELL OFFLINE AS WELL.
SO
IF I GO INTO AIRPLANE MODE, I
CAN VIEW VIDEOS THAT I HAVE
PREVIOUSLY SAVED FOR OFF-LINE
VIEWING AND I CAN TAP ON IT AND
I CAN PLAY THE VIDEO WHILE I'M
OFF LINE.
ALL OF THIS GOODNESS IS
AVAILABLE ON THE MOBILE WEB
TODAY.  SO FROM INSTALLING WEB
APPS TO YOUR DEVICE, TO PAYING
FOR THINGS ON THE WEB, TO
POLISHED MEDIA EXPERIENCES,
WE'RE WORKING HARD TO MAKE
USING
WEB APPS A GREAT EXPERIENCE.
WE'RE ALSO WORKING HARD TO MAKE
BUILDING WEB APPS A GREAT
EXPERIENCE.  SO HERE'S A
QUESTION.  HOW GOOD IS YOUR
CURRENT WEB APP?  AND HOW DO
YOU
EVEN FIND OUT?  TO HELP YOU
ANSWER THAT QUESTION, WE
LAUNCHED A TOOL CALLED
LIGHTHOUSE.  LIGHTHOUSE GUIDES
YOU ALONG YOUR PWA JOURNEY AND
RUNS OVER A HUNDRED AUDITS
AGAINST YOUR WEB APP CHECKING
EVERYTHING FROM PAGE
PERFORMANCE
TO BYTE EFFICIENCY TO
ACCESSIBILITY.  AND IT EVEN
GIVES YOU A SCORE FROM ZERO TO
A
HUNDRED.
SO IF YOU WANT TO BRAG ABOUT
YOUR GREAT LIGHTHOUSE CORE ON
TWITTER, YOU CAN.  IT REALLY
DOES SEEM TO GET THE
COMPETITIVE
JUICES FLOWING.  AND YOU WANT
TO
TAKE ALL OF THE GOODNESS OF
LIGHTHOUSE AND MAKE IT AS EASY
FOR EVERYONE TO USE AS POSSIBLE
AND SO WE'RE INTEGRATING
LIGHTHOUSE RIGHT INTO CHROME
DEVELOPER TOOLS.
SO YOU CAN JUST OPEN IT UP, AND
YOU SEE A LIGHTHOUSE AUDIT
RIGHT
THERE.
WHETHER YOU WANT TO TWEET YOUR
SCORE OR NOT, I'LL LEAVE UP TO
YOU.
SO HOW DO YOU GET A GREAT
LIGHTHOUSE SCORE?
WELL, FOR ONE THING, YOUR APP
WILL NEED TO WORK WELL WHEN
YOU'RE OFF LINE OR ON A FLAKY
NETWORK.  AND THERE'S A
POWERFUL
TECHNOLOGY BAKED INTO BROWSERS
CALLED SERVICEWORKER THAT
ENABLES THIS.
BUT SERVICEWORKER IS QUITE A
LOW-LEVEL API AND CAN BE HARD
TO
WORK WITH DIRECTLY.  SO TO HELP
YOU TAKE FULL ADVANTAGE OF THE
POWER OF SERVICEWORKER, I'D
LIKE
TO INTRODUCE WORKBOX.
WORKBOX IS A TOOL THAT WE HAVE
BUILT THAT ENABLES YOU TO
TAKE -- TO GET THE MOST OUT OF
SERVICEWORKER.  IT BUILDS UPON
EXISTING TOOLS AND IT
SIMPLIFIES
A NUMBER OF COMMON PATTERNS AND
BEST PRACTICES, THINGS LIKE
FLEXIBLE CACHING, OR MANAGING
BACKGROUND SYNC OR EVEN
COLLECTING USER STATS WHEN THE
USER IS OFF LINE.
AND WORKBOX IS COMPLETELY
MODULAR AND FLEXIBLE SO THAT
YOU
CAN JUST TAKE WORKBOX,
INTEGRATE
IT INTO YOUR EXISTING TOOLS AND
START USING IT RIGHT
AWAY.
BUT DO REALLY MAX OUT THAT
LIGHTHOUSE SCORE, YOUR APP WILL
NEED TO DO MORE THAN JUST WORK
OFF LINE.  IT WILL NEED TO BE
FAST.  AND THIS MEANS THAT YOU
NEED TO BE ABLE TO BUILD AND
LOAD YOUR RICH, COMPLEX
APPLICATION WITH AS LITTLE
EXTRA
OVERHEAD AS POSSIBLE.
WEB COMPONENTS ARE A WAY TO
BUILD LIGHTWEIGHT USABLE PIECES
OF YOUR APP WITH VERY LITTLE
OVERHEAD.  YOU CAN CREATE YOUR
OWN COMPONENTS OR YOU CAN REUSE
ONE OF THE THOUSANDS OF
COMPONENTS THAT ALREADY EXIST.
REMEMBER THOSE AMAZING AMP
PERFORMANCE NUMBERS?  AMP IS
BASED ON WEB COMPONENTS.  AND
JUST LIKE WE BUILT WORKBOX TO
HELP YOU GET THE MOST OUT OF
SERVICEWORKER, WE BUILT POLYMER
TO HELP YOU GET THE MOST OUT OF
WEB COMPONENTS.
AND I'M HAPPY TO ANNOUNCE TODAY
THE LAUNCH OF POLYMER 2.0, THE
NEXT MAJOR EVOLUTION OF THE
POLYMER LIBRARY.
[ CHEERS AND APPLAUSE ]
IT IS A GROUND-UP RETHINK THAT
IS BUILT TO TAKE FULL ADVANTAGE
OF THE BEST NEW FEATURES OF THE
MODERN WEB PLATFORM.  IT USES
THE NEW WEB COMPONENT APIs
THAT HAVE SHIPPED IN CHROME AND
SAFARI.
IT EMBRACES ES6 CLASSES.  IT IS
COMPLETELY MODULAR.  AND BEST
OF
ALL, IT'S 10% FASTER AND 80%
SMALLER.  SO TO TAKE A LOOK AT
SOMEONE WHO HAS USED POLYMER TO
BUILD A GREAT PROGRESSIVE WEB
APP WITH A GREAT LIGHTHOUSE
SCORE, LET ME INVITE UP ON
STAGE
DIPIKA KAPADIA AND RATUL ROY
FROM OLA CABS.
[ APPLAUSE ]
Dipika Kapadia:  HI, EVERYONE.
I'M DIPIKA KAPADIA, HEAD OF
CONSUMER WEB PRODUCTS.
Ratul Roy:  I'M RATUL ROY,
PRINCIPAL ENGINEER.
Dipika Kapadia:  WE ARE HERE
ALL
THE WAY FROM BANGALORE AND
REALLY EXCITED TO TELL YOU
ABOUT
OLA AND OUR PWA.
OLA IS INDIA'S LARGEST
RIDE-HAILING SERVICE WITH A
MISSION TO PROVIDE MOBILITY FOR
A BILLION INDIANS.  WE STARTED
SIX YEARS AGO OUT OF A LITTLE
APARTMENT IN MUMBAI.  AND IN
THOSE DAYS, OUR CO-FOUNDER
WOULD
ACTUALLY DRIVE CUSTOMERS AROUND
WHEN THEIR RIDE DIDN'T SHOW UP.
TODAY WE DO OVER A MILLION
DAILY
RIDES.  BUT EVEN THAT'S NOT
ENOUGH WHEN YOUR MISSION IS TO
MOVE A BILLION INDIANS AROUND.
IN ORDER TO DO THAT, WE NEEDED
TO REACH TIER 2, TIER 3 CITIES,
SMALLER CITIES WITH FLAKY
NETWORKS WHERE USERS HAVE
LOW-END SMARTPHONES WITH SLOW
FRAMEWORK
PROCESSORS AND LOW MEMORY.
THAT'S THE REASON WE BUILT THIS
PWA.  WE WOULD LOVE TO SHOW YOU
WHAT WE BUILT, SO LET'S GO TO
DEMO WITH RATUL DRIVING.
RATUL, LET'S ASSUME WE'RE BACK
IN BANGALORE AFTER AN AWESOME
I/O EXPERIENCE AND NEED TO GET
A
RIDE FROM THE AIRPORT BACK TO
THE OFFICE.  WILL YOU CALL A
SUV?
Ratul Roy:  SURE, DIPIKA.  I'M
LAUNCHING THE PWA FROM THE HOME
SCREEN.
IT'S FAST, ISN'T IT?  IT'S
ASKING FOR THE BROWSER LOCATION
PERMISSION.  BUT I'M GOING TO
GO
AHEAD AND CHOOSE OTHER LOCATION
FROM MY SAVED FAVORITES.
SO I'LL BE TAKING CAB FROM
AIRPORT TO WORK.
THE REASON I
COULD DO IT SO FAST IS BECAUSE
I
SAVED ALL THE LOCATION AS MY
FAVORITES.  IF YOU HAVEN'T,
STILL YOU CAN GO AHEAD AND
WHILE
SEARCHING THE ADDRESS BAR FOR
THE LOCATION OR YOU CAN LOAD IT
IN THE MAP AND NAVIGATE
THROUGH.
IF YOU HAVE NOTICED, IN ORDER
TO
SAVE DATA, WE LOAD THE MAP ONLY
WHEN YOU NEED
TO.
HERE ARE THE RIDES, DIPIKA.  WE
HAVE A SUV AVAILABLE IN FIVE
MINUTES.
Dipika Kapadia:  COOL.  BUT
WHAT
KIND OF RIDE ARE WE GOING TO
GET?
Ratul Roy:  SURE, HAVE A LOOK
HERE.
Dipika Kapadia:  SWEET.  I
THINK
EXTRA LEG ROOM AFTER THIS LONG
FLIGHT BACK FITS THE BILL.
Ratul Roy:  SURE.
Dipika Kapadia:  SO, GUYS, SO
FAR YOU'VE SEEN OUR PWA IS AN
IMMERSIVE, FULL-PAGE EXPERIENCE
THAT'S RESPONSIVE TO THE TOUCH,
LOADS REALLY FAST, AND SUPPORTS
BACK-BUTTON NAVIGATION MUCH
LIKE
A NATIVE APP.
SO WHAT DO YOU SAY, GUYS?
SHALL
WE BOOK A REAL-LIVE CAB IN
BANGALORE?  IT'S ABOUT 5:00
A.M.
THERE.
[ LAUGHTER ]
AWESOME.
RATUL, DO THE HONORS, PLEASE.
Ratul Roy:  SURE.  LET ME  TRY.
I'M CONFIRMING THE BOOKING TO
PICK UP.
Dipika Kapadia:  GO FOR IT.
OOPS, THERE YOU HAVE IT,  GUYS,
THIS IS A REAL-LIVE  BOOKING IN
BANGALORE THAT WE  JUST MADE.
THANK YOU SO MUCH, RATUL.
Ratul Roy:  SURE.
[ APPLAUSE ]
Dipika Kapadia:  NOTHING  RIGGED
HERE.
YOU BETTER CANCEL THAT  BOOKING
BEFORE HE GETS MAD  AND SHOWS
UP.
[ LAUGHTER ]
Ratul Roy:  LET'S
(INDISCERNIBLE).
Dipika Kapadia:  AWESOME.
OKAY.
SO THE OLA PWA IS ONLY A HALF
MEG, OF WHICH THE APPLICATION
CODE IS JUST 200KB.
SO HOW DID WE BUILD THIS  REALLY
PERFORMANT APP WITH  SUCH A
SMALL
SIZE?
LET'S LOOK AT THAT.
FIRST, WE USED THE POLYMER
FRAMEWORK, WHICH LEVERAGES
CHROME OR OTHER BROWSER
RESOURCES, AND GIVES US
BLAZING-FAST WEB COMPONENTS,
DOM
AND CSS CAPSULATION,  SUFING
SHADOW.COM, AND HTML  SHADOW
PORT, FOR A VERY  EFFICIENT
40KB.
NEXT, LET'S TALK ABOUT THOSE
FAST LOAD TIMES.
WHAT YOU SAW RIGHT NOW IN THE
DEMO WAS THE REPEAT CACHED
EXPERIENCE OF THE HOME  SCREEN.
BUT WE HAVE A REALLY  ENVIABLE
FIRST LOAD TIME OF  ONE TO THREE
SECONDS,  DEPENDING ON THE
NETWORK,  INCLUDING LOW 3G,
WHICH
IS  WHERE OUR TARGET AUDIENCE
LIVES.
LET ME SHOW YOU HOW.
AS YOU CAN SEE ON THE LEFT  SIDE
HERE, WE LOAD OUR WEB
COMPONENTS
VERY  STRATEGICALLY, USING A
WATERFALL MODEL, SO THAT  WE'RE
ONLY FETCHING THOSE  COMPONENTS
THAT THE USER  NEEDS TO SEE FOR
HIS FIRST  INTERACTION WITH OUR
PWA.
WE'RE FETCHING IN THE
BACKGROUND
THE OTHER  RESOURCES HE NEEDS TO
ENSURE  THAT THE EXPERIENCE
STAYS
SNAPPY GOING FORWARD.
ONCE WE'VE LOADED ALL THE
COMPONENTS, USING WORKBOX, WE
PRE-CACHE ALL OF THESE, SO  THAT
THE REPEAT LOAD TIME  STAYS
UNDER
A SECOND.
FROM THIS POINT ON, THE ONLY
SERVER CALL THAT WE ARE  MAKING
IS TO FETCH DATA, SUCH  AS
REAL-TIME CAB  AVAILABILITY,
MAKING A  BOOKING, ET CETERA.
ALL OF THIS STAYS UNDER ABOUT
5KB.
WE ALSO LEVERAGE LIGHTHOUSE.
[ APPLAUSE ]
AND WEB PAGE TEST.  AND WE  ARE
PLANNING TO INTEGRATE
LIGHTHOUSE
IN OUR BUILD,  BECAUSE,
OBVIOUSLY, WE'LL ADD  MORE
FEATURES TO THE APP.  SO  HERE
YOU CAN SEE OUR  LIGHTHOUSE
CORE.
WE ARE  VERY, VERY PROUD OF THIS
CORE.  AND WE OPTIMIZE FOR A
PERFECT SCORE.  AND WE CAN
TOTALLY RELATE TO DEVELOPERS
WANTING TO TWEET AND BRAG  ABOUT
THEIRS.
SO HOW'S OUR PWA DOING FOR  US?
WELL, WE'VE BEEN OUT FOR  ABOUT
A
MONTH NOW, AND WE ARE  SEEING
THAT OUR CONVERSION,  OUR RIDES
BOOKED IN TIER 2  CITIES, IS
COMPARABLE TO OUR  NATIVE APP.
BUT WHAT'S GREAT TO SEE IS  THAT
IN TIER 3 CITIES,  SMALLER
CITIES, OUR  CONVERSION IS
ACTUALLY 30%  HIGHER THAN OUR
NATIVE APP,  WHICH SHOWS THAT,
CLEARLY, WE  ARE SOLVING FOR
NETWORK  ISSUES AND THE NEED FOR
LOW  DATA USAGE, WHICH IS
INHERENT  IN THESE GEOGRAPHIES.
WE'VE ALSO SEEN MOBILE  TRAFFIC
INCREASE BY 68% IN  THESE CITIES
SINCE WE  LAUNCHED, WHICH SHOWS
THAT WE  ARE EXPANDING OUR
REACH.
BUT WHAT SURPRISED EVEN US IS
THAT 20% OF OUR PWA BOOKINGS
COME FROM USERS WHO HAVE
PREVIOUSLY UNINSTALLED OUR
NATIVE APP.  SO THIS SHOWS  THAT
OUR PWA CAN EVEN BE A  GREAT
RE-ENGAGEMENT TOOL.
SO THERE YOU HAVE IT, GUYS.
OUR
PWA HAS BEEN A WIN-WIN  FOR OUR
CUSTOMERS AND FOR  OLA.
SO I HOPE SHARING OUR JOURNEY
INSPIRES MANY OF YOU TO BUILD
YOUR OWN PROGRESSIVE WEB APP,
AND THE NEXT TIME YOU'RE IN
INDIA, REMEMBER   TO BOOK  YOUR
RIDE ON OLA.
[ LAUGHTER ]
[ APPLAUSE ]
Ratul Roy:  THANK YOU.
Dipika Kapadia:  THANK YOU.
HERE YOU GO, RAHUL.
Rahul Roy-Chowdhury:  GREAT.
THANK YOU, DIPIKA AND RATUL.
AND CONGRATULATIONS TO THE  TEAM
AT OLA.
SO, FOLKS, THERE YOU HAVE IT,
AMAZING MOMENTUM ON THE CORE
PILLARS OF THE MODERN MOBILE
WEB, AMP, AND PWAS.
NEW APIs, UNLOCKING NEW
EXPERIENCES AND NEW USE  CASES,
EVERYTHING FROM  INSTALLING WEB
APPS TO YOUR  DEVICE, TO PAYING
FOR THINGS  ON THE WEB, TO
POLISHED MEDIA  EXPERIENCES.
AND LOOKING AHEAD, COMPUTING
CONTINUES TO EVOLVE AT A FAST
CLIP.  AND WE AT GOOGLE WANT  TO
MAKE SURE THAT WE CAN HELP
DEVELOPERS TAKE ADVANTAGE OF
THESE CHANGES, WHETHER  THEY'RE
BUILDING NATIVE APPS  OR
BUILDING
FOR THE WEB.
AND JUST LIKE WE DO WITH  NATIVE
APPS, WE WANT THE WEB  TO BE A
GREAT PLATFORM FOR  FUTURE
TECHNOLOGIES AS THEY  EVOLVE.
ONE SUCH FUTURE TECHNOLOGY IS
VR.  VIRTUAL REALITY ENABLES
THE
CREATION OF  RICHLY-IMAGINED
WORLDS THAT  YOU CAN FULLY
IMMERSE  YOURSELF IN.  AND
THROUGH THE  WEBVR API, ALL OF
THIS  EXPRESSIVE POWER IS
AVAILABLE  ON THE WEB.  WEBVR
ENABLES  COMPANIES LIKE WITHIN
TO
SHOWCASE THESE AMAZING VR
EXPLORATIONS FROM CREATORS
AROUND THE WORLD, RIGHT IN  YOUR
BROWSER.
WEBVR ENABLES COMPANIES LIKE
SKETCH PAD TO BRING YOU THESE
AMAZING STUNNING VR SCENES TO
EXPLORE.  THEY HAVE OVER ONE
AND
A HALF MILLION OF THESE.
NOW, THESE WOULD BE TRULY
MIND-BLOWING IF YOU ALL HAD  VR
HEADSETS ON.  BUT YOU GET  A
SENSE OF WHAT IS POSSIBLE.
WEBVR IS NOW FULLY SUPPORTED  IN
CHROME, AND MOST MAJOR  BROWSER
VENDORS HAVE  ANNOUNCED THEIR
SUPPORT AS  WELL.
AND LOOKING EVEN FURTHER  AHEAD,
WE SEE THE ADVENT OF  AR,
AUGMENTED REALITY, A WAY  TO
CONNECT INFORMATION TO THE
PHYSICAL WORLD.
SO NO MATTER HOW COMPUTING
EVOLVES AND CHANGES IN THE
FUTURE, THE WEB WILL ALWAYS  BE
HERE AS A WAY FOR YOU TO  REACH
YOUR USERS AT
SCALE.
IF YOU WANT TO DIG IN MORE,  WE
HAVE A LOT OF GREAT  SESSIONS ON
THE MOBILE WEB AT  I/O THIS
YEAR.
AND EVEN  AFTER I/O IS DONE,
COME
AND  TALK TO US.  TELL US WHAT
YOU'RE WORKING ON.  TELL US
WHAT
YOUR CHALLENGES ARE.  WE  ARE
HERE TO HELP YOU BE  SUCCESSFUL
ON THE WEB.
IT'S AMAZING TO SEE HOW FAR
WE'VE COME OVER THE LAST 12
MONTHS.  THE MODERN MOBILE  WEB
IS NOW MAINSTREAM, AND I  CAN'T
WAIT TO SEE WHAT  HAPPENS IN THE
NEXT 12  MONTHS.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
[ APPLAUSE ]
Ben Poiesz:  HI, EVERYBODY.
I'M
BEN POIESZ, I'M THE PRODUCT
MANAGER FOR ANDROID FRAMEWORK.
I LIKE HOW EVERYBODY IS RIGHT
OVER THERE.  I WISH I COULD
JOIN
YOU.  THE SUN IS GOING TO COME
AND GET ME.
WHAT I WANT TO TALK TO YOU GUYS
ABOUT IS BACKGROUND LIMITS AND
A
LOT OF THE INFRASTRUCTURE THAT
WE'VE PUT IN PLACE IN O, AND IT
IS A STARTING POINT.  AND I
WANTED TO TRY AND HAVE THIS
TALK
TO GIVE YOU A GLIMPSE OF HOW
WE'RE APPROACHING THE PROBLEM
AND SO YOU DON'T JUST THINK
WE'RE TRYING TO RUIN ALL THE
APPS AND EVERYTHING YOU'RE
DOING
IN THE BACKGROUND.  WE'RE
ACTUALLY TRYING TO FIND A
BALANCE OF ENABLING USERS TO
HAVE BETTER LIFE THEY CAN RELY
ON AND HAVE DEVELOPERS DO THE
USE CASES THAT THEY TRI-ARE
GREAT AND RESPOND.WILL TO.  AT
THAT DO THAT, WE'RE GOING TO
TALK A BIT ABOUT THE PAST, A
LOT
ABOUT THE PRESENT, AND A LITTLE
BIT ABOUT THE FUTURE AND WE'LL
GIVE A GLIMPSE OF THE SPACE
WE'RE TRYING TO GO LONGER TERM.
SO IN THE PAST, WE HAVE DOZE
AND
STANDBY.  DOZE AND DOZE LITE
WERE INTRODUCED TO TRY AND SAVE
BATTERY IN TWO MAIN CONDITIONS,
OFF
FOR A LONG PERIOD OF TIME.  A
GOOD EXAMPLE IS I TAKE MY
TABLET, I TOSS IT IN MY DESK
AND
IT SITS THERE FOR A FEW DAYS.
YOU REALLY WANT THE DEVICE TO
LAST A LONG TIME AND DOZE WAS
INTRODUCED TO MAKE THAT DEVICE
LAST FOR UP TO A WEEK.  IT WAS
LARGELY SUCCESSFUL WHEN IT WAS
INTRO INTRODUCED.  DOZE LITE
WAS
TRYING TO TAKE THAT SAME
CONCEPT
AND APPLY IT TO MY PHONE IS IN
MY POCKET, IT'S NOT ON BUT IT
IS
ON ME.  AND DOZE WASN'T
IDENTIFYING THAT SITUATION.
AND
DOZE LITE WAS TRYING TO TARGET
THAT.  AND TO START SLOWING
DOWN
APPLICATIONS AND LIMITING WHAT
WAS HAPPENING THROUGHOUT THE
DAY.  APP STANDBY WAS SIMILAR
IN
CONCEPT IS THE USER INTERACTING
VERY OFTEN AND IF NOT, BEGIN
THROTTLING THAT BACK.
WE ALSO LOOKED AT BROADCAST
REMOVAL, AND THIS IS WHEN WE
TARGETED AN INITIAL SET OF
THREE
PARTICULAR BROADCASTS.  AND THE
BEST EXAMPLE OF THIS WAS WE
WERE
FINDING YOU TAKE A PHOTO AND
SUDDENLY ALL THE APPLICATIONS
ARE GETTING REALLY EXCITED
ABOUT
THAT PHOTO BECAUSE IT'S
LISTENING TO THAT BROADCAST.
THEY WOULD ALL BE WAKING UP A
WHAT'S GOING ON WITH THE PHOTO?
SHOULD I BACK IT UP?  WHAT
SHOULD HAPPEN?  THE USER IS
LIKE, I AM REALLY TRYING TO
TAKE
A PHOTO.  GOD FORBID SHOULD YOU
TAKE TWO PHOTOS.  THE SECOND
PHOTO IS NOW THIS RESOURCE
CONTENTION.  AND SO WE FOUND
THIS WAS REALLY SUCCESSFUL TO
PULL THESE GUYS BACK FROM BEING
THESE GENERAL BROADCASTS ANNEX
STEAD BEING A BIT MORE --
INSTEAD BEING MORE TARGETED.
THAT'S THE LEAD-IN TO THE
PRESENT WHEN WE STARTED LOOKING
AT A GENERAL STRATEGY FOR
BACKGROUND LIMITS.  I WILL ALSO
TALK ABOUT ALERT WINDOW WHICH
IS
A SIMILAR PROBLEM SPACE.  AND A
BIT HOW WE ARE TRYING TO BRING
A
DATABASE APPROACH TO IMPROVING
SYSTEM HEALTH ON ANDROID.  I
DON'T MEAN HEALTH LIKE MY
PERSONAL HEALTH, BUT MORE LIKE
THE DEVICE HEALTH.
AND THEN I'LL PEPPER IN A FEW
BEST PRACTICES AS WE GO
THROUGH.
SO BACKGROUND LIMITS.  WHY?  SO
WHAT WE'RE TRYING TO DO IS TWO
PARTS.  ONE IS TO SAVE BATTERY.
THIS ONE WAS LARGELY AROUND THE
LIMITS THAT WE PUT IN PLACE FOR
LOCATION AND THE GOAL THAT
WE'RE
TRYING TO GET AT IS WE WANT
MULTIDAY BATTERY LIFE.  THAT'S
WHAT'S GOING TO TAKE US A WHILE
TO GET THERE.  BUT THAT'S WHAT
WE'RE TRYING TO GO.  AND TO DO
THAT, WE KNOW WE HAVE A PRETTY
LARGE TASK IN TERMS OF WHAT'S
HAPPENING IN THE BACKGROUND.
IT'S A NEARLY 6 TO 8%
EFFICIENCY
IMPROVEMENT FROM WHERE WE ARE
TODAY.  THAT'S LIKE THE
BACKDROP, IF YOU WILL OF HOW
WE'RE THINKING ABOUT IT.  AND
THESE ARE THE KIND OF INITIAL
STEPS IN SETTING THE FRAMEWORK
FOR HOW WE'RE GOING TO GET
THERE.
THE OTHER PART IS ABOUT RAM
MANAGEMENT AND WORKING ON HOW
BROADCASTS ARE BEING FIRED TO
APPLICATIONS AND ALSO DEALING
WITH HOW APPLICATIONS ARE
RUNNING IN THE BACKGROUNDS WITH
LONG-RUNNING SERVICES.
SO JUST TO GIVE YOU A CONCRETE
EXAMPLE OF THIS IS YOU HAVE
THIS
CHART OF SCREEN-OFF PERFORMANCE
OVER TIME.  AND THE ONE THING
YOU CAN SEE UP HERE -- I CAN'T
SEE MY MONITORS ANYMORE.  THE
SUN HAS TOTALLY KILLED ME UP
THERE.
THE ONE THING YOU CAN SEE UP
THERE IS OVER TIME YOU'RE GOING
TO HAVE A SLIDE OF YOUR
SCREEN-OFF BATTERY PERFORMANCE,
THE LONGER THE PHONE IS IN THE
FIELD.  YOU'LL ALSO SEE THAT
THE
JANK RATES, THE SLOW UI FRAMES,
GET HIGHER THE LONGER THE
DEVICE
IS IN THE FIELD.  AND SO THESE
ARE THINGS THAT WE REALLY WANT
TO HELP REMEDY AND ADD
ROBUSTNESS INTO THE PLATFORM SO
WE CAN REALLY SMOOTH THESE OUT.
LIKE, OBVIOUSLY WE'RE TALKING
DEVICE'S AGE AND PHYSICS COMES
INTO PLAY AND THE MARCH TIME
HAPPENS BUT WE DON'T WANT THEM
TO BE ANYWHERE NEAR THAT STEEP.
ANOTHER EXAMPLE IS AS A DEVICE
IS ON IN THE COURSE OF EVEN
DAYS, THIS ONE IS MEASURED
ALL -- INITIALLY HOURS AND THEN
IN DAYS, YOU CAN SEE JUST
UPTIME
STARTS TO TAKE A TOLL ON THE
DEVICE.
AND SO THESE ARE THE THINGS
WE'RE REALLY TRYING TO TARGET
AND IMPROVE.
SO LET'S DIG IN A LITTLE BIT TO
SOME OF THE CHANGES THAT WE'RE
INTRODUCING.
BACKGROUND LIMITS ON THE SAVE
RAM PART IS WE WANT TO RESTRICT
SERVICES AND BROADCASTS AND WE
WANT TO REDUCE THE AMOUNT OF
CHURN THAT'S HAPPENING ON THE
DEVICE.  AND TO SAVE BATTERY,
WE'RE LOOKING TO IMPROVE
BACKGROUND LOCATION SCAN RATES
AND WiFi SCAN RATES AND TO
REDUCE THEM AND MAKE THEM BE
MORE OF A TRICKLE THAN THESE
BURSTY EVENTS THAT WE'RE SEEING
HAPPENING IN THE ECOSYSTEM.
SO FOR BACKGROUND LIMITS, THE
BIG ONE HERE IS WE WANT TO
REDUCE THAT RAM USAGE.  TO DO
THAT IS -- WELL, THIS SLIDE IS
THE SAME.  I SHOULD SKIP.
SO HOW WE'RE DOING THAT IS WITH
BROADCAST RECEIVERS.  BY
PULLING
THESE GUYS BACK YOU ARE ABLE TO
THEN SAY, OKAY, ALL THESE
BROADCASTS THAT ARE IMPLICIT
ARE
GOING TO BE SILENCED.  IF YOU
ARE NOT CURRENTLY RUNNING,
WE'RE
NOT GOING TO WAKE YOU UP FOR
THEM EXCEPT IN THE CASE WHERE
THEY ARE EXPLICIT.  WE SAY
SOMETHING IMPORTANT HAS
HAPPENED
OR YOU HAVE BEEN TARGETED OR
REGISTERED FOR SOME WAKEUP AND
THOSE THINGS WILL STILL WORK
COMPLETELY AS NORMAL AS THEY
DID
BEFORE.  SO THAT FOLLOWS ALARMS
AND NOTIFICATIONS.
OTHER ONES THAT WE'RE STILL
KEEPING AROUND, BOOT COMPLETE,
LOCALE CHANGING AND THESE ARE
REALLY EVENTS THAT ARE NOT
HAPPENING AS THE USER'S TRYING
TO DO SOMETHING ELSE.  THAT'S
REALLY BEEN THE TARGET OF HOW
WE
APPROACH WHICH THINGS SHOULD
CONTINUE TO WORK AND WHICH
THINGS SHOULD WE START
DEFERRING.
THE OTHER ONE HERE IS FREE
RUNNING BACKGROUND SERVICES
SHOULD NO LONGER BE A THING.
AND THE IDEA BEHIND THAT IS WE
WANT USERS TO HAVE VISIBILITY
TO
WHAT'S HAPPENING ON THEIR
PHONE.
AND SO IF AN APPLICATION IS
DOING SOMETHING REALLY
EXPENSIVE
IN THE BACKGROUND, WE WANT
THERE
TO BE SOME AWARENESS FOR THE
USER.  WE DON'T WANT THE DEVICE
TO BE TOILING AWAY IN THE
BACKGROUND WITHOUT ANY
AWARENESS.  THIS MEANS WE WANT
TO START STOPPING THOSE
SERVICES
AFTER THEY'RE RUNNING FOR A
LITTLE BIT.  WE WANT TO START
THROWING -- WE WILL START
THROWING AN EXCEPTION IF YOU
TRY
TO START A BACKGROUND SERVICE
WHEN YOU'RE NOT IN THE
FOREGROUND OR WHEN YOU DON'T
HAVE A FOREBROWNED SERVICE
RUNNING.  AND THIS IS ALSO THE
VERY LAST ONE, IS WE START
RELEASING WAKELOCKS.  YOU STILL
WANT TO MANAGE WAKELOCKS.
DON'T
THINK THE OS IS GOING TO HANDLE
THEM FOR YOU.  WE ARE ADDING
MORE PROTECTIONS IN DIFFERENT
SCENARIOS WHERE THEY MIGHT HAVE
BEEN LEAKED OR THE DEVELOPER
WAS
A LITTLE LAX IN THEIR CLEANUP.
WE STILL HAVE THE WHITE LISTING
WE HAD BEFORE SO THERE WILL BE
A
WHITE LISTING STRATEGY THAT'S
AROUND WHEN GCM FIRES OFF A
BROADCAST TO YOUR APPLICATION.
YOU WILL STILL GET WOKEN UP.
YOU WILL GET A SHORT EXEMPTION
TO HANDLE THAT MESSAGE.  FROM
THERE YOU CAN KICK OFF A
SERVICE, BRING YOUR APPLICATION
TO THE FOREGROUND IF IT'S
APPROPRIATE.
OR YOU CAN JUST TAKE THE NOTE,
RUN A SCHEDULE A JOB AND ALARM
AND HAVE IT BE SCHEDULED BY THE
OS AND HAPPEN WHEN IT HAPPENS.
THERE IS FLEXIBILITY FOR OEMS
IF
YOU ARE RELYING ON OEMs
SPECIFIC INTENT OR SOME
SPECIFIC
BEHAVIOR THAT'S NOT BUILD IN
THE
EPS.  THE OEM WILL DEFINE WHICH
MYS ARE EXPLICITS AND IMPLIES
SYS IT AND WHICH THINGS CAN BE
FIRED AND WHICH THINGS GET THE
BRAKES TAPPED ON THEM.  YOU
MIGHT BE THINKING AT THIS
POINT,
THE USER PART OF MY BRAIN IS
REALLY HAPPY PROBABLY.  THE
DEVELOPER SIDE IS GOING, WAIT,
I
NEED -- I HAVE THINGS TO DO.  I
HAVE THINGS TO SAY.  HOW CAN I
COMMUNICATE TO THE DEVELOPER?
LIKE, IT'S REALLY IMPORTANT,
BEN, WHAT ARE YOU DOING?
THERE'S A NUMBER OF STRATEGIES
AND I WILL TALK ABOUT THEM
RIGHT
NOW ABOUT HOW TO DO THESE
OPERATIONS STILL WITH THE USER
ON A TIMELY BASIS AND STILL BE
RESPECTFUL OF THE BATTERY BUT
THEN ALSO BE ABLE TO TELL THE
USER, NO, I'M DOING SOMETHING
INCREDIBLY IMPORTANT.  SO THE
FIRST ONE TO LOOK AT IS USING
FIREBASE AND GOOGLE CLOUD
MESSAGING AND USING THE HIGH
PRIORITY AND NORMAL PRIORITY
MESSAGES.
I HOPE YOU'RE TAKE-AWAY FROM
THIS SLIDE IS NOT LIKE FIRE ALL
TORPEDOES AT HIGH PRIORITY.
REALLY WANT YOU TO BE BALANCED
IN SAYING IF SOMETHING IS
IMPORTANT, LIKE, SAY, MY FIRE
ALARM IS GOING OFF AT HOME AND
I
WANT TO SEND A NOTIFICATION TO
THE USER, USE A HIGH-PRIORITY
NOTIFICATION.  IT'S KIND OF A
BIG DEAL.  IF YOU ARE, SAY,
USING A USER IS SCHEDULED FOR A
TV SHOW THEY LIKE AND THAT TV
SHOW IS NOW AVAILABLE AND THEY
CAN STREAM IT AT THEIR LEISURE,
USE A NORMAL-PRIORITY
NOTIFICATION.  IT WILL MAKE A
BIG DIFFERENCE IN THE BATTERY
LIFE OF THE DEVICE AND IT
REALLY
ADDS UP WHEN THE ECOSYSTEM
STARTS TAKING THESE APPROACHES.
THE OTHER ONE HERE IS SOMETHING
NEW CALLED THE JOB INTENT
SERVICE.  THIS IS COMING OUT --
WE JUST MISSED THE WINDOW BUT I
STILL WANTED TO TALK ABOUT IT
FOR WHAT CAME OUT WITH THE NEW
26 BETA.  BUT IT WILL BE COMING
OUT SHORTLY BEFORE O LAUNCH.
IT'S A STRATEGY OF YOU CAN USE
JOB INTENT SERVICE ON O TO GIVE
YOU BACKWARDS COMPAT SUPPORT SO
YOU WILL USE THEN JOBS WHEN
YOU'RE ON O AND YOU WILL HAVE
AN
AUTOMATIC FALL-BACK TO USING
SERVICES PRE-O.  THE REALLY
NICE
PART ABOUT THIS WHEN YOU HAVE
THAT FALL-BACK, WE WILL HANDLE
THE WAKELOCKS FOR YOU.  SO YOU
DON'T HAVE TO WORRY ABOUT IF
YOU
WILL MAKE A LEAK OR MAKE A
MISTAKE THERE.  DEFINITELY LOOK
AT THIS WHEN IT COMES OUT.  IT
WILL MAKE YOUR LIVES A LOT
EASIER TO ADOPT.
THE OTHER LAST ONE IS ABOUT
ALARMS, SYNCS AND JOB
SCHEDULING.  THESE ARE ALL GOOD
STRATEGIES TO RUN JOBS ON A
CADENCE IN THE BACKGROUND THAT
GIVES THE OS FLEXIBILITY ABOUT
WHEN IT RUNS.  SO I WILL GIVE
YOU AN EXAMPLE.
IF ALL THESE APPLICATIONS
BEFORE, WHEN WE HAD A WORLD OF
THESE BROADCASTS BEING FIRED
AND
THAT APPLICATION CAN START
SERVICES, THEY'LL ALL START AT
THE SAME TIME.  AND THE OS
REALLY HAS ONLY NUKES TO DEAL
WITH THIS PROBLEM.  WE CAN ONLY
KILL YOUR PROCESS.  THERE'S NO
ABILITY TO THROTTLE.  WE CAN'T
TRY TO SQUISH RAM.  IT'S JUST
YOU LIVE OR YOU DIE.  AND WHEN
THE RAM BECOMES CONTENTIOUS, WE
START THRASHING PRETTY RAPIDLY.
WHEN WHEN YOU ARE USING YOU'RE
USING JOBS AND
ALARMS, THE OS HAS NOW
FLEXIBILITY TO DEFER, TO RUN
ONE
JOB AT A TIME, A FEW JOBS  AT A
TIME, AND SPREAD IT OUT  ACROSS
THE LIFETIME OF A  DEVICE.  AND
THAT AVOIDS,  THEN, RESOURCE
CONTENTION, IT  AVOID JANKINESS
IN THE  BACKGROUND.
I'VE MADE THIS REALLY  EXCITING
FLOWCHART FOR YOU  THAT YOU CAN
LOOK AT IT  LATER.  THE IDEA
BEHIND IT IS  ROUGHLY LOOKING AT
WHAT ARE  THE DIFFERENT STAGES
THAT ARE  HAPPENING AND WHAT IS
THE  RIGHT CHOICE FOR YOU AS A
DEVELOPER AND FOR THE USER TO
HAVE, LIKE, THE -- THE BEST,
MOST EFFICIENT EXPERIENCE FOR
THE USE CASE THAT YOU'RE  TRYING
TO ACHIEVE.
YES, THE END OF THIS IS MAYBE
YOU SHOULDN'T DO IT IN THE
BACKGROUND.  AND THAT'S THE  ONE
I REALLY WANT YOU TO  FOCUS ON,
IS THINK ABOUT DO I  REALLY HAVE
TO BE DOING THIS?   IS THE USER
GOING TO  UNDERSTAND WHAT I'M
TRYING TO  DO?
IF THE USER IS GOING TO
UNDERSTAND WHAT YOU'RE TRYING
TO
DO, AND A GREAT EXAMPLE OF  THIS
ARE, LIKE, NAVIGATION  APPS,
MUSIC-PLAYING APPS,  VARIOUS
EXERCISE  APPLICATIONS, ALL OF
THOSE  SCENARIOS, IF YOU'RE
RUNNING  A FOREGROUND SERVICE
AND
THE  USER SEES A NOTIFICATION,
IT'S GOING TO MAKE SENSE TO
THEM.  YOU'RE GOING TO BE
REALLY
WELL ALIGNED.
SO IN THOSE SCENARIOS, PLEASE
GO
DO THAT.
IN OTHER ONES, WHERE YOU'RE,
LIKE, I DON'T KNOW HOW TO
EXPLAIN THIS TO A USER, THEN
YOU
SHOULD DEFINITELY BE
CONSIDERING
JOBS OR BE NOT  CONSIDERING
RUNNING IT IN THE  BACKGROUND AT
ALL.
TRANSITIONING, THAT WAS THE
BATTERY SAVING AND EXECUTION
PORTION.  NOW I'M GOING TO
TRANSITION A LITTLE BIT TO  TALK
ABOUT LOCATION LIMITS.
AND THE IDEA HERE WAS TO PUT
SOME UPPER BOUNDS ON WHAT  WE'RE
SEEING IN THE  BACKGROUND AROUND
GEOFENCING,  POLLING, AND
OTHERS.
AND IT  WAS CAUSING, REALLY, A
SIGNIFICANT AMOUNT OF DRAIN.
AND THE REASON IS, LOCATION  IS
POWER-HUNGRY.  AND THERE  WERE
REALLY NO FUNCTIONAL  LIMITS ON
WHAT AN APPLICATION  COULD DO
WHEN IT'S IN THE  BACKGROUND
WITH
RESPECT TO  LOCATION.
AND SO IT WOULD END UP WITH  TWO
DIFFERENT TYPES OF  SCENARIOS.
WE'D HAVE -- MOST  OF THEM, TO
BE
HONEST, ARE  ACCIDENTAL.  ONE
BEING IS  THAT APPLICATIONS ARE
AGGRESSIVELY REQUESTING
LOCATION.  AND THIS COULD BE
BECAUSE THEY -- THEY'RE
INTERESTED IN WHERE YOU ARE,  OR
THEY HAVE A PARTICULAR USE
CASE.
BUT THE ONE THAT WAS  REALLY SAD
WAS THIS IDEA OF  LEAKS, IS THAT
IF YOU'RE  RUNNING IN THE
FOREGROUND,  YOU'RE -- SAY
YOU'RE
NAVIGATING, YOU'RE GOING TO
HAVE
A REALLY HIGH RATE OF  QUERY.
AND WHEN YOU GO TO  THE
BACKGROUND, THAT HIGH  RATE
MAYBE
ISN'T NECESSARY  ANYMORE.  AND
THE INTENTIONAL  OF THE
DEVELOPER
WAS TO  REDUCE IT.  BUT FOR ONE
REASON OR ANOTHER, MEMORY  LEAKS
OR WAKELOCK LEAKS, IT'S  STILL
RUNNING FULL BLAST.   AND WE SAW
THAT A LOT, A LOT  OF
APPLICATIONS EVERY SECOND
GETTING A LOCATION REQUEST.
THAT'S GOING TO COMPLETELY
DESTROY BATTERY.  THOSE ARE  THE
TWO AREAS WE'RE TRYING TO
TARGET
HERE.
THE IDEA NOW IS NOT TO SAY  THAT
YOU CAN'T RUN IN THE
BACKGROUND.
WE'RE TILL  ENABLING THAT .  BUT
THE IDEA  IS TO SPACE IT OUT,
ONCE  EVERY 30 MINUTES WITH A
CYCLE  OF ACCURACY WITHIN TWO
MINUTES WITHIN THOSE  30-MINUTE
UPDATES.  YOU CAN  THINK OF IT
AS
A 30-PLNT  DELAY WITH AN UPDATE
ACCURACY  OF TWO MINUTES WITHIN
THAT  30-MINUTE CYCLE.
THE SAME WITH WI-FI.  THE API
IS
A LITTLE BIT DIFFERENT .   WE
DON'T HAVE THE CONVENIENCE  FOR
SCHEDULING.  BUT IF  YOU'RE
BANGING ON THE WI-FI  QUERY,
YOU'LL KEEP GETTING  THE SAME
RESULTS IF YOU GO  TOO FAST.  WE
WON'T ACTUALLY  DO THE QUERY.
THOSE ARE THE  TWO STRATEGIES
THAT WE TAKE  IN FOR LOCATION
AND
FOR  WI-FI.
JUST TO HIGHLIGHT, THERE'S A
NUMBER OF OPTIONS HERE HIS OR
HER LOWER BATTERY IMPACTING
THAT
YOU SHOULD BE LOOKING  AT.  ONE
IS BATCHING,  GEOFENCING, AND IN
THE  COMPLETE LAST CASE AGAIN IS
SERVICE.  IF YOU ARE USING  THE
FOREGROUND SERVICE AND  THE USER
UNDERSTANDS WHAT IS  KIND OF
HAPPENING, THAT'S  REALLY
CRITICAL.  IF THEY  UNDERSTAND
WHAT'S HAPPENING,  THAT WILL
ENABLE THEM TO SAY,  YOU'RE
RUNNING IN THE  BACKGROUND.
YOU'RE  EXPENSIVE.  I GET IT,
MOVING  ON.
AND YOU'LL HAVE RELAXED
REQUIREMENTS WHEN YOU'RE IN
THAT
MODE.
SO THE OTHER THING I WANTED  TO
TALK ABOUT -- I KNOW IT  FEELS
LIKE I'M TALKING ABOUT  BATTERY,
AND THEN SUDDENLY  I'M TALKING
ABOUT ALERT  WINDOW.  I WANT TO
TAKE A  MOMENT TO THINK TALK
ABOUT  IT.
TO BE BRUTALLY HONEST WITH  YOU,
THIS WAS ONLY INTENDED  FOR
WHAT
THE NAME IS, SYSTEM  ALERT
WINDOWS.  IT WAS NEVER  REALLY
CONSCIOUSLY INTENDED  TO BE USED
THE WAY THAT IT  HAS BEEN.  BUT
WE WERE IN A  SIMPLER WORLD IN
API ONE, AND  IT WAS LEFT
PUBLIC.
AND  PEOPLE HAVE FOUND REALLY
AMAZING IDEAS AND SOLUTIONS
USING THIS API.  SO WE DON'T
WANT TO GET RID OF IT.
HOWEVER, WE DO WANT TO TRY  AND
PUT IT ON RAILS.  WHAT  WE'RE
REALLY WORRIED ABOUT  IS, MANY
APPLICATIONS  RENDERING ON TOP
OF
EACH  OTHER, CONFLICTING WITH
EACH  OTHER.  THERE'S NO
ATTRIBUTION OF WHAT
APPLICATIONS
HAPPEN TO BE  RENDERING AT ANY
POINT IN  TIME.
AND SO THE IDEA WAS THAT CAN  WE
ADD SOME LAYERING?  CAN WE  ADD
SOME ATTRIBUTION WITHIN  THE
MODEL?  AND THAT'S WHAT  WE DID
WITH THE APPLICATION  OVERLAY.
SO THE IDEA HERE IS, WITH AN
APP
OVERLAY, IS THE USER CAN  NOW
MANAGE WHAT IS FLOATING  ABOVE
THE -- THEIR  APPLICATION
ACTIVITY.  IT'S  Z-ORDERED
PROPERLY UNTO  THEMSELVES, AND
TO
SYSTEM UI  AND TO THE
APPLICATION
BELOW.   AND IT WILL
AUTOMATICALLY  SHOW A FOREGROUND
NOTIFICATION IN THE
NOTIFICATION
MENU, SO THE  USER IS AWARE IF
THEY'RE IN  MULTIPLE
APPLICATIONS
SIMULTANEOUSLY USING THIS
FEATURE.
THIS WAY, IF THEY SEE IT,
THEY'RE UNHAPPY WITH IT, THEY
CAN GO TO THE APPLICATION,
CONTROL THE SETTINGS IF THEY
WANT.  YOU SHOULD ALWAYS MAKE
SURE YOUR USERS ARE AWARE OF
USING THIS, BECAUSE IT CAN BE
KIND OF SURPRISING IF IT
DOESN'T
HAPPEN.
AND THE OTHER THING THAT WE
CHANGED WAS FOR TARGETING ON  O
IS, IF YOU ARE NOW USING  THIS
NEW OVERLAY TYPE, YOU  WILL THEN
SEE -- SIT ABOVE  THE LEGACY
VIEWS.  SO THIS IS  MAYBE YOUR
INCENTIVE TO ADOPT  A NEW MODEL,
IS ONCE YOU'RE  USING THAT,
EVERYBODY WILL BE  PROPERLY
Z-ORDERED IN A KIND  OF LRU
FASHION.   AND THEN  YOU'LL --
BELOW SYSTEM UI,  BUT ABOVE
THINGS LIKE THE  KEYBOARD AND
OTHER SYSTEM UI  COMPONENTS.
SO NOW I WANT TO TRANSITION A
LITTLE BIT ABOUT TALKING  ABOUT
HOW WE'RE GOING TO  IMPROVE THE
SYSTEM WITH DATA.   AND, YOU
KNOW, I DON'T MEAN  TO BLAME
ANYONE, 'CAUSE IT'S  NOT.
THAT'S
NOT MY INTENT.   BUT IT'S REALLY
A STORY ABOUT  APPLICATIONS.
AND
THAT  PHONES ARE AMAZING, AND
YOU
CAN DO SO MANY THINGS WITH  THIS
PORTABLE COMPUTING  DEVICE.
HOWEVER, WE HAVE  RESOURCE
SCARCITY, MOSTLY IN  THE FRAME
OF
BATTERY.
AND THE QUESTION THAT COMES  UP,
WELL, THEN HOW DO WE  BALANCE
THIS?
AND THE BIG THING THAT WE
REALIZED -- AND YOU MIGHT BE
THINKING AT YOUR SEAT, YEAH,
NO,
DUH, NO.
THERE ISN'T VERY GREAT  TOOLING
UP UNTIL RECENTLY TO  HELP
DEVELOPERS UNDERSTAND  THEIR
IMPACT.  WHEN WE  REACHED OUT
INTERNALLY EVEN  AT GOOGLE, WE
WOULD FINE THEY  DIDN'T REALIZE
THEY WERE  DOING IT.  SO THAT
KIND OF  BROUGHT AROUND A NUMBER
OF  THOUGHTS THAT I'LL GET  INTO
THE OTHER ONE IS THIS KIND OF
TRAGEDY OF THE COMMONS IN  THAT
YOU HAVE SO MANY  APPLICATIONS
ON
YOUR PHONE.   AND IF ANY OF
THOSE
APPLICATIONS SAY STICK A
WAKELOCK, YOU ONLY NEED ONE  TO
DO IT AND THE COST IS NOW  YOUR
CPU IS UNABLE TO GO TO  SLEEP.
AND YOU'LL HAVE A  VERY
PRECIPITOUS DRAIN ON  YOUR
BATTERY OVER TIME.
AND WHEN YOU HAVE HUNDREDS OF
APPS AND ONLY ONE NEEDS TO  MAKE
A MISTAKE, YOU'RE PRETTY  MUCH
GUARANTEED TO HAVE A BAD  TIME.
AND SO WHAT WE STARTED  LOOKING
AT IS HOW CAN WE GET  TO A POINT
OF SUSTAINING  PERFORMANCE,
INTRODUCING  ACCURATE
MEASUREMENTS FOR  DEVELOPERS AND
BRINGING ON  LINE NEW
DASHBOARDS.
SO LET'S DIG IN A LITTLE BIT
INTO WHAT THESE ARE.  AND
THERE'S A TALK ON BAD
BEHAVIORS,
IT WAS EARLIER IN  THE DAY.  IF
YOU HAVEN'T SEEN  IT, PLEASE GO
HOP ON YOUTUBE  AND GO TRACH AT
TAKE A LOOK A LOOK AT  IT.  THE
GUYS WHO PRESENTED  IT ARE HERE
IN FRONT, STARING  AT ME.  THANK
YOU.
THE BIG ONE HERE IS, WE'RE
LOOKING FOR EGREGIOUS  BEHAVIOR
THAT WE CAN ALL  AGREE ON.  SO A
GOOD EXAMPLE  OF THIS IS
WAKELOCKS.  IS IF  YOU ASK A
DEVELOPER, YOU WERE  HOLDING A
WAKELOCK FOR SIX  HOURS
STRAIGHT.
YOU WERE IN  FOUR ROUNDS AND THE
USER  WASN'T -- IN THE
FOREGROUND
AND THE USER WASN'T  INTERACTING
WITH YOUR  APPLICATION.  AND
PRETTY MUCH  EVERYBODY SAYS I
HAVEN'T HAVE  BEEN DOING THAT.
THE TRICK  WAS, THERE WASN'T
REALLY GOT  TO INSTRUMENTATION
TO
HELP  YOU UNDERSTAND THAT WAS
HAPPENING.  AND THAT'S WHERE
THE
PLAY CONSOLE IS COMING  INTO ITS
OWN AND BRINGING OUT  THESE
FEATURES SO YOU CAN SEE  THESE
TYPE OF SITUATIONS THAT  ARE
HAPPENING.
OTHER BIG ONE HAS BEEN REALLY
HE
IS VEERING JANKING FRAMES,  SO
FROZEN FRAMES, FRAMES THAT  DAK
OVER 700 MILLISECONDS TO  RUN.
ALSO REALLY HARD TO  FIGURE OUT
WHERE IN YOUR  APPLICATION
THEY'RE OCCURRING  AND EVEN IF
THEY'RE OCCURRING  AND IF THEY
ARE, WHAT DRISES  THEY'RE
OCCURRING ON.
THE LAST WAS CRASH LOOPING  AND
CRASH DATES.
THE OTHER IS LOOKING AT THE  OS
SIDE.  NO THE TO SAY THAT
EVERYTHING IS ABOUT APPS.   IT'S
NOT.   WE HAVE TO BRING  A LEVEL
OF SANITY ONTO THE  OPERATING
SYSTEM.  ONE GOOD  EXAMPLE WAS
THE IMPROVEMENTS  WE MADE ON
BOOT
TIME AND  LOOKING HARD AT HOW
THE
OS IS  STRUCTURED .  AND THE
OTHER  ONE IS ALSO GOING TO BE
STARTING TO LOOK AT I/O
THROUGHPUT, HOW MANY SCANS  ARE
HAPPENING IN THE  BACKGROUND IN
DIFFERENT  PARAMETERS.  AND ALL
THESE  WILL START COMING OUT AND
BEING AVAILABLE FOR YOU GUYS
OVER THE COMING YEARS.
JUST TO GIVE YOU AN EXAMPLE  OF
THIS, I HAVE A SELECTION    OF
GOOGLE APPS.  I HAVE  HIDDEN THE
NAMES TO PROTECT  THE INNOCENT,
SLASH, GUILTY.
BUT WHAT I HAVE PUT UP THERE  IS
A HASH LINE.  AND THE HASH  LINE
IS EFFECTIVELY THE  THRESHOLD
THAT YOU'RE GOING  TO SEE OF
WHEN
WE SAY AN  APPLICATION HAS
CROSSED INTO  THE TERRITORY OF
BAD  BEHAVIOR.
SO YOU CAN SEE THE MAJORITY  OF
APPLICATIONS IN THIS CROSS
SECTION.  THESE ARE ALL MAJOR
GOOGLE APPS.  MOST OF THEM  ARE
QUITE GOOD.  AND THERE'S  A FEW
OUTLIERS THAT ARE  HAVING ISSUES
WHERE A  WAKELOCK IS GETTING
STUCK IN  THEIR APPLICATIONS.
AND YOU  CAN SEE THE PERCENTAGES
HERE,  THAT THEY LOOK SMALL, BUT
WHEN YOU SEE THESE NUMBERS  OF,
LIKE, HALF A PERCENT  HERE, ONE
PERCENT THERE,  THOSE ARE JUST
ONE APP.  AND  AS I MENTIONED
BEFORE, ONLY  ONE APP NEEDS TO
MAKE THIS  MISTAKE FOR YOUR
ENTIRE  DEVICE TO SUFFER.
MULTIPLE  THAT BY THE HUNDRED
APPS.  IF  YOU WORK OUT THE
RATIO,  YOU'RE GOING TO HAVE A
BAD  TIME.
THE NEXT ONE HERE, LET'S TALK
ABOUT FOREGROUND CRASHES AND
HELPING OUR DEVELOPERS
UNDERSTAND REPEAT OFFENDERS,
RAPID CRASHING IN A CYCLE.
WE GENERALLY HAD GOOD
DOCUMENTATION TO UNDERSTAND  IF
YOU CRASH, BUT NOT  REPEATED
CRASHES VERSUS  SPORADIC.  DO I
HAVE A  POPULATION OF 5%
CRASHING
REALLY EXTREMELY OR DOES IT
SPREAD ACROSS THE POPULATION
95%.
THE VERY LAST ONE  HERE IS
ABOUT
FROZEN FRAME RATES.   YOU CAN
SEE
ANOTHER EXAMPLE  OF MOST
APPLICATIONS ARE  ACTUALLY DOING
PRETTY GOOD.   AND IN THIS CASE,
THERE WAS  ONE WHO WAS A LITTLE
NOT AS  GOOD.  AND WHEN WE
PASSED
THIS DATA ALONG TO THE TEAM,
THEY'RE LIKE, CRAP.  NOT  THEIR
INTENT, OBVIOUSLY.
BUT IT REALLY MAKES THE
EXPERIENCE ON THE DEVICE NOT
REALLY THAT FANTASTIC.
ESPECIALLY THE APPLICATION.   IT
MAKES THE USER GO, IS MY  DEVICE
WRONG?  IS THE APP  BAD?  WHAT'S
HAPPENING?
SO GIVING THIS INFORMATION  BACK
TO DEVELOPERS, THEY'RE  ABLE TO
START REMEDYING THESE  PROBLEMS
AND SOLVING THEM.
SO THE BIG THING HERE IS
VISIBILITY.  AND THIS IS
VISIBILITY BOTH FOR YOU GUYS  AS
WELL AS FOR THE USER ON  THEIR
DEVICE.
SO NEW DEVELOPER TOOLS, WE'RE
ALSO DOING A LOT OF OUTREACH
BOTH INTERNALLY AND  EXTERNALLY
WITH BIZDEV, TO  REACH OUT TO
TEAMS AND INFORM  THEM, HEY, DO
YOU KNOW THIS  IS HAPPENING ON
YOUR APPS?   IN MANY CASES WE
DON'T, AND  IT'S A QUICK FIX,
ESPECIALLY  WITH WAKELOCKS.
AND THE LAST ONE HERE IS
BATTERY SETTINGS IN THE PLAY
STORE.  AND I'LL TALK A  LITTLE
BIT ABOUT THAT, AND  OEM
DASHBOARDS.  WE ALSO WANT  TO
GET
THIS DATA OVER TO  OEMs SO THEY
CAN SEE WHAT  IS GOING ON AND
THEY CAN SEE  WHAT DEVICES ARE
INTRINSICALLY GOOD AND YOU  HAVE
A STRONG BASE TO WORK  ON, THAT
YOU'RE NOT SEEING  JANK BECAUSE
OF THE DEVICE  FREAKING OUT, BUT
YOU'RE  HAVING A GOOD EXPERIENCE
AND  THAT YOU HAVE THE ABILITY
TO
CONTROL YOUR OWN DESTINY.
SO BATTERY MENU ON HERE IS
ABOUT -- THIS IS THE NEW O
BATTERY MENU.  AND IT WAS
REDESIGNED WITH THE IDEA OF
BEING ACTIONABLE FOR USERS.   WE
WANTED TO MAKE SURE THAT  IF YOU
GO TO THIS MENU, YOU  DON'T GO,
OKAY, I SEE GOOGLE  PLAY
SERVICES, THE  SETTINGS --
ANDROID OS, AND  SCREEN.
YOU'RE,
LIKE, WHAT  AM I SUPPOSED TO
THINK IF I  SEE THIS?  THERE'S
REALLY  NOTHING ACTIONABLE HERE.
AND WHILE IT WAS TECHNICALLY
ACCURATE, IT WASN'T  NECESSARILY
USEFUL TO WHAT  YOU'RE TRYING TO
DO, IS TO  UNDERSTAND WHAT
APPLICATIONS  ARE IMPACTING YOUR
BATTERY  LIFE.
SO THIS IS HOW WE  RESTRUCTURED
IT.  AND WE ALSO  INCLUDED,
THOUGH, YOUR  FOREGROUND
INTERACTION WITH  THOSE
APPLICATIONS.  AND THIS  IS
SOMETHING THAT HAPPENS  REALLY
QUITE COMMONLY.  AND  I'LL GIVE
YOU JUST A QUICK AN  ANY DOTE
FROM INTERNALLY.
I HAD A BUCK FILED TO BUG FILED
TO ME,  IT WAS ABOUT ANDROID
BATTERY  LIFE, IT'S HORRIBLE.  I
DON'T  MAKE IT PAST 3:00, WHAT'S
GOING ON?
WHAT HAPPENED ON THEIR DEVICE
WAS THEY WERE PLAYING POKEMON
GO
FOR TWO HOURS ON THURSDAY  AT
1:00 P.M.
AND I WAS -- AND MY REPLY  WAS,
THAT'S PRETTY AMAZING  THAT YOU
GOT THIS MUCH  BATTERY LIFE OUT
OF POKEMON  GO ON YOUR PHONE.
ALSO, IT  WAS THURSDAY AT 1:00
P.M.,  GOOGLER.
BUT, YOU KNOW, THE THING WAS
THAT I TOOK AWAY WAS, THEY
DIDN'T REALIZE THEY PLAYED IT
THAT LONG.  AND SO THAT WAS
HAPPENING QUITE OFTEN.  YOU'D
SEE AN APP WITH BATTERY  DRAIN,
BUT YOU DON'T  NECESSARILY
RECOGNIZE IT WAS  BECAUSE, OH, I
USED MY PHONE,  LIKE, AN EXTRA
HOUR TODAY.   AND IT'S HARD TO
REMEMBER,  HOW LONG DID I REALLY
HAVE  THE SCREEN ON.  SO THAT'S
HOW  WE STRUCTURE BATTERY, IS TO
HELP INFORM YOU OF HOW LONG
YOU'RE USING THE DEVICE, HOW
LONG YOU'RE USING DIFFERENT
APPLICATIONS, AND SO THAT YOU
CAN MAKE THIS COMPARISON OF
WHAT
IS HAPPENING IN THE  APPS.
WE DON'T WANT TO PASS  JUDGMENT
ON AN APPLICATION  BEING GOOD OR
BAD.  IT'S NOT  NECESSARILY A
BAD
THING IF AN  APP USES 20% OF
YOUR
BATTERY.   IF YOU WERE LIVE
STREAMING AN  EVENT, THAT'S
PRETTY DECENT,  ESPECIALLY IF IT
WAS FOR AN  HOUR OR TWO.  SO
WE'RE NOT  TRYING TO SAY
INTRINSICALLY  THINGS ARE BAD IF
THEY'RE  HIGH.  BUT WE WANT TO
ADD  SOME VISIBILITY SO A USER
CAN  SEE THIS IS AN APP I DIDN'T
TAKING UP 5% OF MY  BATTERY?
AND
THOSE QUESTIONS  STARTED
HAPPENING ON THE  USERS' PART
AND
GIVING YOU  GUYS FEEDBACK  AND
YOU CAN  SEE THE SAME DATA IN
THE
PLAY  PLAY  CONSOLE.
SO THIS IS WHERE I WILL
TRANSITION TO TALKING A  LITTLE
BIT ABOUT THE FUTURE,  SO YOU
CAN
KIND OF GET AN  IDEA OF WHERE
WE'RE GOING.
THIS IS ALSO MY SUGGESTION TO
REALLY LOOK AT BACKGROUND
LIMITS, TO LOOK AT TARGETING  O,
TO TRANSITIONING AWAY FROM
BACKGROUND SERVICES TO JOBS,
ALARMS, GCM, ET CETERA.
AND THE THING IS, WE WANT TO
GET
TO THIS AMAZING BATTERY  LIFE
THAT I STARTED OUT WITH,
MULTI-DAY BATTERY LIFE.  AND  TO
DO THAT, THERE'S A FEW  THINGS
WE'RE GOING TO HAVE TO  CHANGE,
IF YOU WILL.  BUT I  WANT TO
TALK
ABOUT SOME  PRINCIPLES.
ONE IS, WE FUNDAMENTALLY
BELIEVE
APPLICATIONS SHOULD  BE ABLE TO
RUN IN THE  BACKGROUND.  WE WANT
MUCH  MORE WELL-DEFINED RULES
ABOUT  WHEN APPLICATIONS ARE
ABLE
TO  RUN.
TODAY, YOU CAN SEE A NUMBER  OF
OEMs TAKING STRATEGIES,  TRYING
TO SOLVE THIS PROBLEM
INDEPENDENTLY.  AND IT  BECOMES
REALLY DIFFICULT FOR  DEVELOPERS
TO DEAL WITH THAT  WORLD WHEN
YOU
DON'T  NECESSARILY KNOW WHAT THE
RULES ARE.  SO WE WANT TO GET  A
LOT CHRIS PER THERE.
WE ALSO WANT USERS TO BETTER
UNDERSTAND BATTERY IMPACT.   YOU
CAN ARGUE MY PREVIOUS
STATEMENTS
ABOUT THE SETTINGS  MENU, WHAT,
THE USER HAS TO  DO MATH IN
THEIR
HEAD ABOUT  HOW MUCH BATTERY IT
USED?   AND I AGREE WITH YOU
COMPLETELY .  WE WANT TO GET  TO
A BETTER PLACE WHERE IT'S  MUCH
EASIER FOR A USER TO  UNDERSTAND
WHAT'S HAPPENING.
AND WE WANT TO THEN ENABLE A
USER WHO SAYS, I'M NOT OKAY
WITH
THIS.  AND IF THE APPLES
DOESN'T
OFFER THE CONTROL, TO  GIVE THEM
ANOTHER OPTION   AT
UNINSTALLING
THE APPLICATION,  SOMETHING
OTHER
THAN JUST THE  NUCLEAR OPTION.
THEN THE LAST ONE IS, WE  REALLY
WANT THIS IDEA OF  CONSISTENT
DEVICE  PERFORMANCE, YOU
SHOULDN'T BE  WORRYING, WILL MY
DEVICE MAKE  IT THROUGH THE DAY,
WILL IT  BE ABLE TO MAKE IT HOME
UNTIL  I GET ON THE CHARGER.  WE
WANT IT TO BE SOMETHING
RELIABLE.
ALL THESE USE CASES THAT  WE'RE
DOING ON PHONES AND ALL  THE
PROPERTIES FROM GOOGLE  AND ALL
THE PROPERTIES THAT  YOU'RE
MAKING AS APP  DEVELOPERS, YOU
CAN'T REALLY  RELY ON THIS STUFF
UNLESS YOU  KNOW YOUR PHONE'S
GOING TO BE  THERE.  AND SO
THAT'S REALLY  THE UNDERPINNING
FOR THIS  GENERAL STRATEGY.
AND SO HOW DO WE GET THERE?
SO THERE'S THREE KIND OF BIG
TIERS.  WE HAVE TO CONSIDER
WHAT
IS THE API CONTRACT?  WE  DON'T
WANT TO BREAK THE  PROMISES WE
MAKE TO YOU.
HOWEVER, WE DO MAKE A LOT OF
PROMISES THAT WE LATER  REGRET.
AND SO AN EXAMPLE OF  THIS IS A
WAKELOCK.  IF YOU  WERE TO
GENERALLY DESCRIBE A  WAKELOCK,
YOU'RE SAYING,  WE'VE GIVEN THE
APPLICATION -- ANY  APPLICATION
CAN TELL THE OS,  STAY AWAKE
UNTIL I SAY TO GO  TO SLEEP,
INDEFINITELY.  AND  WHEN YOU
GIVE
THAT LEVEL OF  CONTROL AND
THERE'S NOT  REALLY A WAY TO
CLOSE THE  LOOP, YOU END UP WITH
VARYING  BATTERY LIFE.
SO WE HAVE TO FIGURE OUT,  THEN,
WHAT IS THE RIGHT  PROMISE TO
MAKE TO A  DEVELOPER AND WHAT IS
THE  RANGE OF THAT PROMISE THAT
WE  SHOULD BE GIVING TO ENABLE
THE USE CASES BUT MAKE SURE
THAT
THE OS CAN BE RESPONSIVE  IN THE
FACE OF
ADVERSITY OR
APPLICATIONS TAKING ADVANTAGE
OF
THE PROMISE THAT'S BEING  MADE.
THE OTHER IS THE ATTRIBUTION  I
MENTIONED BEFORE AND THE
CONTROLS THAT THE USER CAN  TAKE
ADVANTAGE OF THIS STUFF.
TOGETHER, THE THREE OF THESE
THINGS SHOULD GIVE US A MUCH
BETTER STRUCTURE.
AND SO THIS IS -- ALL OF THIS
IS, AGAIN, LIKE YOU SEE THIS
LITTLE EXCITING BADGE ABOUT
PENDING REVIEW ON THERE.   THESE
ARE REALLY JUST IDEAS  TO
ARTICULATE HOW WE'RE
APPROACHING
THE PROBLEM.   BECAUSE WE KNOW
IT'S A BIG  CHANGE.  AND SO
WE'RE
TRYING  TO BROADCAST THIS CHANGE
ADVANTAGE OF IT.  YOU CAN  START
MOVING OVER TO  BACKGROUND
LIMITS
AND  TARGETING NODE NOW SO THAT
YOU'RE NOT GOING TO HAVE A  BAD
TIME LATER ON.
AND SO SOME OF THESE THINGS  IS
WE NEED TO LOOK AT MORE  LIMITS
ON BACKGROUND  SCANNING.  WE --
WE HAVE TO  ADJUST THE LIMITS
THAT WE'RE  DOING.  WE HAVEN'T
REALLY  GOTTEN AROUND TO
BLUETOOTH  YET.  WE'RE ALSO
LOOKING AT  APPLICATIONS
LISTENING TO  OTHER EVENTS ON
THE
DEVICE  AND WHETHER THOSE THINGS
SHOULD BE HAPPENING OR NOT.
A BIG ONE HERE IS DEFERRING
WORK.  WE WANT THE OS TO HAVE
MORE FLEXIBILITY TO HAVE
DISCRETION ABOUT WHEN JOBS  RUN.
WHEN IT'S ALL  SERVICES-BASED,
THE OS HAS  REALLY NO CONTROL.
IF THE  SINGLE LARGEST INSTALLED
BASE  APPLICATION MAKES A
UNILATERAL DECISION TO  INCREASE
WAKELOCK TIME, THE  OS TODAY AND
THE USER IS  POWERLESS TO DO
ANYTHING  ABOUT IT.  SO THAT'S
WHY  WE'RE LOOKING TO MAKE THESE
TRANSITIONS.  AND THE BALANCE
SHOULD BE NOW USERS ARE MORE  IN
THE DRIVER'S SEAT ABOUT  WHAT
FEATURES THE  APPLICATION'S
GIVING AND  WHETHER THE USER
FINDS VALUE  IN THOSE FEATURES
RUNNING IN  THE BACKGROUND.  AND
THEN  THEY CAN ARTICULATE THAT.
THE DEFAULTS FOR ALL OF THESE
THINGS IS ON, AND THE MODEL  YOU
CAN THINK OF, AS LONG AS  YOU'RE
COOL, THE OS IS COOL  AND
EVERYBODY WILL BE COOL  AND IT'S
GREAT .  AND IF IN  THIS
SCENARIO, THOUGH,  APPLICATIONS
START GETTING  AGGRESSIVE,
BATTERY STARTS  GETTING HIGH,
SCANNING RATES  START GETTING
HIGHER, WE MAY  START INFORMING
THE USER,  HEY, THIS STUFF IS
KIND OF  HEAVY ON THE BATTERY,
DO
YOU  WANT IT TO RUN IN THE
BACKGROUND?  AND THEN THEY  CAN
ARTICULATE THAT BACK TO  THE OS.
AND THEN WE CAN, YOU  KNOW,
BEGIN
HAVING A CONTROL  SURFACE FOR
HOW
WE MANAGE  INDIVIDUAL
APPLICATIONS.  AND  SO THEN THE
USER CAN SAY,  THESE TEN APPS I
CARE ABOUT A  LOT.  THESE OTHER
APPS, NOT  SO MUCH.  WE'RE NOT
SUGGEST  THAT WE NEED TO HAVE A
MICRO  MANAGING MENU.  THAT'S
NOT
THE DESIRE.  BUT USING THINGS
LIKE HOW USERS ARE  INTERACTING
WITH THE  APPLICATION, HOW OFTEN
ARE  THEY INTERACTING WITH GCM
APPLICATIONS WHEN THE IS 101  UP
.  HOW OFTEN DO THEY  INTERACT
WITH -- HOW THE OS  SHOULD DOLE
OUT ITS LIMITED  RESOURCES,
NAMELY BATTERY.
THE LAST ONE IS WE HAVE TO  BEEF
UP THE IDEA OF  FOREGROUND
SURFACE -- HOW  DOES THAT NOT
TURN INTO ALL  THE APPLICATIONS
RUSHING TO  THE EXITS OF
FOREGROUND  SERVICE AND THEN
WE'RE BACK  IN THE SAME MESS
THAT
WE ARE  NOW WITH NO CONTROL
SURFACE  AGAIN.
AND WE WANT TO FIND A
BALANCE SO THAT APPLICATIONS
CAN GENERALLY DO EVERYTHING
THEY NEED AND IN THE
EXTREMES, THE USER IS ABLE TO
ARTICULATE APPROVAL FOR THESE
EXTREME SITUATIONS.  AND
WE'RE HOPING THAT'S GOING TO
RESULT IN A MUCH MORE STABLE,
MUCH MORE RELIABLE DEVICE IN
THE LONG RUN.  AND SO
HOPEFULLY THAT GIVES YOU A
BIT OF INSIGHT ABOUT HOW
WE'RE APPROACHING ANDROID
HEALTH AND MOSTLY BATTERY
LIFE AND RESOURCE CONTENTION.
SO -- OH, I FORGOT A SLIDE.
BUT THE IDEA OF THE LAST ONE
WAS ATTRIBUTION AND VALUE.
SO WE WANT TO REALLY MAKE
THAT IDENTIFIED, AND I
ALREADY TALKED ABOUT THE
POINTS.  I WON'T BORE YOU
REPEATING IT.
AND THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR
THE -- FOR YOUR TIME.
[ APPLAUSE ]